Previously on Movamex Und das ist ein Sennheiser HMI 26.
Kann ich?
Ja, du willst das Mikrofon wechseln?
Also das Ding ist halt...
Heute ist wieder richtig geiles Programm für unsere Hörer. So Denis, können wir dich besser hören darüber?
Also zum Musikern wärs besser, weil das halt nicht so einen tiefen Bass hat, das andere Mikro.
Aber das Mikrofon klingt doch blecherner, findest du nicht auch?
Das ist klarer halt. Also es ist nicht blechender, sondern viel deutlicher als vorher.
Schlem, Schlem, Schlem.
Finde ich das wirklich klarer?
Aber guck mal, eins ist ja so, hier merkt man oft noch mal diese Farbtemperatur-Geschichten, dass wenn man sich an eine Farbtemperatur gewöhnt hat, dann ist die andere Farbe gleich zu viel.
Ich setze jetzt immer das Teil auch noch mal auf und dann hast du ja den Unterschied zu mir.
Aber das Mikrofon klingt doch blecherner, findest du nicht auch?
Also es ist weniger Bass drin.
Ich dachte, ich hätte so eine Elmer Gunn Stimme.
Sie können sowieso das gar nicht beurteilen, weil die kennen meine echte Stimme ja gar nicht.
Elmer Gunn Stimme war früher im Fernsehen.
Ach so, der!
Tim, so wird das nie was. Ich steig hier aus, ich mach hier nicht mehr mit.
Ich hab keinen Bock mehr auf dir, das ist aber zu laufend.
Ich würde mich dankbar für Ihr Feedback von den Hörern, wenn ihr das jetzt hier hört, wie ihr das so empfindet.
Ja und für mich war das jetzt quasi die letzte Sendung.
Das ist hier wieder los.
Und ab nächste Woche dann bei Mobile Android.
Arsch!
Tim, nimm die Waffe weg.
Ich sag Arsch!
Das wär dann auch geklärt. Sprüche machen hier. Soweit kommt es noch. So, da sind wir und er.
Echt?
Ja, jetzt sind wir richtig dabei online, im Internet mal gucken, wie das hier so mit dem DSL hält und so. Dazu vielleicht später mehr, wenn ihr uns dann überhaupt noch hört.
Seid ihr noch alle da?
Wir sollen uns ja nicht so viel über Streams unterhalten, während sie nicht laufen, weil das ist ja langweilig für die Leute, die das später hören. Jeder hat ja irgendwas zu meckern. Ihr wisst ja jetzt, was passiert, wenn gemeckert wird, ne? So, nachdem wir das dann mal geklärt hätten, können wir ja mal hier die Runde begrüßen. In neuer Besetzung, mit Huckel. Nicht ganz so neu, oder?
Nein, ich fühle mich auf jeden Fall ganz frisch jetzt auch.
Frisch erneuert, rund erneuert in 2013.
Genau, verurlaubt und erholt und verurknallt auch.
Die Ohren ein bisschen belastet von dem neuen Speaker-Kabinett.
Genau, auch. Aber alles in allem frisch und dynamisch am Berg.
Ja, Denis setzt leider aus, er meint, er habe die Kongressgrippe. Das bringt mich wieder in die großartige Situation, der Einzige zu sein, der hier auf dem Kongress war, nachdem Denis ja meinte, er führe nicht hin, aber dann natürlich doch da war, außer dir natürlich. Du warst wahrscheinlich nur mental anwesend, vielleicht noch nicht mal.
In Gedanken so ein bisschen, zwischendurch mal. Ich habe Tweets gelesen, ja.
Du hast Tweets gelesen.
Und dass du dich mal nicht übernimmst. So, dann haben wir Roddy wieder heimgeholt, aus den bösen USA. Da war es wie?
Sehr regnerisch.
Sehr regnerisch. Na gut, dass du jetzt wieder in Berlin bist.
Nee, nee, nee, also kein Vergleich zu dem, wie es da gerade da draußen ist, sondern wirklich so, man hatte so das Gefühl, ich bin jetzt in den Tropen, aber nur kälter. Nee, nee, Sandy nicht, Sandy war schon durch.
Ja, und dann haben wir uns jetzt hier Verstärkung wieder reingeholt. Unser Joker, der heutigen Sendung, Clemens.
Ja, hallo.
Wir ziehen den Joker. Wir spielen eine heiße Karte hier. Ist ja nicht dein erster Auftritt, hier. Was war denn eigentlich die Sendung, wo du das erste Mal dabei warst?
Internet im Festnetz.
Nein, in den 90ern.
Ach so, bei Mobile-Max.
Ja, das ist jetzt auch erst so fünf, sechs Folgen hier, oder?
Genau. Und Clemens füllt hier die Lücke und so haben wir dann hier wieder sozusagen Vollbesetzung hergestellt, auch wenn Denis gerade nicht dabei ist.
Du musst dann immer um Android reden, das ist dir schon klar.
Nee, aktuell eigentlich, also naja. Du musst vor allem die gegensätzliche Position zu Tim haben, sonst funktioniert das nicht.
Ja, so, mit der Besetzung starten wir hier ins neue Jahr.
Und damit gleich zu meiner ersten Frage, wo ist die Quotenfrau?
Wo ist die Quotenfrau? Ja, das ist ein guter Punkt. Ich hab mich ja eigentlich auch gerade der Initiative angeschlossen. Ich hab übrigens gerade auch noch mal parallel die Team-Seite aktualisiert. Da musst du mir jetzt erstmal beantworten, was eigentlich dein erster Mac war, Clemens. Das weiß ich nämlich gar nicht.
Mein allererster Mac war erstaunlicherweise ein Mac Mini, ein PowerPC Mac Mini, First Generation. So, so.
Eigentlich hätte ich bei meinem ersten Mac ja sagen müssen, das war ein Mac-Emulator für einen Amiga.
Nee, geht schon um Hardware.
Ich fand ja so geil an dem Emulator, man hat diesen Amiga gestartet und die Diskettenlaufwerke klangen nach Amiga und dann hast du diesen Mac-Emulator gestartet und dann klangen die Diskettenlaufwerke nach Mac. Und das fand ich total faszinierend jedes Mal wieder.
Ja, die hatten doch auch ein anderes Aufzeichnungsverfahren. Also ein anderes, anders wir schieben die Köpfe durch die Gegendverfahren. Wenn du das wieder nachbaust, dann... Ja, aber so ein Ding hatte ich auch mal ganz früher, aber das ist irgendwie, das war irgendwie...
Ja, diese Amiga-Laufwerke waren immer so schrabbel, schrabbel, schrabbel und die Mac-Laufwerke, die waren so ein so ein wohliges Brumm, Brumm, Brumm, Brumm.
Ich hatte nie ein Amiga. Ich hab damals mit Atari, die gab's, da gab's aber auch so Mac-Emulatoren und so Zeugs.
Ja, ich bin zu leise.
Ich werde hier nachreguliert. Und der Chef, der jetzt übrigens, kann man für die Hörer mal sagen, der jetzt auf einem Ledersessel sitzt.
Ja, wie sie es gehört.
Nicht so wie wir Fußvolk hier. Der Chef im Ledersessel soll mal hier was nachregulieren.
Also der erste Mac Mini Januar 2005, falls du suchst.
Ich kann dich auch lauter machen, so ist nicht.
Nö, ich höre mich gut, aber hier und welcher.
Ja, die erzählen immer irgendwas, das musst du jetzt nicht. Die Philosophieren jetzt hier, wer mehr Bass hat und so weiter, das ist einfach alles gefühlt.
Tim, hast du?
Übrigens, wir wollten dir noch nachschicken. Ich war auch nicht auf dem Kongress, aber ich habe ihn regelmit verfolgt aus Stockholm. Dank der hervorragend laufenden Streams. Muss man an dieser Stelle mal sagen. Also, sehr gut, sehr gute Arbeit.
Ja, bei denen hat es geklappt.
Da kann man, also das, wieso, bei wem denn nicht?
Ach, nix.
Alles in Ordnung.
Ach, du meinst hier? Ja, das ist ein anderes Thema. Das ist ein anderes Thema.
Aber schieb es nicht aufs DSL. Ich hab die ganze Zeit einen Ping zu laufen auf V4 und V6 und sage euch, ich hab noch kein Paket verloren.
Ja, ich kann ja auch sagen, dass es, ich kann dir aber sofort zeigen, was das Problem ist, es sei denn, es hat sich magisch jetzt hier unter meinem Arsch geändert, aber du bist ja hier mit diesem, Du hast mir das Bild ja schon geschickt, mit diesem Daten da vertraut, ne? Hier, Spektrum.
Hm, hier fehlt der Unten-Ecke. Der wird halt hinten woanders aufgefüllt. Aber geht ja noch was, du hast ja noch ein bisschen Reserve.
Die Telekom meinte, das wäre das Problem.
Problem ist, wenn sich das dramatisch verändert, dann gibt es einen Riesing. Das Modem ist darauf geeicht, wenn du jetzt auch mal guckst, auf deiner Fritzbox, diese Dinger wabern leicht hin und her. Wenn du das eine Weile beobachtest, deswegen haben sie in der neuen Version auch dieses Minimum und Maximum-Feld da unten. Das haben diese komischen orange Rand. Diese Spektrum bewegen sich. Wenn die sich über einen gewissen Level hinaus bewegen, denkt sich das Modem, Moment mal, lass uns mal nochmal neu anfangen.
Verstehe.
Und das haut dir die Verbindung weg.
Das sieht bisher ganz gut aus.
Ja, bisher sieht es betrieblichter aus.
Gut. Vielleicht hat sich ja auch irgendwas mit der neuen Version hier verbessert.
Ich meine 2013.
Scheint sehr unterschiedliche Auffassungen zu geben, was bei, wie beliebt die Fritzbox bei der Telekom eigentlich wirklich ist, also bei den Technikern. Zum Beispiel kannst du hier keinen, also es wurde ja ein Test durchgeführt von außen. So ein Leitungstest, der letztendlich auf das gleiche Ergebnis kam wie die Fritzbox, aber ich wollte es ja so und dazu habe ich extra so ein DSL-Modem zugeschickt bekommen. Dass halt so ein Telekom, wissen schon, ein Speedport Tralala-Gerät sein musste, damit es eben...
Das ist dasselbe in grün, das ist plus eins, wo Sie draufgucken können aus der Ferne. Das ist übrigens genau der Grund, warum ich immer noch Fritzboxen betreibe, weil ich gerne Herr meines eigenen Equipments bin und nicht so gerne möchte, dass nur die Telekom auf meinen Modem draufgucken kann. Sondern das mag ich dann doch lieber gerne selber tun. Und deswegen aus genau demselben Grunde bloß exakt 180 Grad verdreht, schickt die Telekom gerne ihre eigenen Dinger raus, damit sie nämlich Herr der ganzen Geschichte sind. Und übrigens auch die ganzen Alices und so was. Wenn du jetzt heutzutage anrufst, wenn du einen Alice-Anschluss hast und rufst an, hast du irgendeine Störung, dann sagen die, ja, wie sind denn die Lampen auf ihren Modem? Und dann sagst du, wie mein Modem? Ich hab ne Fritzbox dran. Und dann legen die auf. Aber auch schonmal die. Denkst du so, hä? Hast den nächsten dran? Und dann die so, ja, das geht so nicht. Sie müssen da unser Modem dran machen. Ne, muss ich nicht. Ich hab noch einen Vertrag von 1800 quietsch. Da durfte ich noch meine eigenen bauen. Ne, das entstehen wir so nicht.
Wie gibt's Verträge, die einem das untersagen?
Die aktuellen, die aktuellen, ich studiere nicht die AGBs von Alice, aber ich weiß, dass Leute, die jetzt sozusagen in den letzten zwei, drei Jahren so einen Anschluss hatten, die kriegen ein Modem zugeschickt. Die verhindern jetzt nicht aktiv, technisch, dass du was anderem dran steckst, aber wehe, du meldest eine Störung, da ist nicht deren Modem dran. Dann sagen die einfach nöde, machen sie mal erstmal unser Modem dran und rufen uns nochmal an. Tschüss.
Und warten noch mal eine halbe Stunde?
Ja, das geht auch anders.
Ja, aber ich hab von denen mal eine Fritzbox zugeschickt bekommen.
Ja, das war, als sie noch Hansenett waren.
Und als alles noch toll war.
Als alles noch tuffig war. Die waren ja mal ernsthaft tuffig. Aber jetzt durch dieses, die meisten Firmen wären nicht besser davon, dass man sie zweimal hintereinander verkauft. Eigentlich kenne ich keine, die in irgendeiner Form besser davon geworden ist, dass man sie an irgendwelche Konzerne verscheuert hat.
Wenn ich so drüber nachdenke, nee.
Der erste Verkauf war an Italiener.
Erst war es die Italiener. Daher nämlich auch diese ganze Alice-Nummer. Die haben nämlich ihre ganze Werbekampagne aus Italien mitgebracht, haben bloß die dunkelhaarige Schönheit, die sie dort benutzen als Werbemodel, durch diese Blondine ausgetauscht. Die haben einfach ihr Market-Research gemacht, haben gesagt, Nordeuropäer stehen auf Blond, also haben sie die Torte ausgetauscht und dann haben sie exakt die selbe Werbe- kampagne hier in Deutschland gefahren, wie in Italien.
Die zählt jetzt aber nicht als Quotenfrau, ne?
Ne, wir haben ja keinen alles-Anschluss.
Trotzdem war das ja auch noch ganz viel wahnsinnig Infrastruktur, oder? Zu dem Zeitpunkt noch und jetzt, als sie zuletzt verkauft wurden, haben sie alles dann ausgetauscht.
Ich stecke da nicht drin, aber in dem Fall nebenan war das so, dass die Italiener einfach gesagt haben, ihr macht das gut, so wie ihr das macht, ihr habt ein bisschen Geld, macht mal ein bisschen Werbezeugs, da seid ihr nicht so gut drin, wer macht jetzt mal das, was ihr in Hamburg macht, machen wir jetzt mal bundesweit. Ihr eskaliert das mal. Und dann in diesem ganzen Telekom, wir kaufen uns gegenseitig und tralalala und hin und her, ist das dann halt eben mal zur Telefonika gewandert und die haben natürlich auch wieder dann dieses übliche Konzern-Ding gefahren. So, jetzt werden erstmal hier Redundanzen rausgemacht und das machen wir jetzt alles, so wie wir es überall machen und lalalala und was machen eigentlich die ganzen Leute hier? In diesem komischen Network-Operation-Zentrum, das geht ja gar nicht. Das ist viel zu heiß. Das merkt man an so Details, wie zum Beispiel zu Telefonika gehört ja auch O2 und wenn du zum Beispiel mit einem O2-Handy eine Webseite aufrufst oder einen Server aufrufst, da hat deine IP-Adresse keine DNS-Auflösung. Da fragt man sich so Hallo, einmal mit Profis bitte. Ja, hab da mal mit den Leuten gesprochen. Also kein Reverse-Mapping. Eine der Begründungen dafür ist, die Leute, die das vorher gemacht haben, sind einfach nicht mehr da. Theoretisch gibt es da noch irgendwelche Leute, die das tun könnten.
Aber da waren noch Menschen, die noch dieses DNS von Hand aufgelöst haben.
Aber die das installiert haben, die sozusagen entsprechend die Reibentries gemacht haben und so, dass das funktionierte und die sind jetzt einfach nicht mehr da.
Das wäre doch mal eine Werbekampagne, so richtig so, weißt du, so mit Flug über die Alpen und so. Ja, hier wird das Internet noch nach traditioneller Handwerksarbeit ausgeliefert.
Die Leute, die diese IP-Pakete sortieren.
Ja, in so Holzeimern werden die ja so von der Alm runtergetragen. Der Ping, der funktioniert bei uns auch auf der Alm.
Kennt ihr dieses tolle, tolle Video von der Sendung mit der Maus, wo sie mal erklärt haben, wie das Internet funktioniert, wo die Typen mit so Moped-Helmen mit Antennen drauf durch die Gänge vom WDR rennen und so.
Genau, mit Envelopes und so.
Mit IP-Adressen, die im 300er-Bereich sind und so. So eine Geschichte fand ich sehr schön.
Episch. Ja, und auch immer noch irgendwie immer noch wahr.
Ja.
Da ist nichts falsch dran. Das kann man echt immer noch genauso... Na ja, das pfeift noch. Ist bloß kein Lautsprecher mehr dran. Und klingt nicht mehr ganz so schön.
Pfeift ein bisschen hochfrequenter auch.
Ja, nur noch so Grausche, ne?
Ja.
Na, das YouTube-Video, das...
Ist schon im Chat gelandet. Das ist doch schon.
Das werfen wir doch mal hier gleich mal ein. Äh, genau hier. Wie funktioniert das Internet?
Ist doch sehr schön.
Ah, warte mal, da hab ich doch hier glatt mal den falschen Kanal ausgewählt.
Es geht acht Minuten.
Einmal mit Profis, genau.
Ah, es geht acht Minuten, Tim.
Ja, ich wollte ja nur mal hier kurz so...
Der Anfang ist schön.
www.wdrmaus.de ist eine der Möglichkeiten, wie man ab heute die Mausseite im Internet findet. Die sogenannte Homepage. Und jeder, der zu Hause einen Computer hat und einen Internetzugang, kann sich darauf alles anschauen, was mit der Maus zusammenhängt. Alles, was man auf dem Bildschirm sehen kann, sind natürlich Computerdaten. Und diese Computerdaten sind beim Westdeutschen Rundfunk in dieser wundervollen grauen Kiste gespeichert.
Das ist die Rechenpower, die heute in deinem iPhone 5 steckt.
Mit diesem roten Kabel, das da rauskommt, mit dem Internet verbunden. Ist ja alles prima, aber wie komme ich mit meiner Kiste denn da an die Mausseite dran? Mein Computer steht auf meinem Schreibtisch und hat nur eine Verbindung mit dem Stromnetz und sonst gar nichts. Muss ich mir auch so eine rote Leitung legen? Rot muss es nicht sein. Ich muss mir so ein kleines, übersichtliches Gerät anschauen.
Ah, das Modem!
Die graue Kiste da in meiner Hand ist ein Modem. Eigentlich heißt es der Modem.
Naja, sogar hier, fach nicht noch korrekt.
Eigentlich heißt es sogar der Modem.
Und eine dritte Strecke in die Telefonbox. Kabelmäßig alles klar, jetzt brauche ich noch eine CD mit einem Programm. Das muss ich auf meinem Rechner installieren.
Erstmal die AOL-CD installieren....
hilft mir dabei, im Internet die Mausseite zu finden. Wie macht er das?
Naja, okay, also wir wissen alle, was ist. Wer ein bisschen angefixt ist, der kann jetzt hier mal nachschlagen. Das ist eine ganz großartige Nummer, wenn die da irgendwie mit dem Motorrad...
Was ich echt immer wieder schön finde, deswegen gucke ich, obwohl ich gar keinen Fernseher habe, aber es gibt ja das interdings. Und seit Jahresbeginn bezahle ich auch dafür. In der Maus ist... Die sind inzwischen so berühmt und jeder kennt die. Die kommen halt überall rein. Wenn die Maus irgendwo anruft, egal, was das ist, sagt, hallo, wir wollen gerne mal gucken, wie ihr so arbeitet oder so, dann...
Ich würde hier auch reinlassen sofort.
Und die haben schöne Sachen gemacht. Es gab auch mal eine... Da ging es halt darum, wie wird ein Gesetz gemacht? Und dann haben sie sich da hingesetzt in den echten Bundestag, mit echten Bundestagsabgeordneten, haben natürlich nicht die Originalparteienamen genommen, sondern gab es irgendwie eine Heilblöd-Partei und eine Maus-Partei und eine Elefanten-Partei. Und dann haben sie den Abgeordneten T-Shirts mit diesen Bildern übergestülpt in irgendwelchen Farben, haben die in irgendwelche Ausschüsse reingesetzt und haben simuliert die Abschaffung des Rechenunterrichtswart. Hat er zwar gesagt, es war blöd, weil das ist ja Bildungs-Tralala, ist ja Länder, aber wir zeigen euch jetzt mal, wie das geht. Also haben wir jetzt sozusagen den Gesetzesvorhaben und haben das wirklich durchgezogen, bis hin auch, dass sie gezeigt haben, dass das Gesetz natürlich dann auch gedruckt werden muss. Also muss dann irgendwann ausgefertigt werden, wird unterschrieben. Und dann haben sie die echten Minister, ich glaube sogar Gerhard Schröder damals als Bundeskanzler, der zwar keine Gesetze unterschreibt, die haben sie trotzdem vor der Kamera hingeschoben, haben gesagt, hier unterschreibt er mal. Und so haben wir also komplett das einmal durchsimuliert, wie macht man ein Gesetz. Das ist auch eine tolle Folge.
Ich denke, das Maus-Prinzip, das ist ein gutes Prinzip.
Zumindest in der Tech-Welt hast du ja auch so einen Status, oder?
Wir sind ein Maus.
Ich nehme jetzt nicht vor, aber Tim, wenn du jetzt mal irgendwo hingehst und zumindest in unserer Branche anklingeln würdest, wollen wir mal sehen, wie euer JavaScript die backt?
Ja, ich wäre froh, wenn da die Türen immer genauso weit aufging wie für die Maus.
Die Mausebene, siehst du?
Ja, aber das löst natürlich hier nicht unser Geschlechterverhältnis-Problem. Da stehen wir natürlich jetzt hier auch nackt im Internet, was das Thema betrifft. Und ich kann nur sagen, der Podcast und der Tech-Bereich ist ja leider immer noch sehr übersichtlich, was das betrifft. Und ich freue mich hier über alle Mitsprachebewerbungen. Die sind ja hier für Gäste auch immer zu haben, aber dürfen sich halt nur Frauen bewerben. Wobei, ich hab schon eine Anfrage, hab ich schon, aber das ist halt nicht eine Frau.
Geschlechtsverwandlung.
Kann man heute alles lösen.
Ja, aber ich meine das jetzt auch ganz ernst. Es gibt da ja auch wirklich viele, viele ist relativ, aber es gibt sie auch so. Im App-Bereich gibt es auch diverse Einzelkämpferinnen, die irgendwie mit ordentlichen Apps am Start sind und die auch irgendwie wirklich super Sachen machen. Aus dem Stand fällt mir jetzt hier gerade mal, aber hier Sophistication zum Beispiel aus irgendwo in Baden-Württemberg glaube ich.
Ich dachte München.
Also Süden.
Alles südlich von Schönefeld.
Wie war das Bergvolk?
Da kommen so Apps her wie Articles zum Beispiel, Groceries für iPhone, Sachen, die sicherlich schon mal gehört habt oder XXTrail und das ist so alles aus der Schmiede. Da ist der Imprint. Heidelberg, na guck an. Na gut, wir müssen jetzt so weitermachen, wie wir halt hier sind und so sind wir halt. So, ihr wart nicht auf dem Kongress? Da habt ihr was verpasst?
Ja, das hab ich auch gehört.
Hast du schon gehört?
Ich hab schon ein bisschen was gehört, aber noch nicht alles natürlich, aber ich hab schon einiges gehört. Das ist also, ich meine, ich hab ja die Vorbereitungsphase eigentlich schon, also ab dem Moment, wo so die Idee im Clubkreis, wir gehen jetzt nach Malen Hamburg, seitdem hänge da schon so die jeweiligen Zwischenschritte und was ist da auch alles so für Probleme und potentielle Sorgen und was auch nicht alles da und kurz vorher auch schon und oh Gott, oh Gott und was könnte da nicht alles passieren und schief gehen und so weiter. Nee, aber auch die Verhandlung mit der Location und so, das war alles...
Da musste schon wirklich mit großen Dingern gerungen werden.
Ich meine nur, so wie er das gerade sagte, das ist eigentlich so dieses Glashalb-Voll, Glashalb-Lehr-Geschichte und so.
Nee, nee, nee, nee, es war eher so, also es war halt, man geht jetzt so das erste Mal nach wieviel, 10, 12 Jahren, irgendwie wieder mal ganz von vorne los und in einer ganz andere Stadt, andere Location, andere Leute und da gab's einfach so auch genug, was hätte schief gehen können, sag ich mal, bis hin zu, wir kriegen die Location am Ende halt doch gar nicht oder so, und das BCC war dann schon weg und so, also da gab's schon so Szenarien, naja, egal. Und dafür, dass es davor halt so viele Probleme und Bedenken, was auch immer gab, ist es jetzt wohl doch ziemlich gut geworden.
Nicht nur dafür, dass es vorher so Probleme gegeben hat, also es war einfach an sich eine ganz hervorragende Veranstaltung. Also man merkt richtig, wie der Club sich da, wie der Kongress sich freigestrumpelt hat von seinen, von den ganzen Schwierigkeiten, in die die Veranstaltung so geraten ist über die Jahre. Natürlich vor allem dieses Platzproblem, wo ja irgendwie alles dran hängt, weil auf einmal gab es nicht mehr genug Platz für Talks, es gab nicht mehr genug Platz für Projekte, es gab einfach überhaupt keinen Platz, also auch die schiere Enge wurde irgendwann zu einem Problem auch so gesundheitlicher Natur. Ich meine, mit so vielen tausend Leuten zusammen treffen, das hat es dann noch extra verschärft.
Ich glaube, der letzte schöne Kongress im BCC war tatsächlich, der war auch hier der Niklas Roy mit seinem analogen Pong und so, da war es noch so ein richtiges Art and Beauty gab, so das letzte Mal eigentlich im BCC.
Was war denn das, 6. mit den nautischen Metaphern?
Ah, nee, das war davor. Das muss davor gewesen sein. Aber es war nicht der 21C3. Aber irgendwie so...
25, 26, irgendwo so in dem Bereich.
Vielleicht.
Die letzten beiden waren auf jeden Fall anstrengend.
Aber das weißte ich noch nicht. Niklas Roy, das war länger her. Das war 22 oder 23C3. Egal. Aber das war so, ich weiß noch, da gab es noch ein Art and Beauty, da kamen halt auch noch ein paar Künstler, da hat auch Jussi mit der hier von We Make Money Not Art ein Talk gehalten und das war halt so ein bisschen, das war jetzt nicht nur so, wir machen jetzt so eine Hacker-Konferenz, das war so, irgendwie war das schön und kuschelig und gab Platz und danach wurde es irgendwie von Jahr zu Jahr irgendwie anstrengend.
Obwohl ich fand, die Pain Station passte sehr gut zu dieser total überlaufenden Location. Also es war halt so das letzte Quäntchen Pain, was noch ging.
Ja, aber ich meine jetzt so, in den letzten Jahren ist halt zum Beispiel das Art & Beauty ja komplett eigentlich verschwunden, hast halt immer diese Blinken-Lights-Leute gehabt und dann war es das aber eigentlich auch schon. Das zum Beispiel war, hab ich immer so ein bisschen vermisst so in den letzten Jahren, dass das alles so wegen diesen Massen von Leuten und so, dass das alles so ein bisschen verschwindet.
Genau, also man merkte einfach, dass der Kongress nicht mitwachsen konnte mit der Nachfrage nach ihm. Das war einfach echt das Problem und es war bis zu einem bestimmten Punkt war das irgendwie noch händelbar und man hat das auch in gewisser Hinsicht so ein bisschen hingenommen als eine natürliche Wandlung, weil schon jetzt im BCC, auch schon im HAKP, war ja der Kongress schon wieder was anderes, als er noch vorher in Hamburg war. Weil das war wirklich nur eine super pifige, mega nationale, also nur deutsche Talks, keine wirkliche internationale Kommunikation, gespeichert in Beteiligung, immer mit dieser Ausnahme der Holländer. Und das hat sich ja dann in Berlin schon sehr schnell gewandelt und von daher war ich auch natürlich jetzt sehr gespannt, was jetzt dieser neue Ort da freisetzen könnte. Naja und jetzt, also man kann wohl davon ausgehen, dass so gut 7000 Leute da waren, also 6600 verkaufte Tickets, wobei das halt auch Tagestickets dabei sind, also wo sozusagen unterschiedliche Personen dann noch kamen. Das ist also ungefähr eine Verdopplung gegenüber dem letzten Jahr. Genau weiß ich es jetzt nicht, aber so Pi mal Daumen war es eine Verdopplung.
Ich war nicht mal da.
Und du warst noch nicht mal da. Vor Ort fühlte es sich aber an wie eine Halbierung. Vor Ort war einfach so viel Raum und so viel Luft und so viel Platz und so viel Raum, in dem man irgendwie vorstoßen konnte, weil das einfach alles so irre groß war, dass man einfach vom Gefühl her eigentlich eher das so wahrnahm, als wenn nur die Hälfte gekommen wäre. Aber es verteilte sich halt dann auch mal auf fünf Etagen und nicht auf zwei. Und eigentlich sogar auf zehn Etagen, weil das sozusagen so zweigeteilt war. Ja, also das kann man echt nicht überbetonen, wie gut die Atmosphäre war. Und das war vor allem auch vom Start weg so. Und das lag natürlich auch daran, dass es organisatorisch so gut lief. Also es war jetzt mal nicht nur die Location, sondern man hat auch alle anderen kritischen Bereiche auf einmal in Griff bekommen. Also alles, was irgendwie Quell von Ärger hätte sein können, das Netz, lief perfekt. Also es war einfach absurd. 3000 Leute in einem Veranstaltungsraum. 3000. Und das ist ja auch die Peak-Zahl gewesen, nicht unbedingt zu dem Zeitpunkt.
Und poppen Bubblewrap.
3000 WLAN-Devices, die gleichzeitig aktiv im Netz sind. Verdopplung zum letzten Jahr. So eine Umgebung, wo insgesamt glaube ich 9000 WLAN-Devices überhaupt gezählt wurden, die sich auf diesem Gebäude befanden. Und du konntest da aber den Stream vom Nachbarsaal wie auf dem iPhone anschauen. Irgendwo in der Reihe sitzen. Ich meine, früher war manchmal nicht daran zu denken, überhaupt eine Webseite abzurufen und jetzt kannst du dir die Streams angucken. Das war schon ein bisschen absurd. Naja, also das lief. Das Kassenproblem war gelöst. Irgendwie, neue Software, auf einmal ging alles. Perfekt vorbereitet. Leute hatten irgendwie alle schon ihre Tickets. Gab da morgens so eine riesige Schlange auf einmal und alle schon so, oh Gott, jetzt geht's wieder los. Morgens um neun, erster Tag irgendwie. Ich stehe 100 Meter entfernt vom Eingang. Viertelstunde später war die Schlange weg.
Ja, nee, das war mit dem Pre-Sale, das hat jetzt dieses Jahr auch deutlich besser funktioniert als letztes Jahr. Und mit der ganzen Einscannerei, gab's denn überhaupt noch Barverkauf direkt da?
Ja, gab alles.
Die haben da die SICKINT-Software, glaube ich, genommen, was sie da auch schon mal...
Die was?
Von der SICKINT oder so ist das, glaube ich, die Software.
Genau, die Kölner sind da sowieso gerade dabei, so ein bisschen diesen ganzen organisatorischen Software-Teil aufzuarbeiten. Ja, na gut, ich könnte jetzt hier episch so weitermachen mit den Partys, die da gelaufen sind. Das war halt einfach der Platz, war halt da.
Erzähl mal Sachen, die wir nicht alle im Stream gesehen haben.
Naja, schwer zu sagen.
Das ist dann zum Beispiel Art & Beauty.
Das Gefühl. Naja, Art & Beauty, es war einfach alles war Art & Beauty. Das war so wirklich das Gefühl. Weil jeder kriegt seinen Tisch. Überall standen diese riesigen runden Tische rum und überall halt Leute dran. Und Blink-Lights gab es da nicht nur an einer Ecke, sondern gefühlt überall. Es war einfach ein permanentes Gebastel. Wie war das Catering? Das Catering war nicht schlecht. Es war nur ein wenig varietätenlos. Also irgendwie so am dritten Tag dachtest du dir so, jetzt könntet ihr auch mal was anderes machen als immer nur diese selbe Kombination. Es gab so ein bisschen Abwechslung bei wie die Nudeln aussahen. Aber dass sie sich jetzt wirklich mal darum bemüht hätten, da über die Tage so ein bisschen Abwechslung ins Spiel reinzubringen, das nicht. Aber sie waren relativ lange da. Also es gab bis spät in die Nacht Essensversorgung. Es waren glaube ich nicht so richtig 24 Stunden. Aber das war auch alles irgendwie gar kein Problem. Und es gab dann aber auch viele leckere Details. Es gab einen Crêpes-Stand und andere Sachen, die dann noch aufgemacht wurden. Und dann war ja hier auch noch Raum-Zeit-Labor da, die irgendwie gleich so mit Slasher-Maschine, Zucker-Watte-Maschine und ähnlichen Apparaten da irgendwie aufgekreuzt sind. Und da gab es dann immer kostenlose Pipa-Po gegen Spende und so. Also das war, also das ist das, was man nicht über den Stream hat sehen können, war einfach dieses Gefühl da. Und alle waren so unglaublich befreit. Vor allem, es war auch überhaupt gar keine Diskussion.
Du hast schon im Stream immer nur die Bühne gesehen. Irgendwann gab es mal eine Bemerkung, wo sie sagten, wir dürfen dir das Publikum nicht zeigen oder irgendwas. Was mich gewundert hat, weil zumindest bei dieser Aktion da mit Frank und Fefe, oder das ich hier mit Bubble-Rap poppen oder so, hätte man ja mal kurz mal so einen totalen Schminkmammer.
Ja, das ist so diese alte CCC-Nummer mit oh, wir dürfen auch unsere Teilnehmer nicht abfilmen und so weiter. Aber da mal eine totale von diesem Parteitag.
Hätte ich gerne mal gesehen.
Ja, irre war das. Und das war ja überhaupt der Hammer, dass so die die meistbesuchten Veranstaltungen, also die traditionell immer schon eine Stunde vorher total überlaufen waren, hier so Hacker-Japadie und sowas, ne? Franks Sachen. Das war einfach so, dass du noch 10 Minuten später reinkommen konntest und noch eine Chance hattest, einen Platz zu finden.
Das ist Novum, ja?
Das ist echt ein Novum, ja? Und dann auch so dieses Gefühl, du weißt einfach, jetzt sitzen da 3000, nur in diesem einen Raum, aber draußen ist auch noch was los, so. Es ist nicht so, dass auf einmal da Crickets und Tumbleweed irgendwie am Start gewesen wären. Naja, aber was man, also da hast du recht, es war einfach diese Atmosphäre und dieses Gefühl, was man da irgendwie zwangsläufig bekam. Und es war einfach schön zu sehen, dass es einfach so vom Standweggriff eine Begeisterung um sich bei allen Teilnehmern, das war schon echt nicht mehr fassbar.
Einfach so dieses...
Und alle so yeah. Genau, so richtig so geil, endlich wieder Kongress, wie wir uns das immer gedacht haben. Und die große Frage, das ist ja auch so eine der Fragen waren, die wir uns so im Vorfeld alle gefragt haben, skaliert diese Veranstaltung eigentlich? Heißt mehr Besucher, mehr Mainstream? Heißt das jetzt kommen irgendwelche Mainstream-Horden, die das vorher im Sat1-Bericht gesehen haben und sich denken, oh geil, hier Hacker und so? Ja, da kann man bestimmt auch ordentlich Counter-Strike zocken oder so.
Apropos Powerpoint-Präse, hast du diese gesehen von dem Typen, der die Cisco-Telefone da aufgemacht hat? Der hat da einen ziemlich geilen Talk gemacht.
Den hab ich noch nicht nachgesehen.
Der hat auch eine sehr lustige Powerpoint-Präse. Er hat auch eine 2 Gigabyte große Powerpoint-Präsentation gemacht. Weil jeder Ding irgendwie von Hand gemalt hat. Wie auf dem Zettel aufgemalt hat. Also wenn er seine Diagramme hingemalt hat, das ist echt so, wie er auf dem Zettel aufgemalt und abgescannt hat. Aber es sieht auch ziemlich geil aus, wird dir gefallen. Der hat sowieso einen ganz guten Talk auch gebracht.
Weil ich hab jetzt gerade keinen Link dafür.
Also so Schallpläne oder so, die er von Hand gekritzelt hat in seiner Powerbank.
Da hat irgendjemand so eine Software gehackt, wo du Diagramme im Stil von XKCD generieren kannst.
Das haben sogar viele für unterschiedliche Libraries gemacht. Die ersten waren für Mathematiker, dass du in Mathematiker so eine Diagramme kriegst. Dann gab es auch eine JavaScript-Grafing-Library und für R gab es auch ein Plugin. Das war ein ganz großer Sport für eine Zeit lang.
Hier ist der Zisco-Vortrag.
Was meintest du? Clemens, wenn du mal... Das ganze Ding ist so water-colored. Wenn du diese üblichen Industriediagramme gewohnt bist, war das mal ganz spannend. Der redet auch ganz ordentlich, auch sein Kollege dort.
Sehr hübsch.
Die haben sehr schöne Sachen gemacht.
Das haben sie doch auf dem iPad gemacht. Klar.
Es waren einige iPads in Betrieb.
Da gibt es auch noch mal Applikationen, die dir so watercolor und pennen und das alles machen.
Aber hier, das kam wohl vom Mac weg, dass diesen Desktop da gerade richtig...
Nein, nein, das kann ja dann...
Schön an dieser Stelle ist, als er sich überlegt hat, auch so Cisco-Telefone hacken, hat er mal so ein bisschen rumgeklickt und gibt halt so schöne Pressefotos, zeigt er da auch. Obama an seinem Tisch, auf dem Tisch ein Cisco-Telefon. Dann den hier. Der Petraeus, ja.
Hinter ihm drei Cisco-Telefone.
Und er dann so angerufen bei Cisco, hat die gesagt so, ich mach eure Dinge auf, ist das ein Problem? Und die so, def ignore. Dann hat er immer weitergetrieben. Hört euch den mal an, der ist wirklich ganz lustig. Also auch gerade wie er eben so schön abgeprallt ist bei Cisco, die erstmal so, ne, wir sind doch secure. Wir sind doch certified secure, ist doch alles in Ordnung. Geht mir doch weg, wir haben kein Problem.
Gutes Beispiel, ja.
Und wie gesagt, wenn du ein paar Mühe zurückklickst, siehst du auch Obama an seinem Tisch, Cisco-Telefon auf dem Tisch.
Moment, das war jetzt betont, das wollte ich jetzt nicht.
Im War Room, ja, sitzen sie unten da. In Air Force One, der Konferenztisch. In Air Force One steht das Cisco-Telefon auf dem Tisch.
Oh ja. Schönes Ding, also gab ja so ein bisschen Kritik, dass jetzt hier so die technischen Überflieger-Talks so nicht so zahlreich gewesen waren, aber es ist jetzt nicht so, dass es nichts interessantes gegeben hätte.
Also, ja, da gab es schon. Ich hab mir jetzt gerade neulich einmal dieses Ding angeguckt, weil ich ja auch so ein Krypto-Fan bin von diesen drei Leuten da. Die sind ja Faktorisierungen, die einfach mal sagen so, wenn wir 2012, jetzt nehmen wir mal so einen schönen 1024-Bit-RSA-Schlüssel auseinander oder so, mit ihren mathematischen Methoden sozusagen. Wie kommt man da besser ran? Da gab es echt ein bisschen Hirnschmerz dazu zu hören, weil das ist schon sehr mathematisch gewesen. Aber auch sehr interessant. Finde ich gut, dass sie da auch so eine Sache haben.
Also es gab definitiv jetzt keinen Mangel an Vorträgen, die das eigene Wissen deutlich übersteigen. Ich hab zum Beispiel da den Vortrag gesehen so über Scada Security. Also Scada ist ja so diese ganze Industriesteuerungsakrobatik und so, da verlässt man dann den Raum dann auch eher so ein bisschen, ja, mit verklickten. Ja, ja, so. Es werden halt sehr viele ganz böse Probleme bekannt, so mit so Default Passwords und so. Also sie haben da irgendwie mal alles, irgendwie die Landschaft gescannt.
Geht's da um diese Zentrifugen?
Ja, ja, da geht's um Atomkraftwerke und solche harmlosen kleinen Infrastrukturelemente. Ja, und die werden halt alle nicht aktualisiert. Es bleibt halt alles so.
Ja, gab's ja auch Security Nightmares, haben sie erklärt, warum. Dann verlieren sie ihre Zertifizierung. Die sind ja zertifiziert. Wenn du ein Softwareupdate einspielst, verlieren sie ihre Zertifizierung.
Genau, das geht ja nicht, dass man jetzt hier irgendwie sicher ist, aber dann auch nicht mehr zertifiziert.
Sag mal, jetzt wo ich gerade hier immer so auf dein tolles, großes Display starre, auf deinem Mac, Ableton hat so zwei Views, weil normalerweise hast du ja immer so diesen View mit diesen Tonspuren da am Laufen und das ist jetzt aber der andere View, richtig?
Man tappt da so hin und her.
Der eine heißt glaube ich Timeline View und der andere Card View.
Okay, ich wollte nur sichergehen, dass da auch alles so seine Richtigkeit hat.
Ja, ne, hat alles seine Richtigkeit.
Zeichnest du denn auch auf?
Ich zeichne auch auf, ich zeichne auch die richtigen Spuren auf.
Großartig.
Ist irre, oder?
Also es wird einfach so.
Einmal mit Profis.
So professionell, ne?
Nicht nur einmal.
Immer wieder mit Profis.
Immer wieder, genau. Der Spruch ist nämlich total falsch.
Nur noch mit Profis.
Einmal ist wirklich zu wenig.
Das eine Mal möchte man wenigstens mal leben. Das müsste manchen brauchen.
Ja, aber dann bist du angefixt.
Ja, was gibt es noch zu sagen zum 29C3? Also ein paar Netzwerkstatistiken hast du ja auch schon fallen lassen. Hier die 22 Gigabit-Ablink, die zu 8 Gigabit ausgelotet waren.
Das war noch, bevor wir auf Sendung gingen.
Das ist immer das Problem, wenn man schon vorher alles beschnackt.
Nur 22 Gigabit?
Ich spreche nie wieder mit dir, wenn die Aufnahme läuft.
Nur 22 Gigabit.
Ja, 2x10 plus 2x1.
Genau, 4 Provider.
Davon haben sie aber nur 8. Bei 8 haben sie dann gepiekt. Da war 8,5, da war dann Ende der Lände. Mehr haben die Teilnehmer einfach nicht zustande.
Aber sie haben immerhin es geschafft, 40% des inbound-Traffics IPv6 zu sprechen. Da haben auch alle so ein bisschen mit der Brau gelupft. Inbound. Also sozusagen, das war die Teilnehmer, die so... Ja, also halt alle großen Sites. Ja, BitTorrent wahrscheinlich auch.
Also sieht man auf jeden Fall in BitTorrents immer häufiger die V6-Teilnehmer. Oder immer mehr.
Jaja, das nimmt halt insgesamt so. Und wenn man einfach nur mal seinen Client richtig... Also was das zeigt ist, wenn man einfach mal IPv6 einfach so einschaltet, dann geht das auch. Und dann wird es auch benutzt. Und das ist auf einmal so da.
Geträumt in meinem Lebensmotto.
Kommt man es richtig, geht es auch schon.
Genau. So, würde man jetzt also hier bei der Telekom mal alles auf IPv6 einschalten und nicht nur, wie sie jetzt da anal fixiert, meinen ja nur die reinen IP-Anschlüsse. Warum auch immer.
Vorsicht, nicht diese dusselige Telekom-Thermologie benutzen. Wenn ich den Typen an den Wickel kriege, der gesagt hat, oh wir nennen unser Voice-over-IP-Produkt IP. Weil jetzt denken die ganzen Hotliner und das ganze blöde Volk, IP ist schon belegt. Das Akronym ist schon belegt. Das ist eh schon doppelt belegt. In der Industrie. Nämlich Internet-Protokoll und Intellectual Property. Und jetzt kommen die Telekom-Leute dazu und definieren ihr Volk-Produkt und nennen das IP. Was kam denn vorher aus meinem DSL-Anschluss raus? Da kam kein IP raus?
Also, wovon wir reden ist, da wo es keine richtige Telefonie mehr gibt, sondern halt so...
Next Generation Networks. Mit weniger Leistungsmerkmal. Aber ich arbeite da noch dran. Ich gucke mir das nochmal genauer an. Das gute alte ISDN hat echt Vorteile. Seitdem ich jetzt seit letztem Jahr in einer Location mal wieder einen echten Telefon-Anschluss, einen ISDN-Anschluss von der Telekom habe, weiß ich erst, was ich die letzten Jahre bei den Alices und diesen ganzen anderen Akkus dieser Welt vermisst habe. Aber da können wir später vielleicht nochmal drauf kommen.
Das ist wirklich ein Drama.
Da werde ich wieder gescholten, dass ich hier zu tun bin.
Ich hatte auch gerade so einen Freund, der mir gesagt hat, ja wir haben so ein Problem mit unserem Telefon. Und ich so, ja was denn? Ja, das rauscht manchmal so ein bisschen und knackt. Und so fühlst du dich gleich so, wann war das letztes Mal, 50er Jahre, da war das so glaube ich, diese Probleme, dass du sowas hattest. Und auf einmal dauert das alles wieder lange und wird schlecht. Und das ist halt jetzt wegen diesem ganzen IP-Kack.
Man kann das aber, ich glaube, dass die Telekom das schon ganz ordentlich baut, was übrigens auch der Hintergrund ist, warum sie denn auf diesen Dinger das V6 mit anknipsen. Weil sie nämlich auch das Volk zu guten Teilen eben auch mit V6 abfackeln. Den ganzen Kunden auf eine ganz andere Technik sozusagen virtuell stöpseln. Ja, du Neukunde, du alles hier, neue, tolle, sexy Technik, da wirst du jetzt drauf geroutet mit deinem DSL-Anschluss. Und das, was halt steht für den anderen Kunden, die Bestandskunden oder sowas, das steht halt da.
Fassen sie halt nicht an.
Oder fassen sie erst später an, wenn sie da Zeit und Lust für haben, wenn das andere alles...
Das ist bei Cable Deutschland auch so. Die neuen Kunden kriegen nicht V6 und Carrier Grade, nicht V4.
Ja, also immerhin gibt es da einen Transition Path. Aber auf dem Kongress konnte man das halt einfach mal schön sehen. Wobei es gab da auch am Anfang Probleme. Also sie haben ja diesmal das erste Mal nicht nur so die Core-Router, sondern im Prinzip auch die ganze Backbone-Infrastruktur mit Unipa-Devices bestritten.
Man hat mal richtig mehrfache Router dort. Die haben halt nicht dieses übliche Spiel gemacht, was man auf solchen Veranstaltungen macht, nämlich einen riesengroßen Layer 2 aufzubauen, mit ein Stapel weißes Switches und dann irgendwo ein, zwei Router, die die ablinks machen, sondern sie haben halt eben auch zwischen den einzelnen Locations geroutet und nicht geswitcht. Das ist halt schon mal ein Paradigmenwechsel dort.
Und das hat dann auch ganz gut funktioniert, nachdem sie die Probleme gelöst hatten mit wieder mal überlaufenden MAC-Adress-Tables und so weiter, generell alle Tables, die so voll laufen können, und dann mussten sie IPv6 da nochmal auslagern.
Das ist zumindest ein Platz für ein Thema, wenn du immer denkst, so Großveranstaltungen mit WLAN zu machen oder hängen wir jetzt einfach noch mehr APs hin, kannst du ja gerne machen. Aber du musst halt immer an solche Sachen denken, wie MAC-Adress-Tables. Dass die ob üblichen Switches, die sie umladen rumlungern, die hören bei 1024 auf. Wenn du Glück hast, hören sie bei 4096 auf. Aber das reicht für so ein Kongress nicht aus.
Hinten und vorne nicht.
So, da brauchst du halt eine Kiste, die 16K MAC-Adressen kann. Auf einem Layer 2. Und das wird immer enger nach hinten.
Aber 16K war nämlich genau das Limit, was beim Kongress gerissen wurde.
Ja, und dann gibt es noch weniger Equipment, noch mehr als die 16K-Dinger. Weil damals, als die Leute gesagt haben, niemand baut ein Ethernet, wo so viele Leute drauf sind. Niemand. Genauso wie man sich vor 25 Jahren dachte, niemand braucht mehr als 640K-Speicher.
Oder niemand hat vor, eine Mauer zu errichten.
Niemand hat vor, einen Flughafen zu errichten. Genau.
Und da muss man dann dran denken, das sind halt so diese Backendsong, mit denen du jahrelang mit deinem Radio gekämpft hast, mit den sich störenden Kanälen und Blattwiesig nicht alle, denkst du, ok, jetzt haben wir hier richtig Radio-Equipment an der Decke zu hängen und reichlich und toll und hin und her. Und dann fallen hier hinten die Switches um. Herzlichen Glückwunsch.
Ja, genau. Und das waren so die Probleme, mit denen sie zu kämpfen hatten. Aber die haben sie dann in den Griff bekommen. Und ab, dann gab es irgendwie einmal so eine kurze Service-Unterbrechung, da haben sie irgendwie alles umgestellt. Das ist so dieser Knick in der Abschlussgrafik auch. Und dann habe ich einfach das Problem, es gibt kein Netz, gab es nicht mehr.
Auf die Gefahr, mich zu wiederholen? Kaum macht man es richtig, geht es auch nicht.
Genau. Das war wirklich erstaunlich. Und das war auch insofern erstaunlich, als das natürlich vorher musste. Das CCH ist ja auch so ein Gebäude, wo dann so Subunternehmer auch mit im Spiel sind. Das ist ja die andere große Angst gewesen im Vorfeld, wie das so alles ausgehen wird. Und natürlich gibt es da auch so einen WLAN-Provider. Der dann überhaupt nicht einsehen wollte, warum denn nicht sein Equipment verwendet wird für diese Veranstaltung.
Ich kenne das genau. Wir haben jetzt Mitte des Jahres kommt die ITF nach Berlin. Da haben wir das auch wieder, das Thema mit den Hotelleuten.
Genau. Und da müsst ihr wahrscheinlich auch so eine ähnliche Mail schreiben, wie dann geschrieben wurde. Das wurde so eine etwas längere Mail verfasst, wurde dann mal so ausführlich dargelegt wurde, was das Problem ist, worauf sich die Gebäudebetreiber auch schon bedankt haben. Ach so, endlich hat das mal einer schön zusammengefasst, was eigentlich das Problem ist, weil die das natürlich nie so verstanden haben. Und dem etwas tickigen Netzbetreiber da wurde dann sozusagen dann auch noch mal eine Kurzanalyse präsentiert, wie schnell man durch ihr PHP-basiertes captive Portal so durchkommt und ruht hat auf irgendwie allen dahinterliegenden Maschinen. Da war dann glaube ich die Diskussion auch schnell beendet.
Wir machen das mit ITF, da machen wir das schon in der Siteservé. Da erklären wir denen schon mal schöne lustige Horrorszenarien und so. Und sie probiert es immer wieder. Letztes Jahr in Paris war das auch so, da hatten wir die Veranstaltungsgeschichten zwar, die haben wir gemacht, aber im Hotel, das Hotel hat gesagt, ach hier, die paar Gäste, wer kennt das doch? Wir haben immer Gäste, die ihr Laptop aufklappen. Ja, aber nicht solche. Ja, so mit 2,3 devices pro Nase, die das Netz auch nutzen, die mehr als ein Tweet am Tag abschicken und so. Nee, nee, das haben wir kein Problem. Und dann haben wir nachts, oder ein Kollege, da Freunde aus dem ITF, die Team, er hat nachts dann das Hotel-Netz umkonfiguriert. Und zwar hat er das Problem, das größte Problem hat er dadurch gelöst, dass er erstmal die Hälfte von deren APs abgeschaltet hat.
Also es wurde schon deren Infrastruktur verwendet. Ja, es ging nur darum, darauf Zugriff zu erlangen.
Und dann konnte man das nochmal ein bisschen in die richtige Bahn lenken.
Ja, also auf dem Kongress lief das auf jeden Fall alles ganz super. Ich meine, das Tech-Netzwerk läuft, das braucht man sowieso schon seit vielen Jahren nicht mehr zu erwähnen. Und auch das GSM-Netz war wohl recht funktionabel. Das habe ich allerdings selber nicht benutzt, da ich mein Zwei-Telefon leider zu Hause vergessen habe.
Weil sie keine Nano-Sims rausgegeben haben?
Na ja gut, die hätte man sich ja schnippeln können. Ich wollte mein iPhone 4 nehmen, aber wie gesagt habe ich es dann vergessen. Aber es gab zumindest schon mal Sims, wo du dir auch gleich die Mikro rausbrechen konntest. Also für Nano jetzt noch nicht, aber an sich war das irgendwie alles ganz okay.
Da frage ich mich zum Beispiel, warum sie da nicht einfach mehr hingehen und mal die Sims der Leute benutzen, die sie eh drin haben. Und warum sie nicht mal jetzt nach Jahren mal hingehen und mal einen Roaming bauen. Das ist ja auch mal technologisch mal. Weil was sie jetzt technologisch in letzter Zeit so gemacht haben, sie machen immer noch keine Daten. Weil sie sagen, okay, das bringt unser Netz um. Wir wollen ja nur ein bisschen mit GSM-Hacking und Spaß und Voice und lalala. Also machen sie keine Paketgeschichten. Nee, machen sie absichtlich nicht. Weil sie sagen, das kommt nicht mit der Infrastruktur. Weil dann werden da sich die ganzen Smartphones da einbuchen und darumduddeln, dann haust du uns das Zeug weg.
Ja, und ist Roaming so ohne Weiteres möglich?
Man kann da was basteln. Da gibt es auf jeden Fall was, das heißt ohne Weiteres. Das ist immer die Frage, wie hoch die Kooperation ist. Aber du musst halt wissen, was du dazu machen musst im Netz. Du musst halt mit dem HLR, von dem eigentlichen Netzbetreiber, dem die SIM-Karte gehört, reden. Und dem halt diese Authentication-Tribplätze aus der Nase ziehen. Und noch ein paar andere Daten, wie z.B. die Rufnummer und so weiter. Ein Telefon und ein SIM weiß ja selber seine eigene Rufnummer nicht. Und all solche Geschichten. Aber diese ganzen Sachen waren das letzte Mal, als ich damit gespielt habe, was jetzt allerdings auch schon wieder so 3-4 Jahre her ist, waren die eigentlich im SS7 offen verfügbar. Das SS7 ist ja eh meistens noch so ein offener Jointentor, weil sie sagen, da hat ja eh nicht jeder Zugriff drauf. Aber sich diese Authentication-Triplett zu holen, war in der Regel nie das Problem. Also, um damit einen Kunden überhaupt mal zu identifizieren, und mehr wollen die ja gar nicht. Die brauchen das und dann kriegen sie den Ciphering-Key da draus. Das Bestandteil dieses Triplett, dann wissen sie auch, wie sie verschlüsseln mit dem Gerät, und dann ist gut.
Lassen die denn jeden da hergelaufen, und mit ihnen reden?
Wie gesagt, als ich letztes Mal die Finger dran hatte, vor dreieinhalb, vier Jahren oder so, ging das.
Haben sie noch nicht damit gerechnet, dass da jemand kommt, der nicht ein Multimillionen...
Das ist auch eigentlich, das ist unkritisch. Das ist sicherheitstechnisch unkritisch. Und die haben halt sehr viele Sorgen auch, und im Zweifel haben die so Sachen einfach lieber offen, anstatt sie zuzumachen, weil dann sofort irgendwie 20.000 ihrer Roaming-Customer gegen die Wand knallen und so. Da das sicherheitstechnisch nicht so dramatisch ist, hätten wir das eigentlich eher offen. Du kannst natürlich keinen Billing-Record schicken, du kannst jetzt nicht ein CCC-Netz aufmachen. Wir sehen davon, dass das auch die Lizenz, die sie da haben, für die Veranstaltung hergehen würde. Kannst du nicht sagen, so geil, hier hätten wir gerne mal 20.000 Dollar für die ganzen Amis, die hier mit ihren SIM-Karten waren.
Ja, die haben hier mindestens ein Megabyte Daten verbraucht. Das ist ja, wissen wir alle, was das wert ist im Ausland.
Da könnte man den Kongress gut refinanzieren.
In welches Land sind sie denn da überhaupt? Ja, in Unikstan.
Ja, also sowas wird nicht gehen, aber rein die Leute zu authentizieren und den Seifer in Key zu kriegen, das würde schon gehen, zumindest im GSM.
Ja, was interessiert euch denn noch vom Kongress? Man könnte ja über alles Mögliche reden.
Also, ich weiß nicht, also jetzt so hier so in diesem Podcast interessiert mich glaube ich tatsächlich nicht so wahnsinnig viel.
Eine Zahl, die mich interessiert hat, wurde leider nicht mehr erhoben seit einiger Zeit. Das ist sehr schade, nämlich die Anzahl der MEX, die ja, als das nochmal erhoben wurde, rasant hoch ging.
Kann das nicht mit der MAC-Adresse raus?
Ja, aber es wurde nicht erhoben. Diese Zahl wurde nicht generiert. Ich kann jetzt nicht genau sagen, was so viel...
Sie haben sich sogar selber geordetet. Haben sie in diesem Abschlusstalk von dem NOC gesagt, sie haben selber nochmal keine Ahnung, oder ein Auditor ist bei ihnen auch durchgehoppelt und hat sich das nochmal angeguckt, bevor der Kongress losgeht, dass sie auch ja keinen Lockfile zu viel haben, wo auch nur irgendeine MAC-Adresse oder eine IP-Adresse drinsteht.
Ja, hatten sie nämlich. Auf vergangenen Veranstaltungen gab es ja immer dann so diesen Moment, da hat irgendjemand so ein File ins Git eingecheckt, oh, da sind alle MAC-Adressen drin. Sie haben es dann immer rechtzeitig bemerkt, bevor irgendjemand anderes es bemerkt hat, aber da gab es immer mal so Momente so, oh, da haben wir wohl nicht richtig sauber gemacht.
Die sieht doch eh jeder andere, oh, bei dem offenen Netz dort sieht doch eh jeder andere MAC-Adressen.
Ja, aber du weißt, also ich finde das ganz okay.
Man will es halt nicht unbedingt vom NOC durchführen lassen.
Dafür machen es denn die Leute, die auf der anderen Seite der Leitung hängen. Obwohl ich weiß gar nicht, ob jetzt wie die Polizeibehörden in Deutschland überhaupt schon mit 10 Gig-Leitungen klarkommen.
Ja gut, aber jetzt mit so einem Netz, wo auch irgendwie gerautet wird und so weiter, da siehst du ja auch schon gar nicht mehr alles so. Also das ist ja gar nicht so doof. Naja, da sind sie halt sehr hinterher und manchen ja dann auch irgendwann in irgendeiner Stelle so und we do not look at your data. We do not look at your data. Mehrfach. Und das war auch ein... Also ich finde das Nocteam immer besonders beeindruckend auf dem Kongress schon seit Jahren, weil das mit Abstand internationalste Sektionen des gesamten Kongresses ist. Also viele, also Kernorgas, klar, das kommt im Wesentlichen so aus unseren Klubsstrukturen heraus. Das ist so, da muss der Club sich drum kümmern. Aber umso mehr es halt so in die Peripherie geht und so autake Gruppen gebildet werden, also schon bei den Engeln ist es da schon deutlich internationaler. Da gibt es auch viele Holländer und andere, die da auch regelmäßig immer wieder mitspielen und wo dann auch schon so langsam die Handelssprache Englisch wird. Und in den Nocks, also genauso auch im GSM-Nock, deswegen sag ich die beiden Nocks, da ist das einfach, da kommst du mit Deutsch nicht vorwärts, weil da sitzt halt einfach alles voll mit Holländern, Engländern, Amerikanern, vor allem die ganzen Netzwerk-Teams, schon aus Europa und jetzt auch in zunehmendem Maße auch US-Amerikaner, die diesmal dazugestoßen sind. Und man merkt auch, dass dadurch einfach auch so der gegenseitige Respekt und die Professionalität auch weiter ansteigt, weil die sozusagen da auf so einem Level miteinander kommunizieren. Alle wollen sozusagen das Beste aus ihrer Erfahrungswelt damit einbringen und es ist ein extrem professioneller Umgang, was dann eben sowohl so eine Respektswirkung hat, als eben auch, dass der ganze Workflow davon einfach auch profitiert. Dass sie sich da einfach auf so vielen Ebenen professionalisieren, das ist wirklich beeindruckend. Trotzdem halt eine nette Atmosphäre und auf keinen Fall humorlos. Das ist schon echt cool. Weiter so.
Genau, weiter so.
Wir sind dafür.
Wo wir gerade bei Events sind.
Huckel.
Ich hab mir gerade ein Ticket geklickt. Ach, das ist ja nur die Rechnung. Auf jeden Fall die Keynote-Speech hält da ein John Bader.
Davon weiß ich ja noch nichts. Steht da Keynote?
Na ja, es ist die erste Veranstaltung.
Es ist auch noch die erste Veranstaltung?
Ja, du bist der Opener.
Siehst du, man wusste ich noch gar nicht. Oh shit.
Und da dachte ich mir so, da gehste mal.
Da bist du doch dabei.
Gleich mal den Pressure ein bisschen aufdrehen.
Genau, und zwar bei der Munich Erlang Factory Light. Das Thema hatten wir glaube ich hier schon ein paar Mal. Es gibt ja diese Erlang Factory, das ist so ein bisschen durch die Welten tingelnde Veranstaltung. Teilweise in den USA, teilweise eben in Europa. So ein bisschen 50-50, ne? Merkt man auch, dass das da ein bisschen anders läuft in der Erlang Welt, weil das kommt ja letzten Endes alles aus Schweden, zumindest mal ursprünglich. Wenn man nochmal auf erlangfactory.com klickt.
Ja, jetzt seh ich's auch, tatsächlich. Oh je, neun Uhr zehn. Na, heide bim bam. Das war aber auch so, ein Kollege hat so gemeint, ja hier übrigens Erlang Factory München, falls er einen Talk einreichen wollte. Und irgendwie dachte ich so an dem Moment, kritisiere ja immer so gerne andere Talks und so. Und jetzt müsste ich ja eigentlich selber mal einen machen, damit ich dann auch sozusagen erstens mich selber nochmal so ein bisschen vielleicht auf so einen Level ziehe und andererseits dann vielleicht auch ein bisschen berechtigter Kritik üben kann. Und dann hab ich den einfach irgendwie so, hab ich halt in dieses Formulier da was reingetippt, was ich so dachte, was ganz interessant sein könnte. Und so zehn Minuten später krieg ich eine Mail, ja, wir bräuchten da noch ein Foto von dir. Und ich so, wat? Wie? Gibt's da nicht so ein Auswahlprozess? Nö, bei diesen Factory-Lights ist es eher so First come, first serve und du bist ja hier bei Booger und wir kennen euch ja schon und so, das passt schon. Und ich dachte so an dem Moment, wo ich das mitgedrückt hab, vielleicht lehnen sie mich ja noch ab und dann bin ich ja fein raus, aber jetzt muss ich deliveren. Na, liefern.
Genau, und zwar heißt das dann A Beginner's Guide to Erlang.
Erlang liegt nicht im Saarland.
Wo ist denn das überhaupt? Ich begreif noch nicht genau, wo das ist.
Wo?
Wo in München, sagst du?
Na, hier steht irgendwas von University, aber dann steht irgendwie Venue to be confirmed. Also ist das in der Uni München?
Aber hier steht doch Maritimhotel München.
Ach nee, University bezieht sich hier auf das Programm, auf deren University. Wo steht das?
Bei Venue links im Menü.
Ach da, Venue, Entschuldigung.
Im Maritimhotel München.
Maritimhotel Goethe Straße 7. Na ja gut, vielleicht... Also vorhin, es gibt jetzt noch so 60 Euro Early Bird Geschichten, wen irgendwie er lang interessiert, der mag da vielleicht hingehen wollen, gibt's dann Huckel Life und mich im Publikum.
Zeig's ihnen.
Ja, mach sie fertig. 35 Minuten muss noch reichen.
Na ja, ich bin gespannt. Das ist ja direkt am...
Das ist ja direkt am Bahnhof.
In 10 Minuten.
Fahren Sie bei der Alan Factory ein.
Das ist eher in 10 Sekunden. Das ist wirklich direkt über die Straße.
Ja, direkt in SVN oder in GitHub einchecken.
Checken Sie direkt in das Repository ein. Das ist ja schön.
Na gut, dann sitze ich zumindest nicht... Also dann hab ich ja schon mal einen Gast sicher.
Ich sehe ja eine Nachtzugfahrt, sehe ich dann auch rechtzeitig da.
Ja, so ein bisschen Schweinsbraten essen kann man auch gleich noch. Das ist eigentlich einer der wenigen Anlässe, warum ich... Da ist ein Maritim.
Ja, das ist eine total krötige Gegend da eigentlich.
Dieses Bayern bereise ich ja nicht so oft, aber für so ein Schweinsbraten...
Die Woche vorher bin ich exakt in der Location. Also nicht im Maritim, aber auf derselben Straße.
Ach, da im Hinterhof ist das, genau.
Das ist eigentlich eher so ein bisschen, naja, das war ein Münchenglaub, für ein Rotlichtviertel zu halten. Bahnhofstralala.
Ich kenne die.
Das ist alles nur...
Ja, naja, auf jeden Fall mein erster richtiger Talk-Talk. Der Sat.1 Talk-Talk.
Hast du auch noch nie auf dem Kongress einen Talk gehalten, oder was?
Nee, auf dem Kongress dachte ich mir immer, die sind mir...
Du bist eigentlich nur so ein kleiner Gestalter, ne?
Genau. Ich hab ja eigentlich Grafikdesign studiert und dann dachte ich mir immer, auf dem Kongress so, ja, also entweder macht man jetzt was ganz lustiges, sowas wie PowerPoint-Karaoke oder was halt so richtig cool ist, aber dann in dem Publikum was richtig cool ist, wusste ich immer nicht so.
Du könntest mal einen Talk halten über Grafikdesign für Programmierer.
Stimmt, das ist echt Bedarf.
Das meine ich aber wirklich ernst. Weil da würdest du an einer Stelle was beitragen, weil du verstehst beide Welten.
Apropos PowerPoint-Karaoke, das habe ich damals gewonnen.
Welches?
Auf dem Kongress.
Achso.
Da gab es mal eins. Und das habe ich gewonnen.
Auf welchem Kongress?
Ja, das muss so 4,5 her sein, das erste.
Wenn das so toll war, dann musst du ja gemerkt haben, auf welchem C3.
Nein, ich weiß es nicht mehr. 23 oder 24 oder so. Ich weiß es nicht mehr genau.
Meine erste Amtshandlung...
Ja, es gibt auch ein Video davon.
Meine erste Amtshandlung beim Club war ja auch die Datenschleuder. Erstmal dieses Magazin, was da so unregelmäßig erscheint, ein ordentliches Layout zu geben, weil als ich das das erste Mal gesehen habe, da blutete das auch mir aus den Augen. Und das ist bis heute noch so geblieben. Das ist immer noch so mein Einstieg in die Hacker-Welt. Erstmal das Magazin hübsch machen.
Die Datenschleuder.
Ein bisschen hübsch tut uns allen gut.
Ja, wenn ich dann halt immer noch das 2600 sehe, das ist halt immer noch genauso ein Layout-Scheiß wie von vor zehn Jahren. Also die haben zum Beispiel, da scheinbar noch keinen, wie auch immer. Also ich kenne das 2600, das habe ich gesehen, das erste Mal, als ich im Club war, weil das da rumlag. Das heißt, ich bin jetzt seit 12 oder so Jahren im Club. Das heißt, ich habe 12 Jahre 2600-Magazin gesehen und war es zumindest verbrieft für diese Zeit, dass es immer gleich scheiße aussah.
Ich erinnere mich.
23.
Ich glaube, ich war sogar da. Was hast du denn?
Der Chat sagt, Huckel ist Musik.
Was war denn dein...
Noch nicht ganz.
Das war PowerPoint Karaoke.
Ja, aber worüber hast du geredet? Was war dein Thema?
Was waren deine Slides? Also die Slides, das war so eine Art Sprachkurs, hatte ich das Gefühl. Also es waren extrem wenig Worte. Es waren nur so Clipart-Grafiken und es war alles extrem zusammenhanglos. Also man konnte ganz gut darüber improvisieren, weil die Slides sowieso keine Story hatten.
Ach, es gibt eine Aufzeichnung.
Klar gibt es eine Aufzeichnung hier. Die Farbe ist direkt schlichtbar. Kein Spielraum für Fantasie.
Verena hatte da auch eine sehr schwierige Präsentation. Da ging es irgendwie um den Zusammenhang zwischen Zigaretten, Krebs, Aids und irgendwie noch irgendwelchen komischen anderen Sachen und das alles im Zusammenhang und alles in einer total wirren Präsentation. Und Verena hatte diese Präse gezogen, hat das aber irgendwie doch ganz...
Das war aber nicht auf dem Kongress. Sicher?
Das war ganz lustig auf dem Kongress, weil die hatten irgendwie einfach nur den Finder offen und da lagen ganz viele Icons drin mit PowerPoint-Dingern. Die hatten alle komische Namen und dann habe ich mich da hingestellt und habe da so hoch gezeigt, die da hätte ich gerne. Und dann haben das nach mir irgendwie alle gemacht, weil das hat irgendwie so Schuhe gemacht.
Ach, das war doch, wo FX so sturzbesoffen auf der Bühne stand, oder?
Da ist ja Roddy, gleich am Anfang. Du warst gleich der Erste und danach gab es einfach nach Roddy kommt nichts mehr.
Da wuchs kein Gras mehr.
Ich fand die anderen auch nicht schlecht.
Aber FX war vollkommen sturzbesoffen.
Jaja, der hat mir hinterher sogar einen Job angeboten. So nach der Art, du kannst aber gut Präsentationen halten.
Willst du nicht für mich Präsentationen halten?
Der Bleistift ist nicht spitz.
Was brauchst du jetzt? Ich war auch in der Veranstaltung, aber ich glaube, ich hab den Anfang verpasst, kann das sein?
Also an dich kann ich mich auch nicht mehr erinnern. Da war ich wahrscheinlich auch zu spät dran.
Also ich weiß noch, dass es unheimlich viel Spaß gemacht hat, weil der Saal war auch so gerammelt voll und die Leute sind total mitgegangen.
Jaja, das war spitze. Ja, damals, als der Kongress noch ein BCC war. Langes CH.
Wie viel der Kongress war denn jetzt? 23?
Das ist der 23C3, das ist jetzt schon eine Weile her. 2006, sechs Jahre, da warst du ja noch ganz clean. Ach so, okay, Erlang Factory, StarGas-Ruckel.
Was auf dem Video übrigens nicht mit drauf ist, und da bin ich auch ganz froh drum, zum Schluss konnte ich mir als Gewinner halt das Geschenk aussuchen, so aus dem Tisch Geschenke, und dann gab es irgendwie unter anderem einen...
Bei einem laufenden Band, mit was du dir merken konntest und so, durftest du mit rausnehmen?
Nee, nee, nur eins davon heran, irgendwelche komischen Bücher. Und es gab aber auch von diesen OpenBSD-Leuten, gab es T-Shirts. Und zwar irgendwie so ein schwarzes in XXXXL und ein rosanes irgendwie für Frauen in S. Und dann hab ich halt das genommen und hab's direkt angezogen. Das ist aber nicht mehr auf dem Video drauf.
Hacker-Porn 2006.
Ja, kommen wir zu anderen Dingen. Kommen wir zu unserem Meta-Irata-Kram. Sachen, die wir schon mal besprochen hatten. Und jetzt ist Clemens da und kann uns endlich erklären, wie es funktioniert. Ja, du hättest ja eine Anmerkung zu unserer IMAP-Diskussion, weil ich so verwirrt war mit den Pfaden.
Es war echt bitter, als ich das gehört habe. Da sitzt du da zu Hause und beißt mir die Tischkante und denkst so, ja, nein, nicht weil du jetzt falsche Sachen gesagt hast. Übrigens, danke Huckel, dass du da schon, ich hab das dann mehrfach auch gesagt, da fragt er einfach Clemens. Nee, ich hab da auch eine gewisse Erdblaster, die auch mal so IMAP Server 2 programmiert haben in meinem Leben. Die sind auch immer noch in Betrieb und ich hab den Schmerz durch Litten, der dahinter steckt.
Aber jetzt nicht so Open Source, sondern so bei irgendwelchen...
Ja. Ja, deine Frage fing an mit What the fuck ist dieser Passpräfix?
Ja, vor allem, was ist sozusagen...
Warum? Versuche mal, nicht ganz so weit auszuholen, damit ich hier nicht so wieder als Labertasche tituliert werde. Die Idee war, als man... Also, man musste einfach vorstellen, wir beamen mal zurück, keine Ahnung, welches Jahr das war, aber zu dem Zeitpunkt gab es ein Mail-Protokoll, nämlich Pop 3.
Wer sich jemals dieses Protokoll angeguckt hat, heißt das eigentlich, dass es schon die dritte Version ist?
Es gab mal ein Pop 2, ernsthaft. Pop 1 habe ich nie gesehen, es gab mal ein Pop 2, das hatte irgendwie eine...
Also, dritte Version und immer noch schlecht.
Eine Lifetime von einem Higgs-Boson oder sowas. Also Pop 3 ist eigentlich das, was jemals rauskam. Und wer sich dieses Protokoll mal angeguckt hat, ist ein ganz duseliges Ascii-Protokoll, was jeder mit Talent auch eintippen kann, weil es sage und schreibe dreieinhalb, und ich meine wirklich dreieinhalb Kommandos hat. Davon ist eins total unnütz. Stimmt, den hab ich vergessen. Halo ist aber nicht Pop 3. Pop 3 ist wirklich ganz simpel. Du sagst User, Username, dann Return, dann Pass, Passwort, Klartext natürlich. Logisch. Später hat man ja noch so Sachen wie Apop obendrauf geflanscht, und welche anderen Geschichten. Aber so, der Urprotokoll sagt so User, dann Username, Return, Pass, Passwort, Return, dann kannst du List sagen, das ist das dämlichste Kommando, was jemals erfunden wurde. Das listet nämlich dir die Mails, und zwar, wenn du zehn Mails hast, macht die dir eine Liste mit Zahlen von eins bis zehn. Und wenn du zwölf Mails hast, macht die dir eine Liste von Zahlen von eins bis zwölf. Und wenn du tausend Mails in deiner Mail hast, macht die dir eine Liste mit Zahlen von eins bis tausend. Und zwar ohne irgendwelche Unterbrechungen oder irgendwas drin.
Das ist völlig sinnlos. Das ist völlig bescheuert.
Das haben sie dann auch relativ früh erkannt. Jetzt kommt nämlich das einzig sinnvolle Kommando, das gibt nämlich noch UIDL, das heißt, listet mir mehr Unique IDs für jede Mail, die da so drin sein könnte. Das ist das Kommando, dann gibt's noch Retrieve, da gibst du dann so die Mail an, die du halt haben willst. Dann gibt's noch Delay, dann kannst du sie löschen und quitt, um dich wieder auszuloggen. Mehr kann Pop3 nicht. Das ist es.
Gut, jetzt hast du ja schon relativ weit ausgeholt.
Ja, aber ich will nur sagen, das war der Zustand, wo sozusagen die Leute angefangen haben mit IMAP und haben sich dann überlegt, jetzt machen wir es. Wie das immer so ist mit so Dingen, die dann am Schreibtisch designt werden, jetzt wollten sie sozusagen die Eier legende Wollmilchsau mit Soße und Scharf generieren. Und das haben sie dann auch getan. Die Idee ist, dass man sozusagen mehrere Namensräume abbildet, dass man alles, was mit Messaging zu tun hat, per IMAP reintut, inclusive News zum Beispiel. Das heißt, man hat dann Namensräume geschaffen und dann gibt es auch solche Sachen wie den sogenannten Hierarchie-Separator, wenn du zum Beispiel heute ein Fallsystem anguckst, wir in unserer Unix-Welt haben ja einen Slash, die Windows-Leute haben einen Backslash, der sozusagen immer die Hierarchien zwischen den Direktoren separiert. Im News war das der Punkt, wer weiß nicht, wer noch NetNews kennt, so comp.net.tralala oder so, da war der Hierarchie-Separator ein Punkt. Andere Leute haben was ganz anderes gemacht. Und diesen ganzen Wirrwarr, also vom Prinzip die Abbildung eines Fallsystems fast, hat man versucht da irgendwie mit rein zu stopfen. Und damit man dann sozusagen die Möglichkeit hat, irgendwo in diesem Fallsystem einzusteigen, was nicht die Route ist, dafür gibt es diesen Path-Prefix. Ihr hattet das letzte Mal auch erwähnt, dass es Leute gibt, die zum Beispiel so einen Server haben, wo alle Mailboxen drin sind und Shared-Mailboxen und sonst irgendwas. Und deine eigene Inbox liegt irgendwo ein bisschen weiter unten und nicht oben in der Route. Dafür brauchst du sozusagen diesen Path-Prefix, um den da rein zu machen. Das ist allerdings heute relativ obsolet. Der ist übrigens deswegen immer nochmal wieder anders, weil es gibt unterschiedliche Mail-Server mit unterschiedlichen Hierarchy-Separators. Also diese Nummer mit dem Punkt gibt's immer noch. Zum Beispiel desiris oder das macht es ganz gerne. Alle Mailboxen heißen Inbox.irgendwas. Also Inbox.blabla.fasel.labor. Da lohnt es sich, diesen Path-Prefix auf Inbox zu stellen, damit du nicht immer dieses Ding da vorne dran hast. Du darfst aber keine Mailbox nennen, die einen Punkt drin hat. Weil das ist ja der, genauso wie du in der Unix keinen Pfeil anlegen kannst, der einen Slash drin hat. Geht nicht. Weil das ist ja der Separator.
Aber den Separator kann man nicht konfigurieren.
Den gibt der Server vor.
Im Server kannst du den schon konfigurieren. Zumindest bei manchen.
Das gibt dir Backends vor. Du hast ja gesagt, du betreibst auch einen DoveCod. DoveCod hat mehrere Backends. Also wie er die Mails hinten speichert. Mbox-Format, Dbox, SD-Box-Format, Mail-Dear-Format. Und je nachdem, was du da hast, dieses System gibt auch diesen Separator vor. Und der ist halt, wie gesagt, bei jedem Server auch irgendwie anders, und bei manchen irgendwie echt krank. Also mit diesem Inbox-Punkt, das finde ich echt krass. Das kann man eigentlich nicht gebrauchen. So. Dann habe ich mir auf meine Liste aufgeschrieben, Trash-Mailboxen.
Das weiß ich aber immer noch nicht, was ich mit diesem Prefix irgendwie machen soll.
Das musst du wissen, das muss dir dein Server-Operator sagen. Ich kann dir jetzt nicht sagen, was für ein Server du hast. Aber du kannst sozusagen in diesen Namensbaum an einer anderen Stelle reinspringen als in der Route.
Gibt es denn einen IMAP-Browser, wo du sozusagen mit deinen Credentials dich bei dem IMAP-Server anmeldest und der dir sozusagen so bei deinem höchsten...
Okay, irgendwas vielleicht ein bisschen komfortableres.
Dann würd ich mal Pine im Debug-Modus oder sowas. Den guten Pine bzw. L-Pine im Debug-Modus.
Weil Apple Mail, da hast du ja nicht die Chance, so was rauszufinden.
Nee, die versuchen es vor dir zu verstecken. So, jetzt zu den kleinen Pesten, die es so gibt.
Jetzt die Logik, weil wenn du jetzt so das normale Mail abnimmst. Das präsentiert dir ja so die Inbox, TM. Und dann, wenn vorhanden für den Account noch weitere Ordner, die dann in diesem Sidebar weiter unten aufgeführt werden.
Oder Unterordner von denen.
Oder eben auch Unterordner dieser Inbox, was mir halt auch schon ein paar Mal passiert ist. Und das kommt halt vor allem dann, wenn du eben an diesem Pass-Prefix rumfummelst.
Nee, das kommt immer dann, wenn du mit so einem Cyrus-Mail-Server zu tun hast, der glaubt, dass alle deine Mailboxen unter deiner Inbox lägen. Das ist aber, wie gesagt, eine Sache, das hat mit deinem Apple-Mail nichts zu tun. Das ist eine Sache, die der Server, diese Hierarchie ansagen, wie heißt das alles und wie separieren wir das heute, sagt der Server.
Aber wo liegt normalerweise die Inbox?
Es gibt keinen normalerweise. Der Standard gibt das nicht vor. Bei den allermeisten Mail-Servern liegt sie in deiner Route. Mit einem leeren Path-Prefix liegt dort und übrigens die Inbox ist der einzige Ordner im IMAP-Standard, der eine spezielle Bedeutung hat. Ansonsten, dass es die Inbox ist und das Einzige daran special ist, dass die Inbox case-insensitive ist. Das ist der Ordner, den kannst du groß oder klein schreiben, das ist immer ein und dasselbe Ding. Es gibt sonst, was ihr als deleted oder send Ordner oder drafts oder tralala Ordner kennt, gibt es für IMAP völlig kein Standard, nichts. Na ja, da kommen wir noch zu. Aber da hat sich ein bisschen was getan. Aber der pure IMAP kennt nur als einzige special Mailbox die Inbox und das Einzige, was daran special ist, ist, dass ihr Name case-insensitive ist. Die Frage konkret jetzt, wo muss ich welchen Präfix anbringen, hängt wie gesagt von dem Server ab.
Und wenn der Cyrus ist, dann ist es wahrscheinlich Inbox als Part.
Inbox als Part, weil alle Mailboxen heißen dort Inbox.Tralala irgendwas. Das liegt aber am Cyrus. Das kann übrigens richtig wild sein. Wenn du so einen Server hast, der mehrere Namensbereiche abbildet, dann kann es sogar sein, dass du auf ein und dem selben Server unterschiedliche Hierarchy-Separators hast. In dem Mail-Bereich hast du vielleicht einen Hierarchy-Separator von Slash und in einem anderen Bereich, in dem News-Bereich hast du einen Hierarchy-Separator von Punkt. Das ist also nochmal richtig lecker. Ich dachte, ich habe das Zeug implementiert, ich habe diesen Standard mehrfach gelesen und gekotzt. Der Typ, der den übrigens gemacht hat, der heißt Mark Crispin, der den wesentliche Imap-Fehler beeinflusst hat, leider ein bisschen arroganter Knirch. Ich habe ein paar Mal auf der ITF mal angebufft, wegen ein paar komischen Design-Entscheidungen, die da so drinstehen. Die sind alle gnadenlos an ihm abgeprallt. Leider muss man sagen, der gute Mann liegt ernsthaft im Sterben, deswegen will ich jetzt nicht schlecht über ihn reden. Aber es ist teilweise ganz bitter. Zum Beispiel habe ich mich lange mit ihm gekloppt, warum es keinen Move gibt. In einem Imap-Server kannst du eine Mail nicht von A nach B moveen. Du kannst sie nur kopieren und dann an der Source löschen. Die Pest ist für jeden, der eine Quotaverwaltung haben will. Vor allen Dingen kommt es noch dazu, dass die Firma Microsoft das Thema mit dem Trash-Order aufgebracht hat. Der Imap-Standard sieht ja gar keinen Trash-Order vor. Der Imap-Standard sagt, wenn du eine Mail löschen willst, dann markierst du sie zum Löschen und dann gibst du ein spezielles Kommando, das nennt sich Expunge, damit wibest du die alle weg. Das bildet übrigens Apple Mail auch ab, das heißt bloß anders, das heißt bei Apple Mail, nennen sie das denn irgendwie Erase all deleted mails oder so was gibt es so einen Kommando, Erase deleted items oder so was heißt das. So funktioniert das eigentlich. Aber dann kam die Weltfirma Microsoft mit ihrem tollen Outlook oder Outlook Express und mit ihrem Schema, dass es diesen Mülleimer gibt. Und die haben überhaupt erst angefangen, Mails, wenn sie gelöscht werden sollen, umzuladen. Anstatt sie zum Löschen zu markieren, wurden sie dort einfach in den anderen Ordner umgelagert und dann würde irgendwann mal dieser Trash-Ordner gelöscht. So, wenn man sich jetzt dazu nimmt, dass es keinen Move gibt, hast du das Problem folgend, die Mailbox ist irgendwann mal voll. Du maulst den User an, sagst, hier geht nichts mehr. Lösch doch mal bitte Mail. Ja, dann geht sein Client hin und möchte gerne eine Mail in den Trash-Ordner kopieren. Dann sagt der Mailsober, ne, du kannst dir nichts kopieren, weil deine Mailbox ist ja voll.
Hätte es ein Move gegeben, würde das Problem schon nicht bestehen.
Interessant ist, jetzt, iMap gibt es jetzt, keine Ahnung, seit 20 Jahren oder so was, jetzt fangen sie an, wahrscheinlich weil Mark Whistler im Sterben liegt, haben sie sich gesagt, so jetzt hauen wir rein, jetzt gibt es jede Menge Add-Inims, unter anderem auch ein Move-Kommando. Und wie sieht das bei den Clients aus? Clients ist ganz interessant. Ihr habt ja letztes Mal auch ein bisschen gelästert über Mail ab. Die ist gar nicht so schlecht.
Das ist nicht ganz scheiße.
Also es gibt so ein paar Sachen, du hast vollkommen recht, diese Subscription-Nummer ist relativ harmlos gehandhabt, aber ich kann auch verstehen, warum. Weil diese Subscription-Feature ist eins der sinnlosesten Features, meiner Meinung nach, bei MAP. Weil es hat keinerlei Einfluss auf die Server-Operation. Es ist einfach nur so eine Merkliste für deinen Client, welche Mailboxen du besonders sexy findest. Ist einfach sozusagen eine auf dem Server liegende Merkliste.
Also bei so einer Firma, wo ich mal gearbeitet hab, da war das so, da gab es für jedes Projekt so ein IMAP-Folder, wo die ganze Mail von den Leuten, die da so involviert waren, auch nochmal so rein, also irgendwie war das so ein Sammelbecken für alle projektbezogene Mail. Und wenn du an dem Projekt angefangen hast zu arbeiten, dann hast du dich halt auf diesen Folder subscibed und hast halt auch immer so die ganze Kommunikation sozusagen in diesem Folder gehabt.
Aber das ist rein Protokoll, das macht aber dein Client. Rein vom Protokoll her, ein IMAP-Server macht mit dieser Subscription List, die der Client ihm gibt, nichts weiter als sie zu speichern. Der macht selber keinen Filter oder irgendwas drauf, sondern er drückt sie einfach wieder raus. Und der Apple hat sich einfach entschieden, das ist eine tolle Feature, aber wir benutzen das einfach mal nicht.
Das interessiert das nicht. Also ich hab ja dann halt hier bei mir eben noch so ein, auch so, ich hab ja meine, hatte ich ja auch schon tausendmal erzählt, aber irgendwie vier Mail-Accounts sind ein sozusagen zusammengelegt und das dann da auf dem Server alles so schön mit Sub-Foldern in der Inbox und Sub-Foldern im Send-Folder und so alles so mit Filter-Rules und so gemanagt. Und das Apple Mail hat da auch regelmäßig zum Beispiel so dazwischen gegrätscht und dann doch wieder irgendwie die Folder doppelt irgendwo anders hin kopiert oder abgesehen von diesen ganzen To-Do's und was es da nicht noch alles für tolle Features in Apple Mail gibt, wo dann extra Folder zugemüllt werden. Aber es kam halt überhaupt nicht klar mit irgendwie, ah Moment, da gibt's jetzt mehrere Unterfolder und was, wie Moment?
Also das funktioniert inzwischen ganz gut. Also ich betreibe auch einen DoveCod, auch mit einem ordentlichen Backend dahinter. Das geht ganz gut. Die grundsätzliche Pest und das war ja auch Bestandteil der Diskussion letztes Mal ist, dass es wie gesagt vom Standard her keine Definition für diese Special Ordner gibt. Der Standard sagt nicht, wenn du einen Drafts Ordner hast, dann heißt der Drafts. Haben die nie definiert. Wie gesagt, das Einzige was drinsteht ist Inbox fertig.
Und das ist das Schöne bei Postbox zum Beispiel, da kannst du diese ganzen Folder auch konfigurieren. Das heißt, du kannst halt sagen, mein Send-Folder soll jetzt so heißen, dann soll in dem Folder liegen und so.
Ja, geht aber schon relativ lange. Es war nur schwierig zu finden am Anfang.
Der Problem ist, wenn du mit mehr als einem Client am Start bist. Das hat Tim mir auch erwähnt. Du hast halt ein iPhone-Mail und ein Apple-Mail und vielleicht noch irgendwo ein Web-Mail, was oben drauf sitzt. Es gibt jetzt seit zwei Jahren, gibt es einen Standard, ich hab den extra noch mal rausgesucht, seit März 2011, kommt aus der Ecke von Huawei und Google, gibt es eine Erweiterung, dass der Serverbetreiber einen unverbindlichen Vorschlag machen kann, wie man doch Ordner nennt. Also einfach nur so ein Hint. Dass der Client fragen kann, gibt es hier einen Special-Ordner, der Drafts enthalten soll? Und wenn ja, wie sollte der denn heißen?
Also die Naming-Conventions, zentral.
Die Naming-Conventions, dass man die haben kann. Das größte Problem ist nicht nur, dass die nicht im Standard drin stehen, sondern dass es eben dann auch Weltfirmen gibt, wie Microsoft, die das Feld dadurch versorgt haben, dass sie das mit durch ihre Internationalisation durchgeprügelt haben. Das heißt, und dann gibt es, deswegen hast du nicht nur Send-Items oder denn Gesendete oder Gesendete lalala oder so. Und das wird wie gesagt auch noch, da gibt es ohnehin so Sachen. Also der Standard sagt zum Beispiel, dass die Ordner-Namen im Protokoll als UTF-7 übergeben werden sollen. Das hat man bei Microsoft die ersten Jahre hochgeflissentlich überlesen und erst mit ISO 8891 benahmten Foldern und jetzt mit UTF-8 vollgekackt, was natürlich auch wieder Chaos ohne Ende bringt. Und wie gesagt, dadurch, dass sie nicht drinstehen. Und dann gibt es ja wie gesagt noch diese Firmen wie Apple, die diese Internationalisation anders machen, indem sie denen nämlich was anderes vorlügen. Das heißt, sie legen einen Ordner an, den sie auf dem Server drafts nennen, die aber in deinem User-Interface immer das Wort Entwürfe anzeigen. Das ist besonders sexy, wenn du dann nämlich mal an einen anderen Kleinen gehst und deine scheiß Entwürfe suchst. Die gibt es da nämlich nirgendwo. Also das ist wirklich ein, wie würde Steve sagen, a bag of hurt. Aber wie gesagt, es gibt ja so ein paar Sachen, die Apple Leute sind gar nicht so schlecht. Die können sehr viele moderne Standards, gerade das Apple-Mail oder die Mail-App auf dem iPhone ist relativ sexy. Die machen auch so Sachen, die dir leider das Debugging ein bisschen erschweren. Als ich damit angefangen habe, ein bisschen zu basteln, auch mit dem iPhone, haben wir gedacht, ach jetzt guckst du mal, was der Client eigentlich so alles sendet. Oh ja, wir benutzen ja SSL, macht ja nichts. Ich hab ja mal einen Private Key. Du kannst ja, Wireshark, kannst du ja so einen Private Key mitgeben und kannst die SSL-Session mit angucken. Ja, das nächste Kommando, was danach kommt, ist, dass das Apple-Mail sagt, oh wir machen jetzt mal Kompression an. Aber das ist relativ moderne Zeug, was das so macht. Was Apple-Mail auf dem iPhone leider nicht macht, immer wieder Kritikpunkt, ist das sogenannte Idle-Kommando. Das ist nämlich ein Kommando, wo der Client sagen kann, ich mach jetzt mal nix. Server sagt, du mir mal was schreibt, wenn sich bei dir was tut. Was ja wichtig ist für Synchronisation. Du willst jetzt wissen, es kommt eine neue Mail rein und die willst du nicht da unten immer pollen. Bei Pop3 musst du immer pollen. Bei IMAP kannst du dich auf die Inbox draufsetzen und sagen, ich hab jetzt nix zu tun, jetzt spiel ich mal den Ball zu dir rüber, Server. Wenn da sich was tut, sag mir Bescheid. Das machen sie auf dem iPhone leider nicht. Da machen sie ihre proprietäre Push-Kacke.
Aber es hält sich auch voraus, dass du deine TCP-Connection aufrecht hältst.
Genau das, was du nicht willst. Das machen sie mit ihren Push-Dingern ja auch. Das Ding hat ja auch da und die TCP-Verbindung ist ja ihr Push-Server. Nur diese eine sozusagen. Ja, nur diese eine. Aber gut, wie ich auch sage, abgesehen davon ist dann auch wieder das Problem, dass iDLE dir auch nicht verrät, ob jemand einen neuen Ordner anlegt oder dir was in einen anderen Ordner reinstopft. Dafür gibt es wieder eine neue Extension. Also iMap ist von daher zumindest interessant, weil nach meinem Dafürhalten der Standard ist der, der am meisten erweitert wurde bisher. Also das kann ich hier noch mal einen kurzen Link nochmal heroben. Es gibt einen Wiki, wo diese ganzen Specks drin sind und welcher Client und welcher Server was implementiert. Das haue ich jetzt einfach mal so kommentarlos in den Chat. Dieses iMap-Wiki. Da kann man mal so sehen, was es überhaupt gibt, was es noch für Erweiterungen gibt und welcher Server, welcher Client jetzt da was spielt. Und da sieht man übrigens auch, dass der DoF Code sozusagen weit vorne ist.
Der ist noch am grünsten.
Der hat auch dafür gesorgt, dass der eine oder andere sich hinsetzt und so ein bisschen Hausaufgaben macht. Ich kann mich noch erinnern, als das so rauskam und die dann so gleich rumtrompetet haben, wir sind jetzt hier mal die Einzigen, die das mit dem iMap mal so vollständig gemacht haben, da ging es dann auch erstmal, oh, wie jetzt, Moment.
Da gibt es wahnsinnig viele Low-Hanging-Fruits. Wenn ich gerade sehe, die iMap-ID-Extension, das ist sozusagen, dass sie sich gegenseitig verraten, wer sie sind. Da sagt ein iPhone, macht übrigens ein iPhone, sagt, ich bin ein iPhone, mit US-Version, mit iOS-Version und tralala und Pipapo, also verrät eine ganze Menge. Und dann sagt der Server, ja, haha, ich bin ein Duffkart oder sowas. Aber das sind alles relativ simple Sachen, die aber in letztem Jahr hinzugekommen sind. Dann gibt es zum Beispiel sehr viele Sachen, die spannend sind für mobile Geschichten. Da kann man zumindest mal kurz mal erzählen, was da so die Ideen ist. Bisher ist ja die E-Mail-Welt so getrennt, so ein bisschen in Senden und Empfang. Zum Senden halt die ganze SMTP-Schiene und zum Empfangen halt, oder nicht Empfangen, sondern zum Abrufen halt eben IMAP. Da gibt es auch schon Überschneidungen zwischen. Dass du zum Beispiel, wenn du eine Mail auf einem mobilen Device weiterleitest, musst du sie bisher runterladen auf das mobile Device, um sie dann per SMTP wieder rauszuschicken, was ja ein bisschen dämlich ist. Da gibt es dann eben so Zusammenspiel zwischen IMAP und SMTP, wo der IMAP-Server der Client sagen kann, lieber IMAP-Server, gib mir doch mal einen All, einen Unique All auf diese Mail, inclusive Authentication und tralala und pipapo, anstatt der Mail selber. Und dann kann er beim Versenden der Mail dem SMTP-Server sagen, hier pack doch mal bitte an dieser Stelle das rein, was du unter diesem All findest.
Das ist doch alles, das braucht doch keiner.
Es funktioniert, das iPhone macht das, das iPhone macht diese Geschichte, wenn die Server das unterstützen. Also von daher ist es zwar ein neumodischer Schnickschnack, aber es gibt immerhin Kleinstuffer, die das tun. So viel dazu.
Hast du auch noch irgendwas auf deiner Liste mit den weltweiten Internets?
Einfach vor vier Themen von gestern.
Ich arbeite ja bei dieser Firma, die diese Software macht, wo man bei eBay Auktionen hochladen kann. Garage Sale genannt.
Oho, da muss ich doch gleich mal kaufen.
Da gibt es schon seit einiger Zeit einen Image-Service zu, wo wir quasi einen Server haben, wo die Bilder hochgespielt werden und in die Auktionen werden dann halt nur die Links auf diese Bilder reingefügt, weil vor einigen Jahren hat halt irgendwie jedes einzelne Bild bei eBay noch extra gekostet. Da war das halt so ein Add-on-Service hier, kannst du Bilder hochladen.
Das ist jetzt nicht mehr so, ja? Jetzt haben sie jetzt drin in ihrer Kalkulation.
Man kriegt mehr Bilder umsonst. Also wenn du noch 20 Bilder brauchst, musst du auch irgendwann bezahlen oder so. Und dann stand irgendwann ein Umzug von dem Server an, irgendwie Provider gewechselt. Ich weiß jetzt die genauen Details nicht, aber der Server sollte gewechselt werden, weil irgendwie ein anderer Anbieter glaube ich ein besseres Angebot und so weiter. Und beim neuen Provider haben wir dann den Server gekriegt. Der funktionierte auch ganz normal und gut, aber es häuften sich ganz strange Problemreports von Usern. Nein, der Provider war Host Europe. Also da gab es User, die konnten den Server nicht erreichen und konnten überhaupt nicht hochladen. Dann gab es User, die konnten ganz normal hochladen, aber bei manchen anderen Usern wurden die Bilder nicht angezeigt, weil die den Server nicht erreichen konnten. Und es dauerte eine Weile und dann kam heraus, dass der Server in der Class A Netzwerk mit 5 vorne range war.
5 slash 8.
5 slash 8. 5 slash 8. Und jetzt musst du wahrscheinlich die Details so ein bisschen ausfüllen. Irgendwie war das wohl so, dass die RIPE dieses 5 slash 8 Netzwerk hatte, irgendwann mal zugeteilt bekommen hat und gesagt hat...
In den letzten Jahren erst.
In den letzten Jahren erst. Auf jeden Fall war irgendwie das übliche Understanding, die 5 range Adressen, die werden nicht benutzt, die teilen wir nicht aus und so weiter. Und dann haben diverse VPN Software Hersteller gemeint, da gibt es noch ein Slash-8-Netzwerk, das können wir einfach benutzen, also nehmen wir das mal, dieses Fünfer-Netzwerk.
Diesen Irrtum sind auch andere Firmen unterlegen, zum Beispiel T-Mobile USA hat ihre gesamte Infrastruktur vor ein paar Jahren auf 5 Slash-8 aufgebaut. Als ich sie darauf hingewiesen habe, dass das aber nicht kein RFC-1918-Netz ist, dass das mittelfristig irgendwann mal rausgegeben wird, der ging natürlich nach Dev-Ignore, aber die hatten jetzt auch ein bisschen Schmerz.
Also ich hatte auch mal bei Artcom damals auch so ein Problem, dass ich Slideshare oder so nie von Artcom aus erreichen konnte und dachte mir immer, es war halt immer so sporadisch, bin ich so auf die Webseite gegangen, hab irgendwie nicht gecheckt, dass es immer nur bei Artcom nicht ging, sondern ich dachte immer, wenn ich was von denen will, gibt's das nicht. Dann hab ich auf Twitter gerannt, dann kam da aber auch gleich ein Typ oder einer von denen und meinte so, lass mal gucken. Dann stellte sich aber auch raus, dass am Ende die 172er IP hatten und das halt eine Zeit lang auch eher so ein mystisches Private Range oder sowas war.
Ich hab den Range nicht verstanden. Von diesen privaten Netzen gibt's ja drei Bereiche. Es gibt 10 slash 8, 172, 16 slash 12 und das ist eine Nibbelgrenze, keine Beidgrenze, das ist nämlich das Böse da dran und 192, 168 slash 16. Und jetzt sagen sich viele Leute, ok, den 10er, den benutzen manche doofen Router und den 192, 68er benutzen sie auch. Also nehmen wir den 172, den benutzt bestimmt keine Sau. Kriegen den aber mit der Netzmaske nicht geregelt.
Aber in dem Fall war es anders. In dem Fall hat der die Firewall, da war konfiguriert, dass halt irgendwie alles, was rausgeht, mit 172, mit 10 und so weiter, das machen wir alles gar nicht. Und da war halt das auch noch so.
Ja, aber die ist dann halt eben die falsche Netzmaske, weil die 12er kriegen die Leute nicht geregelt, die richtig einzustellen. Aber es ist auch so klassisch. Aber es wird halt eng. Du merkst dann, es wird wirklich eng, wenn selbst diese Sachen, die jahrzehntelang keine Sau benutzt wird, jetzt benutzt werden, ja, jedes Bit wird irgendwo ausgeknutscht.
Damit kann man die Leute eigentlich doch prima überreden, IPv6 zu benutzen. Nehmen wir jetzt immer mal wieder so, irgendwie so, ehemals private Ranges so einfach rausgibst und dann irgendwie so die ganze Welt in.
Und das Ende vom Lied war übrigens, wir haben noch einen Server gebucht unter der Maßgabe, ihr gebt uns aber keinen Server im achter Netz. Im fünfer Netz. Haben die dann auch gemacht und den alten halt gekündigt.
Das geht jetzt auch schon. Es gibt auch sehr viele Tippfehler oder Dämlichkeiten dabei. Ich hatte glaube ich mal in dem anderen Podcast mal erwähnt, das 192.68.0 und eins gehören mir. Glaubt gar nicht, ich kann die nicht benutzen, seit Jahren schon. Wenn ich die anmache, glüht mein Router einmal hell auf und ist weg. Weil es so viele Leute gibt, die sich bei dem eintippen der 192.68.0 Adressen vertippen und die eins weglassen. Und das multiplizierst du mit ein paar Milliarden Leuten auf der Welt.
Das ist ungefähr so, als würdest du dich im Telefon beruhen, der Justin Bieber eintragen.
Genau.
Bieber denn nur mit I oder so. Das ist irgendwie schräg.
Einfach so. Naja, das sind so die Schmerzen im Netz. Aber wie du schon sagst, es kann jetzt wirklich sein, dass die Schmerzen jetzt immer größer werden und das IPv6 irgendwann wirklich so die Fluchttür ist. Deswegen rede ich jetzt auch wirklich auf alle meine Provider ein, die noch nicht irgendwie das mit dem V6 haben.
Naja, richtig Provider hast du so.
Es ist echt die Low Hanging Fruit inzwischen. Wer heute noch sagt, er könne das nicht, der soll sich einfach rausstellen in Regen und Schämen.
Ja, aber es gibt zum Beispiel, in meinem Fall ist es so, ein Provider, der seine Kapazität von einem anderen Provider kriegt. Da sozusagen komplett hinterhängt.
Dann soll er sich in den Hurricane Electric Tunnel schalten. Drei Minuten Tipparbeit auf dem Cisco. Also wirklich, bitte.
Ja gut, für den überschaubaren Traffic, den das dann auch am Anfang erst mal erzeugt.
Nicht mehr lange.
Nicht mehr lange. Nächster Kongress wird sicherlich den Incoming-Traffic deutlich über die 50 Prozent heben können. Da bin ich mal recht sicher. Es wurde auch schon gewitzelt, dass auf dem nächsten Kongress gar kein IPv4 mehr eingeschaltet wird.
Ja, das wär doch mal eine... oh jetzt hab ich's ausgemacht.
Beim Nock gefragt, ob da irgendwas dran sein könnte, dass man irgendwann vielleicht nur noch V6 hat. Maybe never.
Nix, nix, mein Arduino Ethernet, der kann kein V6.
Was, Arduino kann kein V6?
Noch nicht.
Es gibt so ein Arduino Ethernet. Im Prinzip ist es ein richtiger Chip, der hängt an dem Arduino dran und macht das ganze Netzwerk. Und der Arduino kann dann mal nachfragen, sind da ein paar byte gekommen?
Das ist schon interessant. Wir werden unter Umständen jetzt mit diesem ganzen Internet of Things-Ding ich denke, es ist nicht so unwahrscheinlich, dass wir bald so V6-only-Devices haben werden. So Geräte, wo man gar nicht sich mehr den Schuh anziehen will, das jetzt noch mit V4 zu betreiben.
Aber ich meine, V4 wird ja nicht abgeschaltet, oder? Also da gibt es ja keinen Plan, oder? Das heißt, es wird ja nach wie vor diese paar Milliarden Adressen...
Du hast schon V6-only-Dinger. Also eigentlich, wenn sie aus der Kiste kommen, diese ganzen Apple, Airport Express, Apple TV oder sowas, ist alles V6-only. Erst wenn du dem später, sozusagen, erst in einer viel späteren Phase, wenn du das erkennt, ich komme nicht woanders hin, dann hol ich mir per DRCP noch was. Aber die Apple-Leute benutzen das zwischen ihrem Equipment und deinem Rechner, wenn sie können, ist alles V6 schon länger. Weil sie eben nicht diese Konfigurationsthematik haben. Sondern du wachst einfach und hast eine Adresse. Ich denke, also bin ich.
Ich denke, also ping ich.
So muss es aber auch sein. Aber ich meinte halt auch Geräte, die dann noch nicht mal eine Konfigurationsoption vorsehen für V4.
Also die sprichwörtliche Glühlampe. Wir haben darüber Glühlampen gesprochen und just zwei, drei Wochen später kamen zwei, drei Kickstarter-Projekte. Also wie heißt diese US-Plattform dort?
Doch, Kickstarter gibt es.
Kickstarter ist die. Mit irgendwelchen Glühlampen. So mehrere. Zwei oder drei.
Ja und die auch alle nur V6 hatten, glaube ich, oder?
Ich glaube die DHCP bestimmt noch. Aber immerhin Glühlampen. Das Internet der Dinge.
Das erhöht halt deine Komplexität nicht unerheblich. So. Also wenn wir jetzt wirklich von so einem miniaturisierten Minimal-Ding ausgehen, was dann nicht viel Kommunikation betreibt und eben auch nicht viel Konfiguration betreiben will und sich vielleicht im Idealfall noch nicht mal was merken will. Also V4 musst du dir ja nach dem Betrieb was holen und merken. Das ist schon eigentlich eine ganze Menge.
So.
Für so ein kleines Gerät, was nur aus einem Mini-Chip besteht und eigentlich nicht viel tun will. Das wäre viel einfacher, dass es einfach wach wird und ich denke, also ping ich, dann einfach sofort da ist.
Da fällt mir noch so ein Spruch, wie Scottie TM hat irgendwann mal auch so im Club in so einer Abendrunde gemeint, ping mich, scan mich, gib mir. Host-Namen.
Heute nach wie vor, wie vor 30 Jahren, immer der größte Schmerz beim Aufbauen. Adressfrage ist alles kein Thema mehr, aber dann kommt die Frage, gut ist das Ding gesagt, so wie soll ich denn jetzt heißen?
Denkst du, Host-Namen? So ist mein Nickname entstanden. Irgendwie saß ich auch vorm Rechner und fragte ihn nach so einem Namen, dann auf die Tastatur gehauen und dann stand da Huckel.
Du hast inzwischen alles durch. Ich weiß noch, bei Art & Com gab es diese ganze Kaufhauskette und Lidl und Aldi und KDW und das. Oder dann die ganze Disney-Mickey-Maus-Serie. Was haben wir nicht alle durchprobiert?
Ich denke, das gleiche, woran ich aufdenke.
Bei der UDK?
Nee.
Wir hatten auch bei Art & Com, wo wir irgendwie den Namespace hatten, Orte, an denen große Katastrophen passiert sind.
An der UDK, also hier Universität der Künstler, da hatten sie es ganz weise ausgewählt, Schriftnamen und es gibt Milliarden von Schriften und jedes Wort, was dir einfällt, dazu gibt es auch garantiert eine Schrift von daher.
Das war echt gut. Ja, so von der Lucida, mal eben auch die Garamond und so.
Danke für den Hint. Ich wollte hier noch einen Werbeblog, der steht auf meiner Liste. Ich habe einen Font entdeckt, der kam neulich mal oben getwittert.
Okay, warte mal, bevor du das sagst, Herr Murnau, warst du...
Nein, jetzt den Werbeeinblendung aus...
Nein, ich bin mit meinem V4, V6 Ding sofort fertig. Ich wollte nur noch einen Satz sagen. Man muss sich einfach daran gewöhnen, dass wir demnächst die Welt haben werden, wo es Geräte gibt, die dann wirklich nur noch V6 machen und die so Geräten gegenüberstehen, die eigentlich nur V4 richtig können.
Aus welchen Gründen auch immer?
Die stehen ihnen eben nicht gegenüber.
Eben, und dann stehen sie sich... Genau, das ist so ein bisschen wie Apple Talk und IP.
Die rufen aneinander vorbei und gut ist.
Gut, Web-Fonts.
Nein, nur ein Font. Und zwar, ich glaube, der kommt von Adobe. Adobe hat einen Font frei rausgerückt für Ume und sonst.
Wie hieß der noch gleich?
Source Code Pro. Source Code Pro ist ein Font, den ich sehr gerne so in Terminal und so jetzt benutze, weil es ist nämlich ein Font, der genau zum Programmieren gedacht ist, wo man die eckigen von den geschweiften Klammern schön unterscheiden kann, die Null von den O's und die Eins von dem I und dem L und so. Also ich bin ja... Sehr schön Mono-based-Font, der wie gesagt umsonst für Ume zu laden ist und ich finde ihn auch sehr schön.
Ich bin ja tatsächlich seit Apple da diese Menlo zum Default gemacht hat, bin ich ja auf der Menlo hingeblieben. Ich finde, das ist ja tatsächlich meine neue Lieblings-Terminal-Schrift geworden seitdem.
Menlo.
Also falls ihr immer nur abgegradet habt und nicht clean installed habt, dann ist euer Default-Terminal-Schrift wahrscheinlich, oder je nach Thema, oder Theme, was ihr ausgewählt habt, immer noch die Monaco. Aber die Monaco ist wirklich die hässlichste von allen. Und die Menlo...
Guck mal, was hab ich denn hier? Ich verwende Andale Mono.
Das ist auch noch mal was anderes. Aber die Menlo ist halt, ich finde die sehr schön. Die hat halt auch genau diese Features. Eins, kleines L.
Oh ja, die ist auch schön.
Großes I, Null und so weiter. Die ist auch sehr schön. Also ich finde da hat Apple auf jeden Fall eine ganz gute Schrift.
Aber sie ist ein bisschen fetter auch, sie ist dicker auch.
Naja, sie ist halt auch dafür gemacht, irgendwie Anti-Alias zu sein.
Genau, das war ja bei der Monaco immer das Ding, wenn du die halt auf Anti-Alias, dann ist die halt so super weggeschwommen, gerade in klein. Und die funktioniert halt in super kleinen Größen und in super großen und sie sieht nie richtig scheiße aus. Und das fand ich schon. Oder sagen wir es anders, eigentlich sieht sie in allen Umständen ziemlich gut aus.
Ich hab die auch einmal angemacht und das war's.
Sie ist dicker, sie füllt mehr, also ich hab ja meine Terminates immer noch weiß auf schwarz. Und das war jetzt deutlich so richtig so pfff.
Also ich sag jetzt auch nicht, dass es die einzige ist. Ich wollte nur nochmal anmerken, dass ich eigentlich mit dieser Menlo sehr glücklich geworden bin, seitdem sie das gemacht haben. Und diese Monaco ist wirklich, also wenn man, also nee, das kann...
War in den 80ern aber okay. Aber da gab es damals schon irgendwie so eine Ersatzschrift, wo jemand irgendwie die Klammern größer gemacht hat, sodass man die besser auseinandergehalten hat.
Ja, ich weiß, die Monaco fand ich schon immer eigentlich scheiße, aber naja, egal.
So weit auseinander sind die jetzt noch auch nicht, ne?
Menlo und...
Na, all die...
Nee, die sind... Ändert sich das jetzt gerade überhaupt? Nee, das ändert sich nicht. Das würde sich sonst sofort ändern.
Ja, das ist ganz komisch. Das ändert sich nicht, wenn ich über die Favorites gehe.
Ja, muss man halt irgendwie eine Weile mal mit unterschiedlichen Situationen ausprobieren. Genau, hier meint auch gerade einer im Chat irgendwie, die Menlo ist fast dieselbe wie die Deja-Vu, Sans, Mono und da gibt es so... Die gehört zu so einer Familie von... Also da gibt es so zwei, drei Schriften, die relativ ähnlich sind. Die Menlo, diese Deja-Vu und dann gab es noch eine, die auch sehr ähnlich ist. Und da gibt es natürlich auch für jedes Lager jetzt einen, der dann sagt, ja, aber die ist auf jeden Fall die beste von allen. Das muss man dann schon selber für sich rausfinden.
Aber du meinst, das nimmt sich nicht so viel?
Ja, also ich habe schon eine ganz klare Meinung, warum ich jetzt die Menlo am tollsten finde, aber ich habe mir die Buchstaben schon alle angeguckt, aber...
Schau dir doch mal die Sourcecode auch nochmal an.
Wir können das ja mal reviewen zum nächsten Mal. Guck mal alle nochmal, was sich so an Terminal-Schriften noch anbietet.
Auf der anderen Seite, dass ich meine Adobe-Produkte empfehle, das sag ich mir jetzt auch nicht empfehlen.
Du wirst alt.
Ja gut, theoretisch können sie das ja ganz gut.
Das ist ganze Adobe-Scheiße.
Ja, das mit den Schriften, da sind sie lange hier noch dabei.
Nee, das meine ich nicht, sondern diese ganzen Applikations-Dreck. Wenn du zum Beispiel, wenn du einen Mac, Apple hat das ja alle so schön designt, du kaufst den neuen Mac, machst den an, der fragt dich, hast du noch einen alten Mac, soll ich die Daten kopieren? Haben wir alle Dutzendmal gemacht. Geht auch mit allem. Geht sogar mit dem Microsoft-Dreck. Nicht mit der Adobe-Scheiße. Die möchte auf jeden Fall neu installiert werden. Kannst du noch keinen Backup einspielen? Nein, sie möchte neu installiert werden. Und das ist echt...
Klickt mal ganz kurz da diesen Menlo vs. Deja-Vu-Link nochmal kurz an, weil da sieht man dann, wie nah die... letzter Link sozusagen in der Liste. Genau, da sieht man jetzt mal die beiden kurz übereinander gelegt und sieht dann auch, dass da Apple eigentlich nur das Sternchen, das das Asteris ein bisschen größer gemacht hat, den Bindestrich ein bisschen elaborierter. Und ansonsten nehmen die sich nicht so wahnsinnig... Achso, und bei der Null statt einem Punkt in der Mitte halt ein Strich, also kriegst du da... Also, ist noch ein bisschen ausgeprägter, die Menlo vielleicht, aber...
Stern ist größer. Das mag ich immer nicht, wenn der Stern so hoch gesetzt ist.
Das mag ich auch nicht, wenn der oben steht.
Der Stern muss schon irgendwie zentral sein.
Ja, und ich finde auch diesen etwas, also den wirklich gemonos-baseden Bindestrich, finde ich auch super. Das mit dem Punkt in der Null oder dem Strich, da bin ich, glaube ich, da könnte ich mit mir reden lassen, aber... Also zwischen den beiden gibt es zumindest, wenn man jetzt einen Linux hat oder halt nicht einen Mac, wo es jetzt die Menlo vielleicht nicht gerade mal ebenso als die voll zum Aushehlen gibt, dann kann man diese Déjà-Vu Sans-Mono nehmen. Und die ist halt wieder based on Bitstream Vera Sans-Mono. Genau, das war die dritte im Bunde. Jetzt haben wir sie alle zusammen. Und jetzt haben wir diese ganzen...
Finde es schon erstaunlich, dass Apple wirklich da die Mühe macht, da nochmal so einen Font. Ich meine, was haben sie da geändert? Die haben jetzt irgendwie so ein paar Zeichen.
Ja, aber genau die richtigen. Der Punkt ist größer, das Komma ist größer, der Stern ist größer.
Der Wind ist größer.
Schau dir die eckigen Klammern an. Wenn du den ganzen Tag nur Objective-C machst, dann tippst du so viele eckige Klammern wie nie in deinem Leben. Und wenn die nicht ordentlich aussehen, dann hat eine Schrift schon verloren.
Ja, auch der Punkt und so, das Komma. Es geht darum, wirklich so diese kleinen Zeichen, die man so schnell mal übersehen kann. Genau, einfach more in your face.
Was für mich immer noch wichtig ist, bei so einem Fund, ich meine, klar, ich programmiere jetzt keine Objective-C, aber...
Noch nicht.
Nee, dann bin ich auch echt zu alt für zu viele Klammern. Aber... Was für mich immer noch wichtig ist, da ich ja dann eher so ein Messaging-Freak und so bin, ich hätte gerne komplette Funds. Komplett heißt, dass da nicht bloß das ASCII funktioniert. Und nicht nur das Roman One, sondern dass vielleicht sogar noch Chorylisch auch noch geht und so und so ein paar andere Sachen. Das muss jetzt nicht das letzte Hangul-Zeichen noch komplett sein, ja. Aber das, was wir so in unserem europäischen Sprachraum haben, hätte ich ganz gerne. Und zwar nicht als Kästchen, sondern so als...
Aber da hast du ja bei Apple dann relativ gute Karten, die haben ja schon...
Ja, die Apple-Fonds. Aber das ist halt eben bei Fonds, die von woanders kommen oder...
Aber genau, deswegen...
Open Source-Fonds führen eben hinter ISO 889, 59, 21 auf und wenn du richtig bettelst, kriegst du noch ein Euro-Zeichen und das wartet dann aber auf.
Die schönste Schrift, da gibt's eine Areal-Variante, die zu irgendeinem Zeitpunkt, also sie wird auch immer geabdeckt, ich hab jetzt den Namen gerade vergessen, aber die hat immer den kompletten Unicode-Satz drin. Und das letzte Mal, als ich sie mir runtergeladen hat, war sie bei 22 Megabyte. Dieses OTF-File.
Und die wurde auch Koreanisch ist a big bag of hurt, wenn du dir die mal anguckst. Das im Unicode-Buch ist.
Genau. Areal Unicode-MS ist das vielleicht. Also ich weiß nicht, bei Apple ist sie mittlerweile auch tatsächlich dabei, aber man kann sie halt auch immer in der vollen Version so richtig einmal Anschlag herunterladen. Ich frag mich ja, weil jetzt auch bei Unicode so viele dazugekommen sind, ob die jetzt schon mal 40 Megabyte sind oder... Also falls mal jemand eine Schrift haben will...
Ist ja immer noch kein Klingonisch drin.
Areal Unicode-MS.
Ich glaube, das ist die, ja.
Aber da gibt's, ich glaube, das ist diese OpenType-Schrift, wenn man da versucht, mal den Apfel aufzumachen, bekommt man ein ganz komisches Zeichen und das ist irgend so ein klingonisches Zeichen.
Der Apfel im Sinne von der Apple-Apfel.
Der Apple-Apfel.
Na gut, den gibt's ja eigentlich nicht. Den hat ja Apple wirklich da so rein forciert in diese Fonts.
Jaja, an so eine Stelle, wo halt so ein, hier könnt ihr alles was rein tun.
So ein 5-8-Wartet.
Da, wo so irgendwie sowas. Da, wo auch Emoji drin ist.
Und da ist da aber irgend so ein komisches klingonisches Sonst-Was-Symbol von irgendeiner Kriegskaste.
Ne, ne, ernsthaft, es gab ja mal diese, diese Star Trek-Fiek, haben ja wirklich richtig mit Formularausfüllen, lalala, bei der Standardisierungskommission mal eingereicht, irgendwo sitzen die in Dänemark oder so was, hatte irgendwas mit Dänemark zu tun. Und man sagt so hier, klingonische Schrift und so. Und die sind echt ernsthaft bearbeitet worden, denn nur auf den letzten, auf den letzten Metern mit irgendwelchen, wegen irgendwelcher Formalitäten irgendwie niedergewürstet worden. Aber es gab echt ernsthaft Vorschläge, klingonisch in den Unicode- Zeichensatz mit aufzunehmen.
Ja, andere Leute haben nur Hobbys.
Da, finde ich, gibt es ganz andere Sachen, die man mal in den Zeichensatz mit aufnehmen sollte. Und in dem Zusammenhang wollte ich auch mal einen kleinen Font-Tipp bzw. eine Font-Diskussion starten. Kennen wahrscheinlich einige von euch, der ist nicht der Einzige, aber ist so einer von den verbreiteteren glaube ich im Web. Hier geht es primär um einen Web-Font, der aber auch eigentlich im Prinzip als normaler Font verfügbar ist, nämlich der Font Awesome, der so ein bisschen so ein Font ist für das moderne Web, wo man so all diese Zeichen drin hat, die man eben so braucht. Also Download-Icons, Lightbulbs, so Pfeile von links nach rechts, Kaffee essen.
Safe-Icons, die keine Diskette mehr darstellen?
Ja, Safe, ich weiß gar nicht, ist hier Safe überhaupt irgendwie vorgesehen?
Im Web safen? Wo willst du denn im Web hin safen? Dafür gibt es das eigentlich auch.
Da mit der Diskette.
Da gibt es auch noch eine Diskette.
Ist die auch verkehrt rum, so wie bei Word?
Ja, wie verkehrt rum?
Die Word-Diskette war immer verkehrt rum. Wenn du da mal eine richtige Diskette dagegen gehalten hast, dann war die irgendwie spiegelverkehrt und stimmt da irgendwie nicht.
Die haben doch diese Ecke. Wenn du die Ecke siehst, dann siehst du aber das Loch nicht, oder das Loch von unten, oder diese Drehmechanismus anstelle der Schublade. Hast du jetzt keine Diskette, Tim?
Nicht mal das hab ich hingehauen.
Auf jeden Fall sind ein paar schöne Sachen drin, so Paperclips und vor allem so schöne Sachen für Bullet-List-Lists überhaupt. Pfeile in alle Richtungen, in allen Formen, invers, mit Kreisturm-Runden.
Nee, das gibt's nicht alles in Unicode. Hallo gibt's im Unicode.
Aber nicht so auf die gleiche Größe gebürstet und nicht auf den gleichen Stil.
Die sind doch alle doch.
Ja, das gibt's in Unicode, aber du brauchst auch erstmal einen Fond, wo das halbwegs aussieht und vor allem brauchst du es auch als Webfond und so weiter.
Und wenn du dir das anguckst, wie das in der Verdana oder in der Geordie oder so dann aussieht, dann ist das halt manchmal auch echt Kraut und Rüben, wenn du die nebeneinander triffst.
Hier ist auch viel dabei, was nicht dabei ist, also ganzen Player, Sachen, Eject und so weiter, das hast du nicht in Unicode drin, ne?
Social Icons, Icon Twitter, wenn da mal ein Meta-Ebene-Icon auftaucht, dann hast du es geschafft.
Ist überhaupt das Original, jetzt ist es verfremdet, weil dürfen sie ja nicht benutzen, ne? Aber GitHub haben sie auch irgendwie drin, also keine Ahnung.
Also dann ist ja Meta, also wenn sie GitHub haben, dann können sie also wirklich jetzt mal hier auf die Meta-Ebene hinzufügen.
Ja, Icon Meta-Ebene, warum nicht?
Eigentlich braucht die Meta-Ebene ihren eigenen Zeitungssatz, oder?
Ja, wobei ehrlich gesagt, naja, da bin ich mir nicht so sicher, ob das jetzt unbedingt in so einen Fond rein muss. Ich weiß, es gibt auch noch so ein paar andere Fonds dieser Art. Jetzt geht so ein bisschen auch der Blick zu dir, Hucke.
Ja, ich... Kennst du da noch irgendwas? Ja, aber nicht so spontan. Da hätte es also, das muss ich mir immer wieder frisch...
Nicht mal vorher Bescheid sagen sollen. Das Problem, was ich mit Font Awesome habe, und vielleicht hat das ja irgendein Hörer gelöst, wenn ich mir das jetzt hier runter lade, zumindest zuletzt, als ich das ausprobiert habe, es gibt dann auch eine TrueType-Variante davon, aber wenn du die installierst, dann gelingt es mir nicht, auf dem Mac alle Zeichen da herauszubekommen. Also wenn ich mir so im Font Book dann sage, ja, hier Zeich mal, dann habe ich dann bestenfalls so ein Zehntel oder so des Zeichensatzes, den ich da irgendwie wirklich konkret visualisiert bekomme. Und ich bin mir nicht ganz so sicher, ob die da jetzt irgendwas falsch gemacht haben, oder ob ich da was falsch mache, oder ob das ein gädigeres Problem von Inkompatibilität zwischen Web-Fonts und normalen Fonts darstellt.
Gibt es da noch eine OpenType-Variante noch von?
Dann müsste ich jetzt mal nochmal den Download selber reinschauen.
Weil so für den Desktop ist dann OpenType schon erstmal die bessere Wahl.
Als TrueType meinst du? So, gucken wir nochmal, was da jetzt in dem Rahmen enthalten ist. Also es gibt hier einen Punkt EOT, TTF und Woff.
Und OTF. Und das wäre dann dein OpenType.
Double-Click.
Ah, ok, dann probier ich das mal aus. Install den Font.
Während er den installiert, was ich ja besonders cool fand, ist jetzt diese neue Tendenz, da so intelligente Fonts zu machen.
Hatte Tim auch hier einmal gezeigt, so...
Das ist mich auch schon ziemlich...
Wo du so Diagramme und so, so Tortendiagramme plötzlich damit malen konntest, ja.
Blinkenlites, es gibt einen Blinkenlites-Font?
Ja.
Den hab ich mal gemacht. Ist das jetzt alles hier?
Zeigt mal damit, was zum lästern haben.
Das sieht irgendwie... Also da sind auf jeden Fall die Social-Icons drin.
Ja, ok, ich werd das nochmal vergleichen, das krieg ich jetzt eh nicht. Ja, es gibt einen Blinkenlites-Font. Den hab ich mal gemacht. Das ist eigentlich ein sehr schöner Font. Der ist nämlich die Buchstaben, so wie sie auf Blinkenlites, auf dem Haus aussahen. Also die Buchstaben, die wir uns selbst für die Auflösungen, die ja... Also das gesamte Haus war ja 18x8 und man konnte maximal drei Buchstaben darstellen.
Das erste Haus.
Ja, also das original Blinkenlites im Sinne von... Nein, das ist Paris da, was da an der Wand hängt. Das ist sozusagen sieben Punkte hoch der Font und fünf breit.
Gute alte Nadel-Drucker-Matrix.
Genau, also eigentlich so ein 5x7... So sieht es auch aus, genau. Es gibt aber eine Besonderheit bei diesem Font. Und zwar... Die Abstände zwischen den Pixeln entsprechen halt tatsächlich dieser Aspekt-Ratio, so wie sie halt auch wirklich auf dem Haus waren. Aber es gibt noch eine Besonderheit, die einem erst dann klar wird, wenn man das mal ein bisschen zoomt. Und ich weiß gar nicht, ob das jetzt hier schon ausreicht.
Die Pixel sind nicht quadratisch, oder?
Hier könntet ihr es jetzt theoretisch schon sehen.
Oder meinst du diesen weißen Strich in dem Pixel? Die sehen aus wie Fenster.
Sie sehen halt genauso aus, wie auf dem Haus. Und auf dem Blinken-Lights-Haus waren halt in jedem Fenster noch so einen Balken, der eine obere und eine untere Scheibe getrennt hat. Und die ist halt hier auch mit drin. Das sind jetzt 250 Punkte. Wo kann ich denn hier mal die Größe angeben? Hier, das mach ich mal 400 Punkte. Da sieht man das schon ein bisschen deutlicher. Und wenn ihr nochmal ganz genau hinschaut, dann fällt euch da in dem Zusammenhang noch ein Unterschied auf.
Manchmal ist der Balken oben und manchmal so unten.
In der letzten Zeile war der Balken nämlich oben. Das ist halt so auf dem Haus. Und das ist aber hier in dem Font halt auch drin. Aber das siehst du halt erst ab einer bestimmten Größe. Und das Abenteuerliche ist, ich hab den Font tatsächlich automatisch generiert aus den original Blinkenlight-Movies. Das heißt, ich hab quasi einen Blinkenlight-Movie, die Dinger gemalt mit unserem Blinkenlight-Editor. Hab das quasi abgespeichert in diesem BML-Format. Also erst hatten wir ja BLM und dann sind wir ja von BLM auf BML. Also BML ist sozusagen Blinkenlight Markup Language. Das ist sozusagen alles in XML. Und dann hab ich aus dem XML, hab ich SVG und SVG-Font erzeugt. Also ich hab das Ding einfach programmatisch zu einem SVG-Font konvertiert. Das war glaube ich mein erstes und letztes Ruby-Podcast, das ich geschrieben habe, fällt mir da mal noch ein. Und ja, dann kam das bei raus und das konnte ich dann wiederum in CTF konvertieren und den gibt's. Den könnt ich gerne gleich nochmal online stellen, wenn wir uns schon darüber gesprochen haben. Hab ich mich noch nie so drum gekümmert und den gibt's auch in Bold. Und ich glaube...
Also hier wurde im Chat der Fond schon gefunden, ne?
Ja, der ist schon auch irgendwie im Netz.
Bei Frau Gerlach.
Genau. Frau Gerlach war nämlich eine Fond-Designerin, die hat das mit mir, also die hat mich sozusagen überhaupt erstmal auf diesen Film gebracht. Und wir haben dann gemeinsam ein wenig beratschlagt und wie man das alles so machen könnte und ich glaube, dass wir zusammen auch irgendwie die Buchstaben noch ausgesucht haben. Aber ich hab dann am Ende diese ganzen Files dann doch alleine irgendwie konvertiert bekommen.
Aber jetzt wird sich Frau Gerlach auf jeden Fall freuen, nachdem es im Chat und damit wahrscheinlich auch in den Shownotes landet.
Die macht nämlich auch noch sonst sehr schöne Fonds.
Ja, ich sehe hier gerade, der hat auch Fondshop-Fonds schon gemacht.
Ja, die hat vor allem, was sie mal gemacht hat, ist, die hat mal den Fond gemacht, der hier auf den Berliner Straßenschildern zu sehen ist. Den hat sie quasi reingeniert. Also die Schrift, mit der so damals die alten... Genau, das gibt es auch in Ost und West.
Die wird sich jetzt auch freuen, dass sie jetzt ein paar extra Hits gerade auf ihrer Webseite kriegt.
Brena Gerlach, nette Person und sehr begabte Typografin und die hat da noch mehr zu bieten. Ich wusste gar nicht, dass sie den Blinkenlatz-Fond auch zum Download hat. Ja, das ist sehr gut. Den habe ich hier gar nicht installiert. Den habe ich hier auch noch als Negative. Den gibt es auch noch als Negative-Bolt. Dann ist er quasi weiß auf schwarz.
Was ist denn hier? Hier fehlt ein Bild.
Also das ist der Fond.
Offenbar ist er auch durchscheind, wenn man sich ihr Ding oben anguckt. Also sozusagen nicht weiß auf schwarz, sondern schwarz mit Löchern. Transparent. Also transparent durch schwarz.
Ja, ja.
Das ist ja auch sexy.
Das ist halt wie so ein Fond. Du malst ja nicht weiß auf schwarz, sondern du hast ja eigentlich nur eine Füllfarbe sozusagen. Und wenn es da weiß ist, ist da halt einfach nix. Ja, ja, was ich alles schon gemacht hab. Fonds, da ändert man sich gar nicht dran. Das war ein schönes Ding. Wobei, das wäre schon nochmal sinnvoll, dass da nochmal ein Experte draufschaut, weil ich mir so mit den Zeilenabständen und so weiter nie so richtig sicher war, ob das eigentlich alles so richtig ist.
Das ist auch immer beim Fond-Schrauben, das ist so krass schwierig, weil da jeder Pixel irgendwie das komplett...
Ja, aber gerade bei diesem Fond willst du ja nicht typografisch korrekt sein, oder korrekt sein mit Respekt zu den Blinken-Lights, Bruder.
Ja, aber auch das ist schon tatsächlich...
Ja, da gab es aber keinen Zeilenabstand, weil ich hatte nur eine Zeile. Also da gab es keine Vorlage, nach der ich hätte gehen können und so. Noch irgendwas zum Thema Fonds? Von irgendjemand?
Na, ich kann zum nächsten Mal gerne mal meine Lieblingsfonds mitbringen und ausweizen.
Also ich finde, das ist ein schönes, generelles Thema, was man hier immer häufiger bringen könnte.
Ja, durchaus.
Zumindest ist es ein ästhetisch interessantes und immer wieder erfreuliches Thema.
In der Tat. In der Tat. So, jetzt guck ich gerade mal hier.
Ja, das Schöne ist eigentlich vor allen Dingen, dass jetzt genug Services oder genug Shops, das halt mit diesen Web-Fonds und natürlich auch allen voran die Browser, das so weit gebracht haben, dass jetzt halt auch wirklich jeder Hans und sein Bruder auf seiner Webseite halten kann. Ich hab ja hier für meinen Webseiten-Universum auch immer eine Lieblingsschrift und ich schreib gerade einer im Chat Avenir, ich glaube es ist sogar die Avenir. Die hab ich jetzt auch schon an verschiedenen Stellen in meine Webseite reingeschraubt und das ist halt cool. Das ist jetzt nicht mehr halt jede Webseite so, du gehst halt manchmal auf Webseite und denkst dir, das ist ja eine schöne Schrift und kannst auch gleich nachgucken, was ist denn das und so.
Das ist ein ganz anderes Gefühl auf Webseiten, die mal nicht nur in Helvetica oder Comic-Song gemacht sind.
Oder Verdana oder Georgia.
Bleiben wir dann nochmal kurz bei Web-Fonds. Kennst du dich da ein bisschen aus? Es gibt auch diese Web-Fond- Dienste von Google und ich weiß nicht, ob es auch noch andere gibt.
Von Adobe, also es gibt Typekit. War das der von Adobe im Moment? Typekit war, also Fondshop hat einen. Eigentlich alle großen Fond-Buden haben sich da jetzt schon irgendwo reingeklingt.
Aber was heißt das, dass die den Fond auch hosten?
Also...
Oder dass ich mir da welche kaufen kann?
Nee, nee, nee, nee, also es gibt verschiedene Konzepte. Also es gibt diese Web-Services, sowas wie Typekit und da bindest du quasi die Fonds von denen ein, also die hosten die Fonds für dich. Und du bezahlst sozusagen pro Zugriff, du sagst halt, ja okay, also meine Webseite hat jetzt vielleicht 100.000 Viewers so im Monat und dann bezahlst du halt je nachdem, wie auch immer. Ja, ich weiß nicht, das ist hier bei Pricing bei Typekit. Typekit ist von Adobe in dem Fall. Personal, 50.000 Page-Views pro Monat kostet 24,99 pro Jahr. Das sind nur zwei Dollar pro Monat.
Für 50.000 Page-Impressions.
Genau, der Vorteil ist von diesen Web-Services. Für 99.99 im Jahr hast du 500.000 Page-Views pro Monat.
Dann kannst du jeden beliebigen Font benutzen von denen.
Genau, das ist halt der Clou dabei. Du hast halt dein gesamtes Portfolio, ihre gesamte Library für 49 Dollar im Jahr. Das heißt, du kannst deine Webseite komplett vollballern. Zum Beispiel bei dem Personal-Ding, also das Trial-Ding, da hast du eine Webseite mit zwei Fonts per Website. Bei Personal kannst du fünf Fonts per Website. Und wenn du dieses Portfolio-Ding nimmst für 50 Dollar im Jahr, da hast du die gesamte Library von Adobe. Du kannst für beliebig viele Webseiten das benutzen, die du halt selber betreibst. Und du kannst pro Seite beliebig viele unterschiedliche Fonts einbauen. Und das ist schon cool, wenn du wirklich Werte darauf legst, da jetzt so richtig abzugehen und volle Flexibilität haben willst, dann ist sowas wie Typekit genau das Richtige. Es gibt noch zwei, drei andere, aber ich hab gerade den Namen vergessen. Und dann kannst du dir halt bei den ganzen Font-Läden, halt Linotype, Fontshop und bei Adobe wahrscheinlich auch, oder was ja ganz groß ist, myfonts.com, diese Meta-Fontseite, da kannst du dir jetzt neben diesen TrueType, Postscript, OpenType-Fonts, kannst du dir eben auch Web-Fonts kaufen. Dann kaufst du dir genau einen Font, auch vielleicht manchmal nur einen Schnitt, wenn du genau weißt, okay, ich will jetzt alle meine Headlines in der Schrift haben. Und dann kriegst du halt dieses Woff oder dieses andere EOT-File. Genau. Und das hostest du dann aber selber auf deiner Webseite. Und das bindest du auch selber in deinen, also das musst du halt selber auf deiner Webseite.
Was ist denn Woff und was ist EOT?
Ja, da müsste ich jetzt auch nochmal nachschauen. Also das hat wieder so, weißt schon, die einen Browser haben das, also Microsoft hat das gemacht und die anderen haben das gemacht. Erst mal und dann haben sich irgendwann geeinigt, ja eigentlich können wir jetzt auch beides. Und jetzt eigentlich können glaube ich alle Browser beides. Aber im CSS gibt es dann so eine schöne funky rule, wo du dann halt so mit so schöner Cascading-Style-Sheet-Manier, also da kommt dieses Cascading auch wirklich in Fahrt, weil du dann halt so in der ersten Rule sagst, ja okay, nimm mal die Schrift. Und dann machst du so eine Special-Anweisung, die nur für Internet-Exploder benutzt, interpretiert wird. Und wenn die interpretiert wird, dann überleht er das mit der Wof-Schrift oder so.
Okay, also EOT ist von Microsoft, Compact Form of OpenType-Fonds, designed by Microsoft und heißt Embedded OpenType. Und Wof ist das Web OpenFond Format W3C von der Web Fonds Working Group. Und ja, auch hier OpenType.
Diese Standardisierung wird auch immer anstrengender.
Du kriegst jetzt halt von den ganzen Fondshops, hast du ja hier auch gleich bei diesem Awesome-Fond, kriegst du grundsätzlich eigentlich jetzt immer beide. Und üblich, wenn man das in CSS einbettet, ist auch, dass du beide referenzierst, um vielleicht noch die Kompatibilität zu alten Browsern zu gewährleisten. Weil so lange ist das noch nicht drin, dass die halt auch selber gehostete Fond-Dings dazu supporten. Und wenn du halt, das ist halt wiederum auch ein Vorteil, wenn du halt so Typekit oder einen anderen Fond-Hoster nimmst, dann kümmern die sich auch gleich darum, dann jeweils das Richtige da einzubetten. Also es ist alles so, es ist schon eine sehr schöne Experience, wenn man halt irgendwie das Geld hat und jetzt irgendwie sowieso so einen Design-Fokus hat, dann ist das sicher nichts Schlechtes. Ich hab jetzt für meine Seiten bisher, weil ich wusste, ich hab schon immer diese Schrift für mein Zeug benutzt, ich will die jetzt auch im Web benutzen, da hab ich mir die halt gekauft.
Ich hab da auch noch einen Tipp, und zwar gibt's ja von Gareth von Aachen, gibt's ein E-Book, was er erstellt hat jetzt in den letzten Jahren zu dem Thema, das Webtypo-Buch, was ich halt, also webtypobuch.de, was ich in genau dieser Problematik da mal komplett annimmt, kann man auch irgendwie online lesen und kann man sich halt irgendwie so als ePub und so weiter kaufen. Da ist halt so ein bisschen Geschichte, etc., wie man das alles irgendwie zu tun hat und auch eben so Grundlagen über Fonds, etc. und wie man was auswählen sollte für sich und so weiter. Alles erklärt und hätte ich das schon gelesen, hätte ich dich eben gar nicht fragen müssen, so altklug daher reden können.
Ja, ich hab mir das halt auch, ich dachte mir so, boah geil, stimmt, Webfonds, ich kaufe mir jetzt diesen Fond und dann erst mal so eine halbe Stunde gegoogelt, weil natürlich eben durch diese Browser-Historie und erst mal die einen das und die anderen das und dann gab es da wieder tausend Blogposts, die alle was anderes erzählt haben, bis man da dann so das Destillat gebildet hat, um so seine CSS-Lösung zu finden. Das hat dann auf jeden Fall ein bisschen Arbeit gekostet. Das ist so eine kleine E-Book-Quelle vielleicht, genau das Richtige. Aber ich denke unsere Hörer sind auch schlau genug, mit Google oder DuckDuckGo oder Bing so umzugeben, dass sie da auch die passende Lösung finden.
Genau, unsere Hörer sind nämlich die tollsten überhaupt. Und deswegen sollten wir jetzt vielleicht auch mal mehr über Macs reden, weil... Über Macs. Du weißt schon, diese Gebilde.
Wir können ja mal über Mac-Adressen reden.
Also jetzt, wo der Kurs so gefallen ist, weiß ich nicht, da haben sie das noch verdient.
Wie der Kurs ist gefallen?
Na, ist doch jetzt bei 500 Dollar noch irgendwas. Nochlich. Das ist ja schrecklich. Seit Maps geht.
Da ist vielleicht mal die Möglichkeit, da einzusteigen. Geht bestimmt noch hoch.
Also 200 Dollar runter. Also die waren bei 700 oder so was, ne?
Ich rieche das nicht.
Ich hab eine ab Apple Aktien. Eine.
Ernsthaft?
Ja, eine. Da hab ich mir vor als 1900 Queatshaw hab ich mir mal eine gekauft. So ein bisschen so, weißt du, wie diese Szene da aus Forrest Gump. Wo er dann so, I invest in fruit business. Und ich müsste eigentlich mal gucken.
Na, wenn du eine Aktie hast, dann kann man relativ schnell feststellen, was die Wert ist.
Da war noch so ein Split dabei und so. Ja, das ihr zwei hast.
Das könnte durchaus auch sein. 1919, na ja, der Peak war, lass uns mal letztes Jahr mal anschauen. Oh doch, der Peak war bei 700.
Sie ist Peak Apple. Seit Maps geht, weil die Analysten, habe ich jetzt irgendwie kurz gelesen, der Meinung sind, na ja, also die Zukunft ist hier schon so mit Cloud und Web und sowieso und Apple hat da irgendwie in letzter Zeit jetzt nicht so die die dicken Punkte gelandet. So in Sachen Internet haben wir hier auch mehrfach schon dokumentiert in dieser Sendung und da ist jetzt wohl erstmal so ein bisschen das Porzellan bei den Investoren zerschlagen.
Ich denke, also ping ich war ja auch nichts bei Apple, ne?
Das hat sich da schon lange ausgepingt.
Die Analysten, naja, wenn man sich die durchlässt, was die sonst noch alles so schreiben, dann weiß man auch warum man da eigentlich nicht zuhören sollte.
Aber die haben ja immer gute Erklärungen, warum sie falsch lagen. Echt? Ja, meistens.
Ja, ich mein...
Na und? Seit wann interessiert Investoren Erklärungen oder rationale... Übrigens, gib mal auf Google einfach nur AAPL ein. Dann malen sie dir natürlich das Ding hin und damit Google auf gar keinen Fall falsche Daten auf deinem Bildschirm zu stehen hat, daten sie den jetzt ab. Während die Seite da steht, gucke ich drauf und ganz Zeit ändert sich der Apple-Course vor meinen Augen. Damit auch ja keiner irgendwie noch eine offene Google-Seite zu stehen hat, wo jetzt einfach noch ein alter Preis steht von vor drei Sekunden.
Ich glaub's ja.
Die letzte Ziffer wird immer rot oder grün, je nachdem, ob er hoch oder runtergegangen ist.
Ja, also ich mein, ich fand jetzt die...
Du wusstest ja gar nicht drauf, in der normalen Suchseite, in den normalen Sucher-Ergebnissen oben, also die Sucher-Ergebnisse ändern sich jetzt noch mal, während du drauf starst.
Aber ich fand jetzt die Erklärung zumindest so ein bisschen nachvollziehbar. Also online haben sie halt echt einfach noch nicht so viel gebracht. Also eigentlich haben sie irgendwas, haben sie irgendwas so im Internet so richtig doll cool gewuppt.
Sie haben sich ein Slash achten Netzwerk gesichert.
Das System ist echt geldwert.
Ja, aber so ich meine so richtig so mit...
Nee, ne? Na doch, wenn du mal am Ende des Tages schaust, also klar diese ganzen Cloud-Dinger, aber Apple betreibt einen Apple Store, wo sie die ganzen Ups und die Filme drausserven und so was. Und das ist echt immer wieder ein erstaunlicher Test, wenn Leute zu mir kommen, sagen jetzt habe ich meinen tollen VDSL-Anschluss mit 50 Megabit. Mein Download wird auch nicht besser. Ich sag, kauft ihr mal ein Apple-Device und ladt mal einen Film runter oder macht mal ein Software-Update. Apple schafft das immer noch, zumindestens die VDSL mit den 50 Megabit bis zum Deckel voll zu machen. Okay, machen sie jetzt nicht selber, aber sie haben jetzt Dienstleister wie AKMai oder so was da angeheuert, die ihnen das bringen. Und sie schaffen das, Milliarden von Ups auszuliefern und Milliarden von Musikstücken und Filmen und so. Okay, das ist jetzt auch schon abgehangene Technik. Das machen sie nicht erst seit gestern. Aber da muss man ihnen auch mal zu Gute halten. Das kriegen sie schon relativ gut gebacken.
Ja, aber sie haben halt jetzt schon ein paar mal den Mund richtig voll genommen. Mit PING so erst so ganz vorsichtig, dann so mit irgendwie iCloud und diesem ganzen iWork in the Cloud und mit Maps und...
Es ist nämlich nicht... Klar, ich meine, das, was du sagst, das ist so eine einfache technische Sache, die vielleicht nicht einfach zu lösen ist konkret. Aber da ist irgendwie schon mal sehr klar, was der Bedarf ist und was was erfüllt werden muss. Wo aber Apple völlig versagt oder wo sie zumindest keine besondere Brillanz entwickelt haben über die Zeit ist, mal ein Modell zu entwickeln, wie die Leute miteinander und mit ihren Diensten interagieren wollen. Wo sind die Daten zu welchem Zeitpunkt? Was für Daten tausche ich aus? Welchen Grad an Zugang und Flexibilität will ich da wirklich haben? Ja und das ist jetzt mit iCloud wieder so... Ich merke an mir...
Ja, aber die anderen tappen doch auch alle im Dunkeln. Also ich meine...
Google tappt da nur sehr begrenzt im Dunkeln. Google hat schon wirklich sehr viele Dienste sehr gut hinbekommen. Maps zum Beispiel.
Aber, aber, aber... Google hat doch nicht den Anspruch immer... Google hat nicht den Anspruch auf irgendeiner dusseligen Keynote zu sagen so von jetzt auf morgen, ab jetzt können das viele Leute benutzen. Moment, Moment, Moment, Moment. Wave hat technisch ganz gut funktioniert, aber es wollte halt keiner haben oder so, wurde falsch beworben oder falsch verkauft.
Google ist jetzt vielleicht auch der falsche Vergleich. Weil, also so, letzten Mal ging es jetzt hier um Dropbox oder, weißt du, es gibt halt schon diverse so Start-ups, Dinge da im Netz, die irgendwie so den Nerv der Internet-Bevölkerung schon direkt treffen, ob sie es jetzt durch Zufall gemacht haben oder auch nicht. Und Apple ist halt immer so, ja, hier! Und diesmal wirklich! Und dann so Tumbleweeds, Crickets und ja.
Aber sprichst du jetzt, du, damit sprichst ja kein technisches Thema an, damit sprichst du ja sozusagen ein Produktdesign dahingehend, was wollen Nutzer wirklich nutzen?
Aber sie machen ja, sie machen ja Dinge, mit denen sie ihre Produkte ja auch verkaufen. Und Maps ist ja nun zum Beispiel eben das letzte prominente Thema, was ja auch so ein zentraler Stein in sowieso ihrer ganzen Strategie war, sich von Google da so ein bisschen los eisen wollten und dann so einen suboptimalen Start hinzulegen und so viel Bad Publicity sich da einzuhandeln, das ist schon...
Das war nicht mal peak Apple, das war einfach nur peak dämlich.
Das war schon, das war halt so viel, dass ihr das jetzt auch nicht wegignorieren konntet.
Das beste Beispiel ist zum Beispiel Dropbox. Seit ich Max habe, wünsche ich mir so etwas wie Dropbox. Also seitdem Internet irgendwie so halbwegs eine Realität ist, war mein einziger Wunsch immer, bitte, bitte erlaubt mir irgendeine Möglichkeit, dass wenn diese, wenn zwei Geräte auch nur in einem Raum nebeneinander stehen, dass sie irgendwie die Daten untereinander abgleichen.
Das kann doch... Mit iDisc ging das halbwegs mal.
Nein.
Ja, weil das fängt schon wieder an.
Das fängt schon wieder an mit halbwegs mal, vielleicht gar nicht mal so scheiße.
War da zwar so ähnlich irgendwie, das hat dann aber auch mehrere Iterationen gebraucht, bis sie dann mal so ein lokales Caching dann dafür eingebaut haben. Vorher war das einfach nur so eine Disk im Netz.
Und du hast dich immer nur gegen die Cloud gesynkt. Wenn du die beiden Dinger nebeneinander gestellt hast, hast du deinen ganzen Scheiß einmal durch deinen DSL-Anschluss hoch und wieder runter genuckelt.
Ja, aber auch iDisc hat nie wirklich irgendwie gegriffen und was ich bis heute noch vermisse, ist halt einfach auch so eine reine lokale Lösung zum Beispiel. Aber egal. Dropbox hat es dann irgendwie denailed. Also Dropbox, finde ich, hat mit wenig Einschränkungen da was wirklich tolles hingelegt und da ist Apple auch immer noch nicht. Also, Summarum, man kann ihnen jetzt nicht, es ist nicht so, dass jetzt sie schon mal geschafft hätten so etwas wie ein iPod oder ein iPhone mit Internetdiensten zu realisieren. Es gab noch nie einen Dienst, wo alle sagen, ja lass da mal Apple ran, ja? Dann haben wir da einen Dienst, der so richtig geil ist. Weil die haben ja auch schon X gemacht. Es gibt kein X, nix. Aber sie haben 30 Jahre geile Hardware-Lösung für jeden Scheiß. Kameras gebaut, Drucker gebaut, immer war es irgendwie...
Software auch nicht so ganz schlecht....
aber irgendwie beim Netz.
Ja, es ist immer wieder dieselbe Story. Es gibt immer wieder einen, der bei was versagt wird, der andere nicht schafft. Also Apple hat das mit der Hardware rausgerissen, was der Microsoft ihnen mit der Software vorgemacht hat. Sozusagen bei der Marktdurchdringung. Und jetzt gibt es halt Leute, die Apple das vormachen, wie man halt ordentliche Webdienste macht.
Ja, ich bin gespannt, wann sich das ändert.
Aber hier, also...
Wir werden aber trotzdem irre viel Geld verdienen. Es ist einfach... Diese Kurve, da sagt gar nichts aus. Ich habe eben auch auf fünf Jahre geklickt. Das ist nichts anderes als eine Trendbereinigung. Die Linie geht da immer noch sehr gerade hoch seit fünf Jahren.
Die Apple-Aktie ist aus 1997. Da war der Kurs bei, keine Ahnung.
14 Dollar. Aber irgendwie bei Apple Maps funktioniert ja. Ich benutze die Google Maps tatsächlich sehr selten. Aber ich bin schon ein bisschen angepisst, dass sie immer noch so bestimmte Straßenverbindungen, bestimmte Sachen immer noch nicht drin haben.
Ganze U-Bahn-Linien fehlen.
Wie lange ist das jetzt draußen?
Viertel Jahr.
Ich glaube, sie werden im Sommer. Das ist so meine Vermutung. Also wenn sie das nicht machen, bin ich enttäuscht. Aber davon gehe ich aus, dass sie jetzt irgendwie so im Sommer, wenn sie irgendwann ein fettes Release machen. Sie verbessern jetzt auch schon die ganze Zeit. So ist es nicht. Es gibt jetzt auch Berlin zum Beispiel.
Übrigens, du kannst ja da Fehler melden. Wie schon häufiger erwähnt habe, bin ich ja gerne mal in Schweden und Stockholm. Ich geh jetzt neulich mal Stockholm, fliegt die Nadel nur mit einem Kuhkaf 50 Kilometer nördlich von Stockholm. Dann das Ding angetickt und dann kannst du ja so sagen, nee, das ist an der falschen Stelle. Ziehst du diese Nadel da nach Gamla-Star, auf diese alte Insel, in der Mitte von Stockholm, schmeißt sie da rein. Ja, ist jetzt auch schon wieder vier Wochen her, immer noch da oben in Togmenistan. Oder kann ich mal gucken jetzt.
Das ist ja jetzt nicht so, dass sie dann sofort eine Datenbankänderung machen soll.
Ich mein, Stockholm hat immerhin einen Apple Store. Da arbeiten Apple-Mitarbeiter, dass nicht schon mal einer von denen da angerufen hat bei ihren Leuten, die sagten, ey, könnte man bitte die Nadel mal dahin machen.
Also ich würde behaupten, dass die einzige Chance, die sie haben, da dieses Maps-Thema noch zu reißen ist, genau das zu machen, dass sie da so mit größtmöglichem Editieren waren. Ich meine, in der Open-Speed-Map, da ist ja nun schon alles da, diese ganzen, also, das ist jetzt, also sie müssen sich da nicht mal wirklich groß anstrengen. Sie können das sogar weitestgehend automatisch wahrscheinlich schon verbessern.
Aber dazu sind sie wieder zu stolz. Anstatt einfach zu sagen, wir haben es jetzt verkackt, ja, lieber Open Source-Gemeinde. Hier habt ihr mal 50 Millionen, die könnt ihr gut gebrauchen für eure Server oder wir spendieren nicht die Server, auf denen euer Schmulde läuft, dafür dürfen wir eure Karten jetzt auf den iPhones benutzen. Da wäre doch ein Win-Win. Nein, dafür sind sie jetzt echt zu stolz. Jetzt müssen sie unbedingt selber stemmen.
Ja, vor allem, was wollen sie mit den Milliarden, den sie da auf der Bank haben? Zu dem Thema übrigens Anfang der Woche oder ich glaube schon Ende letzte Woche kam das Gerücht auf, dass Apple Waze kaufen will. W-A-Z-E geschrieben. Und ich hatte also ohne dieses Gerücht zu lesen, habe ich mir diese Waze-Applikation mal runtergeladen und angeguckt. Das ist auch sehr strange, weil das ist so Facebook für Maps oder so. Du legst dir so einen Account an und dann bekommst du so eine komische, sieht aus wie eine Sprechblase mit Augen. Und diese Sprechblase mit Augen, die folgt dir dann durch die Stadt und du kannst dann sehen, wo sind andere sogenannte Wazers. Und du kannst dann halt irgendwie kommen.
Force-Fair Reloaded oder was?
Was soll das? Ja, aber halt mit Maps. Also du kannst auch wirklich die Karte dann bearbeiten. Es gibt einen Map-Editor, wo du halt sagen kannst, ich ziehe jetzt hier noch eine Straße ein und solche Sachen. Und du kannst halt Staus melden und du kannst Baustellen melden und diesen ganzen Scheiß. Und kannst dann aber auch irgendwie so Dankeschön-Punkte an andere Wazer vergeben und so.
Also ich war ja in Kolumbien, in Bogota und da haben das wirklich echt viele Leute benutzt. Also ich hab das überhaupt auch das erste Mal zur Podcast genommen.
Aber die Software ist so schlecht! Meine Güte! Du machst dir das Ding an, zooms ein bisschen rum und dann fehlt die halbe Karte, weil er einfach irgendwelche Tiles nicht lädt. Das ist der Hammer! Also und dann guckst du auf die Website und dann gibt es die Firma seit 2006 und du denkst dir, was haben die die letzten sechs Jahre gemacht, wenn sie nicht mal eine Anzeige hinkriegen?
In Bogota hat das, soweit ich das getestet habe, ganz gut funktioniert und sie meinten also, es wäre halt super aktuell, was so Verkehrsprobleme betrifft und davon gab es da ja eine Menge. Und vor allem, da gibt es halt nicht so wie hier so eine super geordnete Meldung mit irgendwie zwischen Ausfahrt sowieso und Ausfahrt sowieso für zwei Stunden jetzt noch Stau, sondern da herrscht halt so ein bisschen mehr Anarchie schon auf der Straße. Du kannst ja dann auch irgendwie deinen Mut da irgendwie, kannst sagen, so ich bin jetzt hier genervt so und das kannst du dir dann auch mal anzeigen lassen und dann mit den Leuten auch gleich anfangen zu kommunizieren. Also das ist sozusagen auch gleich so eine Kommunikationsplattform. Du kannst die Leute direkt anschatten und so, die sich da halt melden. Also putzig. Für mich wäre das jetzt auch nichts, aber klingt ganz witzig. Wenn du da im Stau stehst, dann hast du zumindest was zu tun.
Das wäre ohnehin, ich meine bei der Durchdringung von diesem ganzen Schmuddel warte ich ja echt noch auf den Dienst, den mal einer bringt, dass du einfach mit deinem iPhone oder meinetwegen mit der Kamera einfach unten ein License-Plate von einem Auto abknippst oder das eintippst. Ja, B-A-B-1234 und das sozusagen als iChat-Handle oder irgendwas benutzt, um denen irgendwelche Unpflichtigkeiten zuzuraunen oder Liebes-Schwüre oder was weiß ich.
Also ich hatte das Gefühl, wenn Apple jetzt Waze kaufen würde, hätten sie ihr Kartenproblem nicht gelöst, weil das war irgendwie auch nicht viel besser als das, was Apple momentan hat. Also zumindest in Berlin.
Ach, das war noch Zeit, ein Karl, die Klammer.
Was ist das, diese komische Microsoft-Klammer?
Ja, diese Microsoft Office Klammer.
Die ist tatsächlich Karl, die Klammer?
Karl Klammer hieß das Teil.
In Deutsch und auf Englisch? Ach, Clippy oder so, ne? Bestimmt.
Das ist doch Karl Klammer, viel besser.
Viel deutscherer auf jeden Fall.
Hier wird übrigens gerade eine Dropbox- Samsung-Partnership irgendwie gemeldet. Dropbox to be included on all Samsung flagship phones and camera.
Donner Schock.
Der Siegeszug der Datei. Ich bin mir echt nicht so sicher, ob Apple es irgendwie noch mal schafft, die Datei loszuwerden. Sie bekämpfen das ja irgendwie, versuchen ja schon seit Jahrzehnten, versuchen sie ja dem Herr zu werden und irgendwie die Idee des Documents irgendwie zu implementieren. Schon mit Open Doc fing das irgendwie an. Das war ja schon der erste Fail.
Ja, aber das war echt krampf.
Ja, ja, das war krampf. Das ist ja auch jetzt krampf. Ich meine, dieses iCloud ist auch krampf. Also ich werde das nicht benutzen. Das kann ich dir jetzt schon sagen. Dieses iCloud, das kriegen die nicht zwischen meine Fingernägel.
Da hab ich noch einen schönen Bug bei der iCloud. Und zwar, iCloud ist ja für den Programmierer nicht ein Dienst, sondern eigentlich drei. Also man hat diesen komischen Ubiquitous Key Value Store, wie er so schön heißt, was eigentlich nur Sync Preferences sind.
Das ist auch halbwegs praktisch.
Das ist halbwegs praktisch. Dann kannst du Files austauschen. Dazu hast du einen sogenannten Ubiquitous Container, wo die Files reinkommen. Und dann hast du halt noch dieses Core Data über iCloud, was im Prinzip immer so Change Logs sind. Also du legst eine leere Core Data Datenbank an und sobald du anfängst, die zu bearbeiten, macht er Change Logs. Und er schmeißt dann massiv Change Logs raus und synkt diese ganzen Change Logs über Core Data, über iCloud. Und das ist dann aber auch so eine ewige Liste. Wir hatten ja schon mal drüber geredet. Das Witzige ist, du kannst halt über bestimmte Verfahren herausfinden, hat der User jetzt iCloud an oder nicht. Und lustigerweise bezieht sich das aber nur auf den...
Wie hat er an oder nicht?
Also du kannst als Programm sagen, benutzt der User iCloud. Hat er einen iCloud-Account konfiguriert?
Und aktiviert.
Und hat er es aktiviert für, ich glaube, Daten und Dokumente oder so heißt die Checkbox. Und das bezieht sich aber nur auf den Ubiquitous-Container. Also du kannst nur, wenn du in deinem Programm auch einen Ubiquitous-Container benutzt, diesen Call benutzen, um festzustellen, ob der das angeschaltet hat oder nicht. Wenn du nur diesen Key-Value-Store benutzt und keinen Container hast, den du irgendwie auch in deinen, den musst du extra anlegen, und dann kannst du es nicht rausfinden. Problem ist jetzt, uns ist eine App abgelehnt worden, weil wir halt einen Container angelegt haben, aber ihn nicht benutzen, weil wir den Container ja nur brauchen, um herauszufinden, ob iCloud an oder aus ist.
Oh weia.
Und dann haben die gesagt, ne, also wenn ihr da keine Daten reinschreibt, dann könnt ihr keinen Container anlegen.
Woher wissen die denn, dass ihr da keine Daten reinschreibt?
Die spielen nicht.
Du, keine Ahnung, der Reviewer, der sieht das ja.
Kann sein, dass er ab irgendwann da mal Daten reinschreibt. Was kümmern die sich um so einen Scheiß?
Du, keine Ahnung, auf dem iPhone ist es kein Problem. Da ist es genauso, also unter iOS, da ist es genauso. Da funktioniert das auch nur, wenn du diesen Container anlegst. Aber da interessiert es keinen, zumindest den Reviewer, den wir hatten. Aber unter macOS musst du, also zumindest bei dem Reviewer, musst du halt auch Dateien in den Container schreiben, um ihn benutzen zu dürfen.
Hast du ihm nicht geschrieben, dass ihr nicht doof seid, dass ihr nicht einfach nur doof seid, sondern dass er den Grund hat, dass sie das gemacht haben?
Ja, ja. Und dann kam ja dieses, nein, also dazu können sie jetzt keinen Container anlegen, nur um festzustellen und so weiter. Das ist jetzt eine totale Irrsinn.
Was passiert denn, wenn wir eine Key-Value benutzen? Der User hat es nicht an. Prallst du denn gegen Fehler? Oder die werden halt einfach nur nicht gesyncht? Oder was ist denn der Effekt?
Ich glaube, die werden nur nicht gesyncht.
Dann brauchst du doch ja nicht wissen. Dann kannst du dir doch egal sein, oder?
Ja, so machen wir es jetzt auch.
Hier ist iCloud, ich hab's ja gleich gesagt.
Mich überzeugt das einfach. Mich nervt auch diese ganzen Programme, die man startet und dann kommt sie erst mal zu einem, oh leg doch mal deine Dateien hier in deine iCloud rein.
Solche Programme hab ich glücklicherweise gar nicht.
Wenn es mal entgibt, ja mal so diese Hacks, die immer rauskommen dazu, die das Betriebssystem wieder in Ordnung bringen. Also diese Default-Writes. Ich brauche dringend mal den, der die Text-Edit davon abhält, immer zu sagen, wenn man ihn jetzt startet, anstatt mir ein leeres Ding da hinzumalen, einfach erstmal wieder mit seinem Speichers-doch-in-der-iCloud-Dialog dazu kommen. Das geht mir echt auf die Eier.
Das Allerschlimmste daran ist, du kannst iCloud als Mac-App nur dann benutzen, wenn du auch tatsächlich über ein App-Store verkaufst.
Ah, es gibt einen Default.
Den Default hab ich aus. Ich will aber den ganzen komischen Dialog da gar nicht haben. Früher war das so, wenn du Texte startet hast und du hast keinen Dokument auf, hat der einfach ein Leerit aufgemacht, fertig. Jetzt kommt der mit seiner ach wählen sie doch mal eine Datei aus, aus iCloud oder My Mac und Recent und so.
Ich hab's ja ganz aus.
Das andere mach ich jetzt auch demnächst aus.
Eine Sache, die jetzt so Apple in Sachen irgendwie so Kommunikations- und Internetdienste dann bei mir jetzt doch ganz gut funktioniert, ist jetzt tatsächlich dieses Messages. Da hab ich mich ja lange auch mit rumgeschlagen. Aber das hab ich letztens mal wieder probiert, so am Rechner halt so Messages gestartet. Und so die Leute, wo ich weiß, die haben iPhone und so, halt irgendwie die einfach so am Keyboard voll geballert. Und das so, ja, das leuchtet hier auch dann immer noch mal auf, wenn die Nachricht ankommt. Also es kommt schon auf allen geregten Leitzeiten hin. Aber woher soll er auch wissen, ob ich jetzt nicht gerade auf dem Klo sitze mit dem iPhone oder ob ich mit meinem Rechner sitze?
Wenn du das zeitnah machst, passiert das übrigens nicht. Also der weiß ja schon, dann ist das auch nicht als ungelesen, auf dem Ding zu sehen. Genau. Das kriegen sie schon ganz gut hin. Aber auch da hat die zum Beispiel jetzt gerade kürzlich Schmerzen.
Ja, das ist es nicht immer.
Was echt die Pässe ist, wenn du das machst, was Apple einfach nicht vorgesehen hat, einfach in ihrer Mentalität nicht vorgesehen ist, nämlich, dass jemand mal sein SIM anfasst. Ich meine, in Amerika hatte das neu schon mal erwähnt. In Amerika gibt es diese Geschichte außer in den Krimis gar nicht. In den Krimis ist ja die SIM-Karte nur dafür da, damit man sie rausziehen und aus dem Taxifenster schmeißen kann auf der Flucht, damit man nicht mehr verfolgt wird von der Polizei. Dafür ist die SIM-Karte da. Ansonsten, dass jemand dieses Ding jemals anfasst, geschweige denn wechselt, ist bei denen mental einfach nicht vorgesehen. Wenn ich nach Schweden war, habe ich natürlich meine schwedische SIM drin. Und nein, ich kaufe mir nicht ein zweites iPhone dafür. Und das funktioniert alles inzwischen ganz gut. Nur das iMessage kriege ich jedes Mal die Krise. Und meldet meine alte Nummer ab. Und der Witz ist, mein Mac fängt an zu schreien. Auf meinem Mac kriege ich die Meldung, dein iMessage-Account hat jetzt eine neue Telefonnummer. Und hin und her. Und dann steckst du die SIM-Karte, die alte wieder zurück. Und dann geht das ganze Spiel wieder von vorne los. Also das ist auch noch ein Big-Bag-Offert. Aber ich glaube, das ignoriert Apple einfach weg. Weil das ist bei denen eh nicht vorgesehen, schon wegen der Provider-Bindung da eine andere SIM-Karte reinzumachen. Und dass wir Europäer so was vielleicht tun, interessiert die gar nicht.
Aber immerhin, sie verkaufen jetzt SIM-Lok frei für uns. Auch in Ameland.
Aber nicht das VeriSign. Ich hätte ja gerne dieses VeriSign iPhone 5. Weil das halt hier die ordentlichen LTE-Bänder hat. Und das hätte ich gerne ohne Provider-Lok. Und dieses Modell gibt es gerade eben nicht.
Ja das stimmt.
Irgendwann berichtet hier gerade, dass wenn er Stockholm eingibt, dass das dann an der richtigen Stelle ist.
Ich hab's grad eben auch nochmal gepiekt, bin auf dem See gelandet.
Ohne C.
Ja und dann hab ich Stockholm. Und wenn du nochmal oben in die Zeile reingehst, einfach nochmal oben in die Zeile jetzt, wo Stockholm Schweden drückt, nochmal Return drückst, einfach.
Nochmal zoomen, suchen.
Dann landet er bei mir in Stockholm.
Nein, bleibe nach wie vor da oben.
Und dann schalt mal auf Terrain um, schalt mal auf Hybrid um.
Da passiert erstmal gar nichts.
Ja, du musst ja auch wieder zu machen. Dauer, Denk, Warte, Gröbel.
Und Studier.
Grau. Rote Nadel im Grau.
Das meinte ich jetzt nicht, aber ich hatte da, also gefühlt verhält es sich erratisch. Also da ist auf jeden Fall noch.
Da ist Potenzial. Und jetzt, jetzt wo du die Google Maps ab, jetzt auch gesehen hast, dann denkst du dir so, Mann, Mann, Mann, Apple.
Die ist ganz gut geworden. Ich war erstaunt.
Gibt's aber nicht fürs iPad.
Leider. Nicht mehr fürs iPad Mini, jetzt du.
Das User Interface ist so ein bisschen so. Der 3D-View ist natürlich viel besser bei den Maps.
Aber es ist schon eine korrekte App. Auch so die ganze Integration mit den Places. Und dass das alles nicht so eine ganze Zeit so ein komisches Viewgeswitche ist. Das nervt mich nämlich bei den Apple Maps auch so ein bisschen. Dass du dann so auf so einen Place mal klickst und dann kommt so dieser Overlay mit irgendeiner scrollenden Karte oben, wenn sie kein Foto von dem Laden haben oder irgendwie so, weißt du was ich meine? Wenn du nach irgendeinem Pizza-Laden oder was auch immer suchst, dann klickst du auf dieses Klömpel und dann kommt dieser View.
Dann kommt so diesen Yelp-Kram und dann sind da irgendwelche Reviews drin und es sind nur Amerikaner, die da drüber schimpfen, dass in Amerika das Essen viel besser ist. Also, das ist echt so schrecklich.
Und ich fand das jetzt so ein bisschen bei der Google Maps App so ein bisschen besser gelöst, dass es einfach so, du siehst dann unten dieses Place mal, kannst es halt so hochdraggen und dann, also es ist auch nicht optimal, aber ich finds für so den ersten Schuss, wie du gerade schon meintest, das schon ziemlich gut gemacht. Und man kann, und man muss sich nicht verbiegen, also man muss wirklich, man kann einfach suchen, was man will, man muss nicht denken so, ok, was könnte jetzt Apple, also wenn ich jetzt den Bahnhof, wenn ich jetzt den Bahnhof Zoo suche, so wie könnte Apple das jetzt eingetragen haben? Und bei Google Maps, da kannst du wirklich suchen, was dir gerade so einfällt, so zoologischer Bahnhof, so egal, es kommt immer am gleichen Ort raus. Du kannst da irgendeinen Scheiß reinlabern und es geht. Und bei Apple Maps musst du ja wirklich dann eben so diese interpretative Hürde noch nehmen und überlegen so, was könnten sie jetzt da reingeschrieben haben? Ok, es ist nicht U-Bahnhof-Kleistpark, es ist auch nicht U-Kleistpark, es ist irgendwie...
Diese unfulminante Abwesenheit auch von Nahverkehr. Also dieses vollkommene Leugnen von Gleisen und Schienen.
Die U3 fehlt komplett.
Ach so, haben sie jetzt überhaupt schon U's drin?
Ja, so ein paar haben sie drin, die größeren Linien. Also, was halt eine größere Linie ist. Aber die U3, da wollte ich gestern zum Hohenzollernplatz, den kannte er nicht, den U-Hof.
Aber auch Google Maps ist da vollkommen schizophren, weil ich meine, sie haben zwar die U-Bahnen drin.
Sie haben den Overlay immerhin, wo U- und S-Bahnen drin sind.
Ja, aber keine Straßenbahnen. Und was halt im Westen Berlins die U-Bahnen sind, sind halt im Osten die Straßenbahnen.
Ja, da hast du nicht ganz unrecht, aber sie haben immerhin alle U-Bahnen. Und sie haben auch die Linien und die Farbenstimmen.
Ja, aber warum haben sie nur U-Bahnen und keine Straßenbahnen? Was ist der qualitative Unterschied dazwischen, dass die mal Untergrund fahren und mal auf so ein Viadukt und dann auch...
Du warst aus Hannover, ne? Wo das üblich ist, dass die Straßenbahnen irgendwie in der Stadt dann unterirdisch weiterfährt und so.
Das ist ein interessanter Punkt. Wie ist das überhaupt in Hannover? Das ist ja deutlich vernetzter. Aber auch Buslinien, ja?
Ja, das stimmt natürlich. Natürlich willst du Straßenbahnlinien haben und du willst auch Buslinien haben.
Vor allem will ich mal Buslinien haben und vor allem Bus-Haltestellen, wo mir wirklich so was mal echt weiterhelfen können. Außer OpenStreetMap gibt's da nüscht. Und sogar da ist OpenStreetMap noch, naja, so naja, weil du es einfach nicht weißt, wie das ist mit Bus-Haltestellen. Die sind mal da irgendwo noch vor der Ampel und auf der anderen Seite dann hinter der Ampel.
Ja, okay, aber ich meine...
Ja, aber das ist das, was ich von einem Kartendienst erwarte.
Vielleicht liegt das ja auch an unseren lokalen Verkehrsbetrieben, dass wir diese Daten auch gar nicht so rausrücken wollen.
Die rücken das bestimmt nicht raus. Darauf können die sich auch nicht zurückziehen. Ich meine, diese Informationen hat man rauszufinden. Wozu haben die denn diese Leute...
Übrigens, die stehen auch alle in OpenStreetMap drin. Mit exakt der Position, wo ist, auf welcher Seite der Kreuzung ist die Haltestelle.
Ja, aber halt nicht so verbunden wirklich dann mit Linien, also zumindest in den Ups.
Nein, ich sage aber am Datenbestand. Nochmal, wenn Apple mal über ihren Scheiß Stolz springen würde und sagen, hallo, wir machen jetzt hier mal die große Open Source Initiative, wir nehmen jetzt mal diesen Datenbestand, der durchaus nicht unsexy ist und schmeißen ihn dafür ein paar Millionen für einen neuen Server auf den Tisch oder sowas. Das wär ja mal ein Knaller, aber...
Können die es denn überhaupt nehmen, so rein recht gesehen?
Sie nehmen sogar Open Street Map.
Ja, aber sie haben sie nur einmal gesnapshotted.
Wir wissen nicht, was sie gemacht haben.
Also auf jeden Fall haben sie nicht den aktuellen Open-Street-Map-Stand von Berlin zum Beispiel.
Oder von sonst irgendwo.
Also man kann nur feststellen, was sie nicht haben von der Open Street Map.
Das ist nicht...
Sie wissen auch noch nicht, dass der eine Flughafen jetzt zu ist.
Also das Street Map taugt nicht universell. Es ist einfach eine Quelle.
Aber es ist immerhin besser, als das, was Apple jetzt hat.
Spuren, diese ganze Navigation usw. Das ist halt keine Stärke von Open Street Map. Also das ist einfach keine Domäne von Open Street Map. Du hast da halt keine Fahrspuren drin.
Ja, aber Navigation ist noch nicht deine Aufgabe. Das ist eine Datenbasis zur Hölle. Die kann man ja schon mal anzapfen. Die ist auf jeden Fall besser, als das, was sie jetzt haben.
Ja gut, aber das muss halt auch zusammenpassen. Wie auch immer. Ich denke, das Problem ist nicht einfach. Sie haben irgendeinen Weg genommen, wo vieles geklappt hat. Aber ein paar Sachen haben ganz katastrophal nicht geklappt. Und das haben sie irgendwie zu spät festgestellt. Zum Zeitpunkt, wo es irgendwie keinen Weg mehr zurück gab. Klassischer Fehler. Und ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass bevor sie jetzt groß sagen, jetzt ist aber alles wieder okay, dass sie sich das sehr lange überlegen. Also machen graduell jetzt hintenrum mit dem Modell, wie sie es jetzt draußen haben, machen sie es besser, so gut sie können. Konzentrieren sie sich aber jetzt wahrscheinlich gerade. Das ist jetzt meine Vermutung. Wenn ich Apple wäre. Und so hab ich den Laden bisher kennengelernt. Wenn sie so eine Scheiße haben, dann versuchen sie das irgendwie innen erstmal richtig auf neue Beine zu stellen. Wir erinnern uns, sie haben jetzt den Forcewell geschmissen, sie haben das ganze Team in eine andere Organisationsform reingepresst, sie haben auch den Chef von dem Maps-Desaster gefeuert. Also da ist sozusagen personell eine Menge passiert. Und jetzt muss es eben auch Konsequenzen haben. Meine Vermutung ist im Sommer. Also wenn sie bis zum Sommer da jetzt nicht groß geäußert haben, dann ist es ein wirklicher Fail.
Ich meine, wir haben jetzt auch den Chef und den Aufsichtsrat vom Bär geschmissen und da wird trotzdem nicht aufgemacht nächste Woche. Also jetzt einfach nur Leute raus schmissen.
Ja gut, aber Bär ist nicht offen und Apple verkauft sich halt auf allen Fronten wie Scheiße, wie geschnitten Brot.
Aber den BER mit Apple Maps zu vergleichen, ist dann doch ein bisschen unfair für Apple Maps.
Also das ist... Machen wir einen Vergleich, der passt, vergleichen wir den Apple Store in Berlin damit. So haben wir auch mal ein Thema aufgemacht. Der Apple Store Bär, genau. Ja, ich hab nicht viel Neues, nur ein bisschen was. Ich weiß, dass jetzt auch an den Fahrstühlen gearbeitet wird.
Dass da auch kein Wasser mehr eindringt.
Es geht voran, also da sind die Arbeiten wohl... Naja, also die stehen zumindest nicht still und sie haben meines Wissens auch keinen Chef gefeuert. Zumindest nicht so, dass überhaupt nichts mehr geht. Meine Vermutung, Vermutung, wirklich nur eine Vermutung, ist immer noch sowas wie März. Meine Vermutung.
März, das wär relativ flott.
Flott? Na ja, dafür, dass wir den letzten September aufmachen wollten. Ne, im Juni. Juli?
Ja gut, aber in Berlin ist man halt auch andere Zahlen gewohnt.
Wie immer, wenn wir verkacken, dann auch richtig.
Ja, richtig und dann auch nicht nur an einer Stelle.
Ich hab ja auch nochmal zum Flughafen, hab ja so ein bisschen in der Wikipedia gelesen und wie das eigentlich dazu gekommen ist, dass die sich dann doch für Schönefeld entschieden haben und so und wie das dann da eigentlich gelaufen ist und dann haben sie irgendwie ja, erst wollten sie halt ein Unternehmen haben, was so die Generalaufsicht hat und alles so, alle Fäden in der Hand hält und das managt. Dann haben sie eine Ausschreibung gemacht und dann hat nur hoch tief gewonnen oder waren überhaupt qualifiziert genug, so diese Ausschreibung zu gewinnen. Dann haben sie das abgesenkt, die Hürden, um diese Ausschreibung zu gewinnen. Dann gab es mehrere Gewinner sozusagen und dann gab es halt irgendwelche komischen Probleme mit Preisabsprachen und so weiter. Dann haben die sich untereinander abgesprochen oder so und dann haben sie gesagt, ja ne, wir suchen uns jetzt einen Gesellschafter und der vergibt alle Gewerbe oder alle Gewerke einzeln und beaufsichtigt die. Wenn ihr das für so ein Projekt wie ein Flughafen anhört, wo du einen Gesellschafter hast, der dann Milliarden-Subunternehmer hat, der eine macht dies, der andere macht das und die müssen alle zusammenfinden, da wundert einen auch nichts mehr.
Am besten Neubau.
Ja, Sperrenberg ist ja noch da.
So, ich wollte ja mal über Max reden hier.
Ach, ich muss mal kurz aufs Klo.
Habt ihr den neuen iMac schonmal angefasst?
Nö, aber den hab ich noch nicht.
Der dünne? Du willst wirklich gehen, ne? Geh mal. Aber erst geh mal Gebühr bezahlen.
Do I look fat, iMac? Sozusagen? Ja, ja, das Mager-Modell war aus dem richtigen Winkel ganz dünn und aus dem falschen Winkel sieht er irgendwie komisch aus.
Also ich hab das Ding gesehen, sowohl den Kleinen als auch den Großen und ich war erstmal eigentlich sehr angenehm angetan von der Overall Appearance. Also ich fand das Ding so an sich nicht falsch. Also ich finde auch nicht, dass das jetzt irgendwo fett aussah oder so. Es war so eine ganz korrekte Rundung. Ich freu mich halt trotzdem noch, ob der Kompromiss jetzt unbedingt so krass hätte sein müssen, dass man dem kleinen Modell da nicht mal einen RAM-Slot verpasst. Also das ist halt jetzt wieder so ein Gerät, wo auch die RAM-Konfiguration ein für alle Mal nach der Bestellung festgelegt ist. Ich weiß nicht, welche Erfahrungen Apple so macht. Ob dann irgendwie sowieso alle dann mit Maximum RAM bestellen, das tun sie bestimmt nicht.
Ich glaube, dass niemand bei Apple RAM kauft, weil es so teuer ist. Und sie deswegen meinen, dass auch niemand updated. Weil sonst würden sie es ja bei Apple kaufen.
Das stimmt.
Ja, okay, sehr steile These.
Ich habe, glaube ich, nie in irgendeinem Gerät, wo man mit RAM auswechseln kann, original Apple RAM drin.
Warum auch?
Oder den so bestellt. Warum auch?
Ich auch nicht, nee.
Hab jetzt gerade, wo wir gerade über ein Thema sind, hab mir jetzt nochmal einen aktuellen Mac Mini gekauft. Ja, den schön mit 16G vollgepackt, für ein Apple und ein Ei. Ja, keine Ahnung, was hat mich die kost bei Cyberport oder sowas. 50 Euro oder sonst oder 60 Euro.
Was für ein Mac Mini hast du gekauft?
Ja, diesen Core i7. Ja, mit den 2,7 GHz.
Also das rechts unten Modell oder was?
Das ist top. Also nicht mit den zwei Platten, sondern den, also was Prozessoren geht.
Moment, ich guck mal kurz hier.
Das ist ein Core i7 2,7, glaub ich. Quad Core i7 2,7 GHz.
2,7, aber 2,3 GHz.
Nee, den kannst du dann noch hochklicken. So, und das ist ja ein 2,7.
Aber das ist das Basismodell erstmal.
Da stopfst du wirklich für ein Apple und ein i, den stopfst du voll mit 16G. Dann hab ich dem eine schöne, diese Samsung... Also der kommt mit vier.
Der kommt mit vier. Zweimal zwei. Du hast den gekauft.
So hab ich den im Laden gekauft, weil wie gesagt, ich den eh aufbohre, du kriegst den nicht ohne RAM.
Ja, dann hast du die zwei Mal zwei rausgeschmissen und gegen zwei Mal acht reingemacht. So, das Upgrade kostet dich dann was?
Du müsstest jetzt bei Cyberport nochmal klicken, wann? Irgendwie 50 oder 60 Euro oder sowas für die zwei, für die 16G.
60 Euro für 16G.
Oder so, oder lass es 70, ich hab ja so eine Gesamtrechnik, kann gleich nochmal drauf schauen.
Wow, Apple nimmt dafür 300.
Warte mal, Cyberport...
Alter Falter, 32GB für 600 Euro, Donner Schock. Ist bestimmt aber auch der gute ECC-RAM.
Was muss denn da rein? DDR3?
Da steht nichts von ECC, aber...
Nee, da muss bestimmt kein ECC rein.
Muss nicht, aber weiß schon. Wird zumindest den Preis so ein bisschen rechtfertigen. Schon erstaunlich.
So, warte, also das ist wirklich... Ich will nicht sagen billig wie Dreck, aber es ist wirklich schon nicht mehr feuerlich. Warte, zu viel Zeug sein gescannt in letzter Zeit. Da ist Cyberport Rechnung. So, und wir haben dit Ram, Ram, Ram, Ram? Ach, das ist noch eine alte Rechnung. Ist blöde, wenn man jetzt erstmal eine was... Von wann ist die? So, also es ist ein 2,7 i7 4 GB mit 1 TB Platte, gibt's halt nicht ohne. Und dann, wie gesagt, ist da Ram drin, da kostet der Riegel, Riegel, Riegel, Riegel, Kingston, kostet 56,90.
Ein Achter.
Ein Achter. Okay, also doch denn schon. Das eine, der eine Riegel kostet.
Also 120 Euro sozusagen, aber hier werden 300 fällig.
Und dann ist da, habe ich da eine Samsung-SSD drin, diese 800, 840 Pro-Serie. Die ist, die macht Spaß. Die macht richtig Spaß.
Ich habe da viel Gutes drüber gehört.
Die ist, sieht auch relativ sexy aus, macht auch mechanisch einen ganz netten Eindruck und so. Also dreht ja nicht, aber ist trotzdem auch gut da zu händeln. Kaum Laufgeräusche.
Hätte man Samsung gar nicht zugetragen.
Macht wirklich ernsthaft im Schreiben und lesen ihre 525, 530 Megabit pro Sekunde.
Ihr habt gehört, ihr seid auch extrem performant und extrem, naja, zuverlässig kann man jetzt noch nicht so richtig sagen.
Diese Pro-Serie, die sie noch mal haben, die haben auch da irgendwie nochmal andere Flashchips drin.
Es gibt eine 840 und eine 840 Pro.
Genau, musst du aufpassen. Und die kannst du daran zum Beispiel erkennen, dass die 840 oder also die nicht Pro-Serie, die haben denn nicht die 256, sondern 250 Gigabyte oder so. Und die Pro, ich glaube die 500, ich hab eine 500 der mir geleistet dafür auch, die hat richtig 512 Gigabyte. Die macht wirklich Spaß. Also die schreibt wirklich schnell, bis sie halt schon ziemlich dicht, sehr dicht am Ende von dem, was halt dein SatA3 überhaupt rausrückt.
Warte mal, die Pro hat 128, die normale hat 120.
Genau.
Da ist der Preis aber schon ein Unterschied.
Die nicht Pro, lesen tun sie beide gleich schnell, aber beim Schreiben ist die Pro doppelt so schnell. Also wenn du die nicht Pro nimmst, die liest zwar 500 Megabyte pro Sekunde oder 500 Quitsch, aber schreibt nur 250. Und die Pro schreibt und liest die über die 500. Hab ich auch ausprobiert. Und das macht echt Spaß, weil das Interessante ist, dieser Mac Mini, das war schon immer so, seit die ersten da raus kamen, das ist eigentlich ein ziemlich geiler Kraftknubbel. Er ist halt, normalerweise wird er mit einer total lausigen Laptop-Platte ausgeliefert, die die Performance von dem Ding total in Bach zieht. Ich hab also schon meine ersten Minis relativ bald, denn damals mit Externfire war ja 800-Interface ausgestattet mit einer ordentlichen Lassie-Platte dahinter oder sowas, dann machten die schon Spaß. Aber jetzt die neuen Dinger und das Ding ist halt eben klein, nicht mal eine Höheneinheit hoch, da passen zwei von nebeneinander in so einen Rack rein und vier oder sechs sogar hintereinander, wenn du so willst. Verbraucht wahnsinnig wenig Strom und ist ein echter Kraftknubbel. Das hat ja nur acht CPUs sozusagen, mit denen du da arbeiten kannst. Mit dem 16G RAM kann man auch super umvirtualisieren. Ich hab jetzt mal ein bisschen... Wie groß ist deine SSD, die du gekauft hast? Ich hab die 512er.
Ja, könnte schon noch ein bisschen billiger werden, diese SSDs.
Könnte billiger werden, kostet... Was hat die gekostet? Also war so 500 feature Euro.
Wenn du jetzt sozusagen auf die hohe Freit-Performance verzichten kannst, weil normalerweise brauchste ja, um jetzt, sagen wir mal, dass der Max-Smooth läuft, ist ja vor allem die Read-Performance.
330 MB Schreiben ist also wirklich... Also ich meine, meine Intel SSD, die jetzt nun echt auch schon zwei Jahre alt ist, ja fast, oder? Nee, nicht zwei, aber anderthalb. Auf jeden Fall mindestens ist die alt. Die schreibt mit, was weiß ich, 180 Megabyte die Sekunde, wenn ich da mal so einen Wikipedia-Dump aus dem Bit-Torrent ziehe und dann wieder mal auf Pause drücke und dann mal kurz das ganze File wegschreiben muss. Das geht halt so, frummt, das dauert ein paar Sekunden, dann sind die Gigabyte da weggeschrieben. Wenn das jetzt noch dreimal so schnell geht, okay super, aber das ist echt schon auf so einem Level, wo mich das schon, also wenn ich nicht wirklich so einen Anwendungsfall habe, wo ich regelmäßig so...
Ich hab mich mit dem Ding auch so ein bisschen auf so Virtualisierungsgeschichten kapriziert und da wuppste halt eben mal so eine virtuelle Maschine, die hat halt dann eben mal 30, 40G oder so was und das macht halt eben Spaß, wenn du die klonen kannst in wenigen Sekunden, wenn du sozusagen dazu guckst, wie der Balken da weggelaufen ist. Und das ist bei mir halt eben auch eine Long-Term-Investment. Das steht nicht auf dem Schreibtisch, sondern das ist mein Hosting-Server, den ich beim Hosting abschmeiße. Und den will ich auch nicht dauernd immer anfassen wieder. Den stelle ich jetzt da hin und wenn das nächste Mal auseinanderfällt, dann zwei, drei Jahre entgegen, mal wieder hin und tausche dann noch mal einen Teil oder so was, sonst würde ich den nicht dauernd anfassen. Was denn sonst?
Denis meint gerade übrigens, dass die Intel auch 330 hat.
Es gibt keinen... Die XServe gibt es ja nicht mehr.
Ich meine, warum Mac?
Weil das die Arbeits... Die Oberfläche ist die Benutzer, die ich gut finde und ich finde Unix darunter gut. Und ich habe mich an die Dinger gewöhnt und ich finde die Hardware geil. Wie gesagt, das Ding ist auch... Für die Größe, für die mechanische Größe, die er hat, ist es ein ziemlich geiler Kraftnubbel. Und einer meiner Hauptgründe, warum ich diese Dinger benutze, ist, weil sie halt einfach überall gibt. Wenn ich irgendein PC-Ding nehme, muss ich dann irgendwie einen BSD oder einen Lidungsdruck drauf spielen, aber da könnte man ja drüber reden. Aber in dem Moment, wo ich mit dem Ding unterm Arm aus dem Laden rausmarschiere, gibt es es nicht mehr. Da kommt die Next Generation Mainboard. Oder tralala, da kriegst du keine Teile dafür oder so was. Und ein Mini ist zwar richtig ernsthaftes Equipment, aber das kann ich im Media Markt kaufen gehen. Wenn ich mit dem Ding Sorgen habe, wenn er mir wirklich auseinanderfällt, fahr ich in den nächsten Scheiß-Sartorn und kauf mir so ein Ding und ersetze den. Das ist sozusagen Profi-Equipment, was es sozusagen im hobbyisten Handel gibt.
Bitte nicht mehr Kraftknubbel sagen.
Und er verbraucht, er hat, selbst wenn du ihn auf den Desk einsetzt, er macht nicht so einen Alarm, der macht eigentlich fast gar keinen Krach, den hörst du eigentlich nicht, er ist recht mit einer SSD, verbraucht wahnsinnig wenig Strom und ist einfach eine ziemlich geile Hardware.
Kannst du auch als Föhn benutzen, wenn ihn wirklich ausreizt?
Ja, wenn ich mal, aber das ist schon echt aufwendig. Da muss ich schon mehrere virtuelle Maschinen starten, wo dann noch richtig gerechnet wird.
Also ich hab mal etwas älteren und der macht immer gut, gut warme Luft hinten raus. Allerdings ist er nie laut. Also du hältst halt die Hand hin und denkst, aua.
Der kommt zwar draus. Aber er ist, er macht wie gesagt keinen Krach und mit der schnellen Platte macht schon Spaß, wenn du mit diesen acht CPUs dort mal einen Compilerlauf machen willst. Also einfach mal so ein, ich hab jetzt nur ein bisschen rumgebanchmarkt, hab das Ding jetzt, bin damit seit drei Wochen am spielen, aber so OpenSSL, OpenSSL inklusive Tests oder sowas, ein Make mit den Tests hinten dran läuft so in 20, 22 Sekunden durch oder so.
Der war letztendlich heutzutage, also die haben ja alle...
Noch mal, für diese Hardware, für diese Größe dort, klar, das kann man dicke Kisten bauen. Ich hab auch schon in meinem Beruf früher mal Sandkisten gebaut mit 48 Platten.
Die Studio-Server sind heutzutage ja auch nicht mehr so fette Monster, da kriegst du heute auch acht Kerne in so einem Box, das irgendwie nicht mehr anderthalb Meter lang ist, sondern irgendwie zwei oder drei Höhen einhalten, sondern die sind ja auch alle jetzt relativ schlank geworden.
Ein anderer Grund, warum ich auch ein Mac-Hardware nehme, ist, weil ich darauf zumindest legal auch ein Mac virtualisieren kann. Ich kann halt einen virtuellen Mac... Klar kannst du einen virtuellen Mac auch auf eine Lieblingskiste laufen lassen, darfst du aber nicht. Lizenz. Aber Apple gibt dir ja die Lizenz, dass du dein Lein und dein Mountain-Line darfst du ja vollkommen legal mit Sägen und Tralala und Soße und Schaf auf einer VM laufen lassen. Auch mehrere davon. Hauptsache die Hardware darunter ist es von Apple. Und ich benutze diese Szenarien gerade in der Virtualisierung dafür, um Test-Setups zu machen, die ich halt mithilfe dieser Snapshots, die diese virtuellen Maschinen haben, sofort wieder zurücksetze. Das heißt, ich habe eine leere Maschine, wo ich mein komplettes Setup mache und alle möglichen Tests mache, Testdaten generiere, neue da reinschaufel und so. Und dann will man den Server tunen und dann willst du deinen Kleint wieder zurücksetzen. Mach ich mit einem Tasten Druck. Zup! Hab ich ein Mac, wie er vor 10 Minuten war. Exakt so. Im laufenden Betrieb. Und dann lass ich den nächsten Test wieder laufen und so. Da kann man ein sehr lustiges Szenario mitbauen. Und wie gesagt, ich mag das Zeug auch einfach.
Das funktioniert ziemlich gut.
Ich hab lange Zeit Virtual Box benutzt. Das hat mich neulich mal gebissen. Weil es nämlich ganz obskure Probleme manchmal hat mit komischerweise mit USB. Im simpelsten USB.
Ja, aber Virtual Box ist auch so ein... Das kann man so langsam auch so aufs Abstellgleis nehmen und dann schieben.
Da haben die Leute langsam den Griff drauf und so. Und dann hab ich mal geguckt, wo ich lange Zeit Virtual Box verfechter war und hab gesehen, Fusion ist unglaublich billig, finde ich. Jetzt kostet irgendwie die Einzelplatzlizenz 49 Euro oder so. Und ich hab jetzt noch diese Pro-Version, weil du da auch virtuelle Netze drin definieren kannst und so Zeugs, die kostet dann 79. Aber es ist immer noch zweistellig.
Aktuelle Version ist 5 dann.
Und es tut einfach zack.
Ja, das ist unglaublich. Du schmeißt da den Mountain-Line-Installer da auf das Fusion.
Genau.
Und dann macht er dir eine virtuelle Maschine, wo du halt Mountain-Line drin hast. Das ist schon so, was geht hier ab?
Und gerade diese Sachen machen halt eben Spaß, wenn du diese schnelle Platte hast. Du würfst da drauf, installiert in die Kiste in acht Minuten oder sonst irgendwas und fertig.
Ich hatte das auch unter Virtual Box versucht und hab da mit dem EFI rumgekrampft und getan und gemacht.
Und hab dann nach ein paar Stunden gedacht, was tu ich hier? Also Virtual Box war zu Zahnzeiten schon immer ein bisschen gefrickelt, aber sie haben es halt eigentlich noch ziemlich, sie haben schon immer gute Updates rausgeschoben und seitdem der Oracle am Ruder ist, ist das nur noch so ein Mini-Rumgepetsche und das wird eigentlich, hab ich so immer das Gefühl, schlimmer als besser.
Ich hab jetzt aus Spaß, übrigens noch mal, wir sind ja in der Freak Show, mal sehen, kann man denn eigentlich auf einem virtuellen Mac mal einen virtuellen Mac installieren? Ja, man kann.
Du hast im Gastsystem noch mal ein Fusion installiert und hast in dem Fusion noch mal ein Mac installiert.
Funktioniert tadellos. Warum? Weil ich es kann. Wenn ich jetzt richtig lange Weile mal habe, dann installier ich in dieser Maschine noch mal einen VMWR und guck mal, wie weit ich damit komme.
Was ich geil fand.
Ich wollte nur sagen, rein von der Performance, diese Platten-Performance hat der Fan gesagt, die hab ich gar gemessen, diese 500-Quitsch-Megabyte, die kriege ich in der ersten Etage, also in der ersten virtuellen Maschine, kriege ich die auch noch hin. Und das finde ich schon deswegen erstaunlich, weil die geht ja durchs Filesystem von dem realen Mac durch. Das geht ja nicht roh auf die Platte, sondern das heißt, das Filesystem scheint die ganze Sache gar nicht so, also der Virtualisierungslayer und das Filesystem schwächtet nicht ab, schwächt diese Platten-Performance nicht ab. In der zweiten Etage halbiert sich das, da kriegt noch diese 250 Megabyte pro Sekunde hin, aber in der ersten Virtualisierungs-Etage hast du eine ziemlich gute Performance. Also das Ding ist sehr fluffig. Und das macht halt eben Spaß mit den Snapshots, weil sie die eben auch in Realtime restoren. Das heißt, du hast plötzlich am Machen, fährst mit der Maus rum und dann drückst du auf den Restore-Knopf und mittendrin ändert sich dein Bildschirm alles wieder so, wie das auf dem Snapshot war. Deine Maus steht an einer anderen Stelle und fertig. Dann ist das Ding wieder so wie vorher.
Das war auch gewagt.
Ich wollte mal kurz zu dieser Samsung-Platte was sagen, die ist ja relativ neu auf dem Markt. Bei der 830 war noch nicht alle ganz so begeistert, aber ich hab von der 840 jetzt viel Gutes gehört. Wenn man jetzt auf diese Pro-Super- High-End-Wreitleistungen verzichten kann, was man meiner Meinung nach durchaus...
Dann nimmst du die ohne Pro.
Dann nimmst du die ohne Pro und die ist ja echt billig. Also 500 Gigabyte kriegst du für 67 Cent das Gigabyte. Ja, das ist für mich so ein bisschen jetzt die Größenordnung, die immer zählt. Und mit den Intels bist du halt immer noch so bei, naja, je nach dem, 120 bis 150.
Also meine Empfehlung zum Thema SSD ist, wenn man sich da schon mal so ein paar Modelle rausgesucht hat bei anderen Tech, danach zu suchen und die ganzen Reviews sich durchzulesen und die möglichen Probleme und so. Zum Beispiel bei anderen Tech gibt's da so ein paar Posts, da sind in drei oder vier von den 840ern innerhalb von wenigen Tagen gestorben. Und jetzt hatten sie da auch kürzlich ein Update, wo sie gemeint haben, dass Samsung meinte, ja, das war die Pre-Production-Firmware und das war jetzt nur auf den Samples und in den und ich hab da noch mal.
Das wird bestimmt nicht wieder.
Genau so. Jetzt ist es ihnen halt bisher nicht wieder passiert. Aber auf anderen Tech, also zu diesem Thema kriegt ihr keine erschöpfenen Reviews oder Tests oder Benchmarks oder Vergleich oder was auch immer. Das ist nach wie vor so die Quelle. Und dann müsst ihr euch halt selber ein Bild machen, welche Trade-offs dann sozusagen, Preis, Performance, Lese, Schreiben, was auch immer, Firmware.
Da kann ich auch noch mal einhaken. Ich hatte ja vor zwei Sendungen oder so gesagt, dass ich das optische Laufwerk rausgeworfen hab und dafür eine SSD rein. Und das Ganze dann zu einem Fusion-Drive zusammen gemanscht und das tut bis jetzt ohne Probleme. Also ich kann es nach wie vor empfehlen.
Immer noch? Du hast jetzt auch schon zwei Monate, drei Monate drin, ne? Wann war das Patel auf Meeting? War im November, ne? Da hattest du mir davon erzählt.
Also Fusion funktioniert, das wundert mich auch ehrlich gesagt nicht, weil wenn Apple das sozusagen so als Konfigurationsoption für neue Computer macht, dann müssen sie sich auch schon sehr sicher sein, dass das läuft. Nicht, dass sie da noch mal so ein Maps-Desaster auf Festplatten-Ebene, das wär's ja.
Und ich hab bisher auch...
Ja, wir haben da eine Datei gefunden. Sie befindet sich nur wenige Gigabyte entfernt von dem Ort, wo sie zuletzt war. Aber das ist ja wohl nicht so schlimm.
Nee, ich hab aber auch nicht dieses Gefühl, jetzt öffne ich mal eine Datei und die ist langsam und jetzt öffne ich mal eine Datei und die ist schnell.
Das ist eigentlich immer schnell.
Das ist eigentlich irgendwie immer schnell. Also, keine Ahnung.
Ich hab auch das jetzt vor zwei... Ich hab ja zwei iMacs, die quasi... Also, ich benutze den einen gerade mit einer Festplatte, mit zu wenig RAM.
Ich werd verrückt.
Wie furchtbar, langsam, das geht überhaupt nicht mehr.
Das ist echt ein Pain bei den Dingern, die Platte zu wechseln.
Ja, das teuerste an dem ganzen Spaß sind bloß diese externen Gehäuse. Die Firewire-Gehäuse, da gibt's ja eigentlich nur einen Hersteller. Die sind noch nicht Thunderbolt-fähig, die beiden, was?
Nee, die sind beide nicht...
Also, der eine ist so... Weil es gibt jetzt inzwischen auch diese inzwischen brauchbare Thunderbolt-Gehäuschen. Ich hab mir auch mal eins mitgenommen, damit ein bisschen gespielt wird.
Außer meinem R hab ich nix mit Thunderbolt. Da muss ich noch generell auf Firewire setzen.
Ja, das Thunderbolt setzt sich auch nicht durch.
Das ist die Frage, ne? Jetzt kommt USB mit irgendwie, ja, wir können jetzt hier auch 10 Gigabit irgendwie schaffen.
Ja, wahrscheinlich Brutto und Netto kommen wieder nur 7 an.
Ja, mit diesem Kommunikationsmodell. Ich hab da auch mal eine Zweifel, aber das Ding ist, dass sie natürlich dann wiederum mit so einer Aussage, wenn sie auf den Markt gehen, mit jetzt, wir können jetzt auch 10, dass es dann eben genug Leute gibt, die sich dann wieder davon abwenden, also von Thunderbolt abwenden.
Das Ding ist halt bei USB 3, egal wie es performt, egal ob es jetzt noch ein paar Prozent langsam ist als Thunderbolt, es gibt einfach ein Arsch voll Peripherie dafür. Und bei Thunderbolt, da braucht es so lange Zeit nicht mal eine Hand, also da haben so ein paar Finger tatsächlich gereicht, um die Peripherie, die da von Third Party kam, irgendwie zu zählen. Und jetzt so langsam kündigt sich dann doch mal viel, materialisiert sich, also angekündigt wurde ja schon vier, aber jetzt langsam materialisiert sich ja sogar was.
Was ist denn überhaupt mit den Sachen, die für letzten September zugesagt wurden? Gibt es die mittlerweile, diese komischen Docs und so weiter, von Belkin oder was?
Belkin hat es ja gerade downgegradet. Wir haben gesagt, wir machen es jetzt billiger, dafür bauen wir noch eine Funktionalität aus. Das ist glaube ich das SATA-Interface oder so. Aber gerade dieser Tag gestern oder so.
Ach echt, war das nicht das, was...
Wir haben gesagt, wir hauen jetzt billiger raus, aber dafür bauen wir noch einen Feature aus oder so.
Okay, der Chat ist schon schneller als wir.
Dafür ist er ja da.
Nur 299 Dollar, jawoll! Natürlich!
Klar! Ich war ja lange Zeit ein Feind von diesem USB-Zeug im Apple-Umfeld, weil er halt einfach nicht performt hat. Aber ich hab mir jetzt für den Mini als Time Machine-Volume noch so ein WD-Buck mit USB dran. Und da schreibe ich irgendwie 170 Megabyte pro Sekunde raus, was mir für mein Time Machine-Volume vollkommen reicht. Und damit ist der Zug für mich auch abgefahren. Also da stoche ich jetzt nicht mehr.
Vor allen Dingen ist die USB-Piloforie auch immer billiger. Das ist billig wie Sau.
Aber was soll jetzt hier diese DespicTillige? Machst du dir jetzt hier den Max oder was?
Nein, ich hab das alles schon mal erlebt mit Firewire. Wir saßen da so wie Apple Fanboys im Club und haben ja alle ausgelacht hier und haben uns irgendwie über das Firewire gefreut. Und ja, die Platten waren teurer und die Kabel waren teurer, aber es war auch geiler und es hat mehr performt. Und was ist aber passiert über all die Jahre? Das Einzige, was du an Third Party bekommen hast, war mal so eine Festplatte. Da haben sich aber die Hersteller auch sehr zurückgehalten. Da gab es immer so von zehn unterschiedlichen Modellen, mal eins mit Firewire dabei, was auch 20 Euro mehr gekostet hat. Und dann gab es ein paar Sony Videokameras, die i-Link Interface hatten, wo du dann aber auch nochmal ein spezielles Kabel brauchtest. Und all die schönen Versprechen von Firewire haben sich so in der Realität...
Außer Audio Interfaces.
Ja, ok. Audio Interfaces kann man auch nochmal. Genau. So und jetzt bei Thunderbolt dachtest du, ok, jetzt haben sie es ja gelernt, so mit Lizenzieren ihrer Schnittstelle und so ein bisschen mehr aufmachen und so ein bisschen jetzt mal Breite in den Markt und ist ja Intel noch mit dabei. Und was ist es? Ist wieder genau der gleiche Kram. Du wartest erstmal ein halbes Jahrzehnt, bis überhaupt die ersten Third-Party-Geräte rauskommen. Du zahlst wie gesagt 50 Euro für irgendwelche Verbindungskabel. Und 299 Dollar, überlegt euch das mal, was das für Geld ist, was ihr für 299 Dollar da draußen an Elektronik bekommt. Und die dreisten sich da jetzt echt einfach so ein Doc oder hier 399 Dollar.
Sie kündigen an, dass sie es jetzt doch für 299 verkaufen, wie sie das ursprünglich mal machen wollen. Dann haben sie den Preis erhöht. Jetzt kündigen sie an, dass sie ein Feature ausbauen, damit sie wahrscheinlich wieder auf diesen Preis kommen, weil sie festgestellt haben, für 400 nimmt das überhaupt keiner mit.
Und was haben sie jetzt ausgebaut, das SATA-Interface?
Ich weiß nicht ganz genau, was sie ausgebaut haben.
Das geht natürlich nicht in der Presse, die ist drin von Belkin, aber das findest du wieder bei Ars Technica oder so.
Dieses Interface geht mir jetzt schon so auf den Zünder.
Also meine einzige Hoffnung dabei ist ja, Firewire war ja eine richtige Apple-Entwicklung. Und Thunderbolt kommt von Intel. Und ich mein, USB kommt auch von Intel. Da ist noch ein bisschen die Tür offen. Also...
Bei Firewire war so lange die Tür offen, sie haben sie einfach nicht aufgemacht.
Ja, aber da hat irgendwann Apple aber auch radikal die Lizenzzahlungen hochgesetzt.
Ja, das ist nicht nur das, es ist auch das so eben lange Zeit, und ich glaube, das ist auch immer noch so. Deswegen sind auch diese Geräte auch heute noch so teuer. Also dieses Firewire-Festplattengehäuse zum Beispiel hat einfach ein, weiß nicht mal genau, wo der Preis ist, aber im Vergleich zu USB-Gehäusen ist es einfach exorbitant viel mehr, mindestens das Doppelte. Das liegt daran, dass du halt einfach nochmal einen extra Stein dafür brauchst. Du brauchst halt einfach nochmal einen extra Firewire-Controller, weil das halt nicht in den anderen Dingern, die du sowieso einbauen musst, Automatschmitte, das USB...
Das liegt aber an den Lizenzzahlungen. Wie gesagt, also Apple hat halt irgendwann die Lizenzgebühren erhöht und danach hat Firewire halt einfach den Knick gemacht und dann war es vorbei. Also das...
Das hat auch was mit zu tun, dass diese Standard-System-Chipsets, die halt Intel rausgebracht hat für die ganzen Rechner, die hatten halt einfach USB alle dabei und Firewire eben nicht.
Ja, denn doch eine Weile lang hatten also auch sehr, sehr viele PCs hatten auch ein Firewire-Port.
Ein Port oder auf ein Chipset?
Na ein Port, ich weiß nicht, ob der mit dem Chipset war.
Das war ein extra Controller, das war immer ein extra Controller.
Genau, eine Weile gab es da einen Markt für.
Die komischen Stecker, die hatten diesen ganz, das war nicht dieser komische, der aussieht wie ein Haus oder ein Firewire 800-Stecker, sondern der war noch irgendwie mal so ein bisschen anders wie ganz obskure Stecker, die so ein PCs da eingebaut haben für Firewire. Aber ich sagen wollte, ein Punkt, der mich an Thunderbolt wirklich so richtig nervt, ist, du hast zu wenig Ports. Die einzigen Devices, die es gibt, sind jetzt die nagelneuen MacBook Pros oder sowas, die mal zwei von diesen Dingern haben, ansonsten hast du bloß einen. Und dann musst du auch gucken, wenn du denen eine Platte kaufst, dass du sie wenigstens noch einen zweiten Port hat, sonst war's das nämlich.
Wenn du noch Ethernet verwenden möchtest.
Oder wenn du nur eine zweite Platte vielleicht verwenden willst irgendwann mal, sonst war einfach deine Thunderbolt-Story endet dort einfach. Wenn du bloß einen Port hast, mit 50 Euro Kabel dazwischen und dann da hinten eine Platte, die auch bloß ein Loch hat, dann war's das.
Endet vorbei. Also so wie die das angehen, ist das so eine Todgeburt.
Es gibt da keine Hubscreen, keine Switches, keine Tralala, sondern das ist höchstens die Chain. Und wenn du ein Gerät mal hast, was bloß ein Loch hat, endet deine Thunderbolt-Story an dieser Stelle.
Am Anfang bei Firewire war auch so.
Ja, dass sozusagen die drehen eher so auf der Achse.
Die richtige Richtung zeigt.
Ja, naja, also ich sehe da... Ich bin da sehr pessimistisch.
Gut, danke Max für diesen Antrag.
Nee, das ist pure Enttäuschung. Also du hast es doch gerade ausgeführt. Warum? Unter anderem. Also es ist ja nicht so, dass ich hier irgendwie an der Realität vorbei rede. Wir reden da schon so lange davon und hoffen so lange. Und Apple selber, das ist ja eigentlich wirklich das Dramatischste von allem, dass Apple selber auch überhaupt nicht da aus dem Telekom. Wie lange hat es gebraucht, bis dieser Ethernet-Adapter usw. kam? Und einen Doc von Apple gibt es auch nicht außer in Form eines wie viel 100 Euro Displays, also ich meine echt.
Dieser Adapter mit diesem sinnlos langen Stecker, da ist ein Chip drin, deswegen ist der so lang. Ja, ich weiß, aber der ist halt da und der legt eine unglaubliche Hebelkraft auf diesen Port. Ich hab immer das Gefühl, dieses Ethernet-Kabel, was dann so nach hinten geht.
Richte dein MacBook eher durch?
Ja, weiß ich nicht. Irgendwann steht das so 45 Grad ab und behauptet trotzdem noch drin zu stecken und ich frage mich, wie es wohl innen in dem Rechner aussieht. Also das ist keine...
Das ist nicht gut. There is room for improvement.
Und ich geh jetzt auch erstmal auf Feuerwehr, weil das abgehangene Technologie ist. Na gut, die Geräte haben halt noch nichts anderes. So wollen wir mal ein bisschen in die iWorld eintauchen.
Oh, jetzt schon.
Ja, Roddy war ja in den USA und hat sich gelangweilt.
Genau.
Und wie das so ist, was macht man, wenn man sich langweilt?
Das ist ja eine schöne Farbe.
Man geht in den Apple Store.
Und kauft sich was.
Wenn sie es da haben.
Schöne Farbe vom Deckel.
Erzähl doch mal deine Geschichte.
Also ich war da, glaube ich, ja, am zweiten Tag oder so. Hast du nicht so schnell gelangweilt? Da sind wir so direkt mal in den Apple Store gegangen, war auch relativ voll und so weiter. Und dann habe ich so, ja, mal gefragt, wie ist denn hier mit iPad Mini und so. Dann guckt er da so.
Wo war das in Portland?
In Portland. Genau. Und der, das ist Pioneer Place, genau, der ist das.
Ist auch so ein kleiner.
Ja, der ist sehr überschaubar. Und dann tippelt der da in seinem iPhone rum. Die haben ja immer dieses iPhone mit dem Scanner dran und mit diesem riesen Akku-Pack hinten dran.
Hier in Deutschland laufen sie mit dem iPad in der Hand rum.
Der tippelt da rum so, ja, ja, haben wir noch zwei von. Geht nach hinten und kommt ewig nicht wieder. Und dann kommt er irgendwann zurück und so, ja, hab ich nicht gefunden, haben wir doch nicht. Steht da zwar drin, haben wir aber nicht. Und dann, weil wir ja zu mehreren da waren, sind wir irgendwann irgendwie mit diesem, scheinbar mit dem Store-Manager ins Gespräch gekommen. Keine Ahnung, das war so ein etwas älterer, distinguierterer, der hatte zwar auch das rote T-Shirt an, aber irgendwie und dann meinte ich so, ja, ich hätte ja ein iPad gekauft, aber sie haben das nicht da, was ich haben will und moment, moment, tippel, tippel, tippel. Er hat halt auch nachgeguckt, meinte, ja doch, da haben wir doch noch welche von. Und ich so meinte so, was denn nun? If you still have it and if you can find it, I'll buy it. Und dieses Gesicht, dieses Gesicht, sowas musst du mal zu einem Applestore-Mitarbeiter sagen, das war großartig. Der hatte so diese leuchtenden Augen, dieses Jagdfieber. Dann ist er nach hinten verschwunden und kam dann relativ schnell wieder nach vorne und meinte so, nee, ist vorbestellt. Ja, da war noch eins, aber ansonsten, nee, die ganzen Cellular-Dinge, also die hatten halt immer nur die mit Wifi und die mit Cellular waren nicht aufzutreiben. Also die hatten halt überhaupt keine da. Und dann haben die mir aber den Tipp gegeben, ja, es gibt dieses 10 p.m. Shopping, da kann man dann, ja, das gibt es hier glaube ich nicht. Was ist das? Du kannst auf der Apple-Webseite nach 10 Uhr abends, 10 p.m. Shopping, kannst du halt, kannst du im Apple Store das Gerät zusammenklicken und kannst dann sagen, ich möchte jetzt aber 10 p.m. Shopping machen und ich hole das dann im Store ab. Nee, am nächsten Tag. Und es ist so, die kriegen halt irgendwie abends ihre Lieferung und tragen das dann ein in das System, was sie da haben und du kannst halt dann online das Zeug direkt kaufen und dann hast du es gekauft und dann liegt es für dich schon im Apple Store und dann kannst du es halt morgens abholen, wenn der Laden aufmacht. Genau. Stellt sich heraus, das geht nur, wenn man eine Kreditkarte hat, die auch eine US-Billing-Adress hat. Sonst kannst du nämlich gar nichts kaufen im Apple Online Store.
Arschkarte.
Und dann hab ich halt immer die abends dann immer so geguckt, wie ist die Verfügbarkeit und dann halt mal hier eins in dem Store und dann war es mal beim anderen Store, grün und so weiter. Und dann waren die zwei Wochen fast schon rum und dann war so von einem Tag auf den anderen in allen Stores der Umgebung grün.
Weil du auf allen Stores die ganze Zeit so auf Request geklickt hast. Die mahnt.
Wahrscheinlich.
Da dachten schon, das kann doch nicht wahr sein. Was ist los mit Portland? Okay, dann laden wir meinen ganzen LKW ab.
Und dann bin ich gleich morgens hin und dann hatten sie tatsächlich noch eins. So, und wie ist's? Ich find's gut. Also, man muss sich halt entscheiden zwischen ich hab den kleinen Formfaktor und das niedrigere Gewicht oder ich hab das Retina-Display. Also es ist halt einfach die Entscheidung.
Das sagen viele Leute. Also einfach nur der Weg zurück. Der Weg zurück, wenn du jetzt eine Weile lang auf das iPad 3 drauf geguckt hast, dann auf diese Dinge. Das hatten ein paar Leute, aber die haben es relativ bald dann auch gesagt, mir ist es lieber, dass das kleiner ist und so und leichter und so.
Seit ich das Teil habe, kommt mir das inzwischen auch schon schwer vor. Aber so ein normales iPad ist halt jetzt ein Ziegelstein.
Also das ist irgendwie... Was für ein iPad hattest du denn vorher?
Na gut, vorher hatte ich nur das iPad 1. Das ist sowieso ein Ziegelstein.
Und überhaupt nicht die Bohne Retina.
Nicht die Bohne Retina. Insofern hat mich das nicht Retina auch nicht so sehr gestört. Ansonsten muss ich sagen, es ist halt einfach ein iPad.
Wozu hast du benutzt das iPad?
Wie benutzt?
Nur so für diverses. Also Mail und...
So regelmäßig?
Relativ regelmäßig. Ja, ich hatte es eigentlich immer dabei. Und wenn irgendwas war...
Hast du jetzt mit dem Mini immer noch genau das Gleiche oder benutztest mehr?
Ja, mehr. Also...
Ja, was heißt mehr? Mehr Mail lesen oder mehr andere Dinge tun oder so?
Das kann ich jetzt so nicht sagen, ehrlich gesagt. Also das ist so...
Oli, das Gesicht ist eben so voll so. Wieso ich verhöre? Wieso werde ich jetzt hier verhöre? Wird hier von sechs Augenpaaren angestarrt, hat eine Lampe im Gesicht.
Das wusste ich nicht, dass ich das auch benutzen soll. Ich dachte ich soll nur kaufen.
Naja, das ganz alte iPad hatte ja noch dazu das Problem, dass es kein iOS 6 mehr bekommen hat.
Schweine im Weltall.
Schweine im Weltall. Und das ist halt auch ganz schön, jetzt auch mal mein aktuelles iOS auf dem iPad zu haben. Mit den kaputten Karten. Mit den kaputten, die zwar schön aussehen, aber sind trotzdem kaputt. Mit den kaputten schönen Karten. Ja, keine Ahnung. Die Sachen, die mich stören, die liegen eigentlich eher an iOS als an dem iPad selber. Das ist so, dass man...
Ich bin ja stolz, dass ich es noch nicht gekauft habe.
Das Mini.
Was ich komisch finde, beim iPhone zum Beispiel hat man dieses Icon, wo man ein Foto machen kann. Man zieht es einfach vom Lock-Bildschirm aus hoch und dann kann man Foto machen. Gibt es beim iPad nicht?
Ja, weil die erkannt haben, dass es einfach albern aussieht mit dem iPad, egal ob groß oder klein, Fotos zu machen. Ich hatte das jetzt wieder in Stockholm auf der Veranstaltung, wo ich da war, da wird gerne mal so Sessions mal video-mäßig auf aufbereitet oder aufgenommen und es sieht total lächerlich aus, wenn Leute mit so einem Stuhlenbrett vorm Kopf dich videografieren. Das ist völlig bescheuert. Tim, sein Herren-Handtäschchen hat sein Herrn-Handtäschchen hervorgeholt.
Das passt so dermaßen cool da rein. Das ist genau der Grund, warum ich mich wundere, dass ich mir noch keines gekauft habe. Weil das irgendwie so perfekt ist. Also ich war ja schon so stolz mit meinem MacBook R11, dass ich so meine Default-Tasche war auf einmal A4. Und nicht so dieses übliche A3, mit dem man so rumrennt, normalerweise mit seinen MacBook Pros. Das empfinde ich auch schon als eine erhebliche Lebensqualität, dass ich einfach mit so einem kleinen Taschchen, was auch vertikal ist, was ich einfach am Körper viel besser trägt, genau, losziehen kann und im Prinzip alles dabei habe, was ich so für eine Tagesreise brauche.
Mit einem kleinen Taschchen. Eine Tagesration. Das passt jetzt sozusagen in deinen Brustbeutel hinein.
Genau, würde ich mit einem iPad leben können, was ich nicht kann, dann wäre das sozusagen die nächste Herausforderung, hier auf A5 zu gehen.
Also das Einzige, was man halt merkt, ist, dass diese ganzen Buttons und so weiter dann doch kleiner sind.
Aber so groß wie auf dem iPhone.
So groß wie auf dem iPhone, aber trotzdem gibt es Software, die der Meinung ist, die kommen damit klar, dass sie die Hit-Targets halt kleiner machen. Und zwar allen voran die Tastatur. Wenn man es senkrecht hält, also Portrait, dann ist ja die Tastatur, die man unten hat, ist ja ein bisschen kleiner. Und die wird halt noch mal kleiner. Und eigentlich müsste Apple diese Klappbuchstaben einbauen. Weißt du, du drückst auf eine Taste und dann klappt die Taste hoch. Das will man eigentlich nicht.
Das ist ja ein iPad.
Ja, aber eigentlich will man genau das haben für die Tastatur.
Verständlich. Ich war auch in deinem Apple Store. Ich kenne jetzt mehr als 50% aller deutschen Apple Stores. Was nicht sonderlich erhebend ist, weil sie sind ja alle gleich.
Du warst in allen dreien schon.
Was denkst du, wie viel es gibt?
12, 13, irgendwie sowas.
In den Städten, die mich interessieren, 0.
Das war nicht die Frage. Du kannst dich nicht selber anmachen, wenn du dich einmal kurz...
Wer bist du? Fünf? Batterie ist alle.
Dann mach ich dir mal neue Batterie rein, dann kannst du dich auch selber wieder einschalten. So, wie viele Stores gibt es in Deutschland? Es gibt... 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10. Genau, davon kenne ich jetzt sechs. Oder? Warte mal, da war ich, da war ich, da war ich, da war ich, da war ich... In Köln eins? Ach.
Warst du denn schon in Singelfingen? Da war ich.
Da war ich. Da war ich.
Ich kenne sieben von zehn. Wartest du denn schon in Singelfingen?
Du bist doch häufig da unten in der Ulmer-Gegend. Da ist doch Singelfingen da um die Ecke.
Ach komm.
Details.
Nee, nee. So ja nun nicht. Aber mal gucken, vielleicht mach ich das auch noch. Köln wär noch so ein Kandidat zum Abräumen. Mein schönes Bowling.
Meine V leuchtet.
Ja, das soll sie ja auch. Du bist die 2, sagt sie.
Ach der A.
Ist sozusagen so ein unnäheres Zählsystem.
Das soll sie auch. Die Sonne scheint mir auf den Bauch. Das soll sie auch. Im Wald da liegt ein Ofenrohr. Stell dir mal die Hitze vor.
Deswegen hab ich die Zimmer weggerufen, damit du hier so poetisch beitragen kannst. So, dann war ich also in Augsburg und ich hatte das Problem, dass ich einen MacBook Air live dabei beobachtet habe, wie es seinen WLAN irgendwie vergessen hat. Das war das Problem. Das war einfach auf einmal diesem Gerät nichts mehr zu entlocken. Das meinte einfach, ich hab keinen WLAN Device. Und alles mit irgendwie...
Was mit einem Air besonders doof ist.
Er besonders doof ist.
Ich hatte, naja gut, ich hatte auch meinen Internetadapter und so weiter, alles dabei. Aber natürlich wollte ich das behoben wissen. Und hab dann einfach mal kurz entschlossen, noch vor Weihnachten da einen Termin gemacht. Und bin da hingefahren und hab dir das mal gezeigt. An der Genius Bar. Genau. Und dann kam sie auch schnell zu der Überzeugung, dass ich total recht hatte, dass auch alle Power-Manager-Resets und alle SMC-Resets und sonstigen P-Ramen, was man da nicht alles machen kann, alles nichts bringt. Am Ende hat sich dann auch herausgestellt, dass tatsächlich dieses Device, das ist ja so eine Steckkarte auf dem Mainboard, auch wirklich das zeitliche Gesinne, das Interessante war.
In einem Air, da ist ja alles aufgelötet. Also in meinem Express, da hatte ich nämlich genau das selbe Problem, da ist eine Steckkarte. Nee, ist das auch nicht. Bei mir haben sie auch das Matterboard gewechselt übrigens. Aber in einem Air ist ja eigentlich alles aufgelötet. Der Airport, der ist immer noch steckbar.
Und dementsprechend war die Reparatur dann am Ende auch echt fair. Obwohl da jetzt kein Apple Care mehr drauf war, waren das dann so 50 Euro und dann nochmal 30 Euro für die eigentliche Reparatur. Also hab ich schon schlimmer erlebt. Das interessante war nur, dass...
Warte mal, wie lange hat es denn gedauert? Live? Während du da mit dem... Latte geschlürft hast und mit dem Genius gesteckert? Haben die das Ding im Backoffice repariert?
Im Backstage, im Pool noch geplanscht. Nein, nein, das hatten sie nicht da. Das ist jetzt nicht... MacBook Air erste Generation, die WLAN-Karte. Also das ist jetzt nichts, was sie mal so eben aus dem Regal ziehen.
Jedenfalls nicht in Augsburg.
Und schon gar nicht am letzten Tag vor Weihnachten. Also da hatten sie sozusagen auch die Reparatur-Queue war ausreichend gefüllt. Aber trotzdem, sie haben es dann in der ersten Januarwoche auch noch hinbekommen, pünktlich. Das war alles super. Und warum ich das überhaupt erwähne, ist, dass beim Check dieses Gerätes er hat dann so ein Hardware-Test-Tool da geholt. Also er hatte so eine wundersame Firewire-Festplatte, die so mit gefühlt 20 Partitions hochkam. Also so beim Booten und Altdrücken, so von links nach rechts, finde ich der ganze Bildschirm komplett mit so Partitionssymbolen gefüllt. Wo du dann sozusagen für jeden nur erdenklichen Geräte-Fall das Richtige hochbooten kannst. Und dann kamen halt so diese Hardware-Tests, die noch so richtig so Linux-Style im Textmodus booten und so. Und hat dann irgendwie durchgecheckt, um festzustellen, dass es natürlich am Ende auch wirklich keinen, also zwar er zwar das Modul sieht, ja, also so weit kam es dann doch schon noch, aber die Funktion irgendwie nicht wieder hergestellt werden konnte. Und dabei ist ihm dann aufgefallen, dass dieses Gerät nebenbei auch noch seine Seriennummer vergessen hatte. Und das, meinte er, das hätte er auch noch nicht gehabt, dass ein Mac seine Seriennummer vergisst. Und er schaute mich auch schon so ein bisschen so an, so mit diesem was willst du mir hier auf den Tisch legen? Max ohne Seriennummer?
Vielleicht hängt die Seriennummer ja an der Mac-Adresse von dem WLAN.
Von welchem asiatischen Dampfer bist du gerade runtergeklettert? Naja, und dann konnte ich ihn aber dann doch überzeugen, dass ich ein ganz seriöser Kunde bin und irgendwie definitiv da keinerlei Maßnahmen ergriffen hab, wo ich auf sowas Einfluss genommen hätte. Naja, Seriennummer steht ja trotzdem noch auf dem Gerät. Und dann hat er halt ein Tool gestartet, mit dem er diese Seriennummer tatsächlich wieder setzen konnte. Es gibt kein Tool, um sie zu löschen. Aber es gibt, also man kann sie nicht setzen, wenn sie gesetzt ist, aber es gibt ein Tool, mit dem man sie setzen kann, wenn sie nicht gesetzt ist.
Also scheint es doch offensichtlich doch schon mal vorgekommen zu sein, dass so ein Ding keine Seriennummer vergisst.
Naja, wenn es gebaut wird, dann...
Naja, aber er hat doch nicht den Foxcon Tool da auf dem Tisch in Augsburg. Du kannst mir doch nicht erzählen.
Wenn sie das Board tauschen, verliert es ja auch so seine Seriennummer, oder? Das war doch früher immer so das Ding. Wenn sie das Mainboard tauschen, oder?
Wenn sie das Mainboard tauschen, dann müssen sie natürlich da auch die alte Seriennummer wieder eintragen. Also das ist schon...
Naja, sicher.
Ich dachte, du kriegst eine neue Seriennummer, die hacken das einfach in ihrer Database durch.
Die Seriennummer steht ja auf dem Gerät drauf, die ist da ja eingelasert. Also wenn nicht alles komplett, also wenn es nicht ein Kompletttausch ist, dann vermute ich, wird das quasi als Reparatur am Gerät und mitbei behalten die Seriennummer etc. Weil es ja dann sozusagen, dann ist ja alles, ein neues Gerät ist halt alles getauscht, dann ist ja auch die Bau-Date neu.
Ich weiß noch, bei Nokia war es damals andersrum, wenn die dir da das Mainboard von deinem Telefon getauscht haben, dann hattest du eine neue E-Mail und dann hatten die einen E-Mail-Label-Drucker, dann hatten die so ein Ding, womit sie sozusagen das neue Label für das Batteriefach drucken konnten. Glaub ich jedenfalls.
Apple macht es andersrum. Dann ist mir noch was anderes aufgefallen. Was man gerne übersieht, das ist ja so ein Detail. Erstmal haben sie seit einem halben Jahr wohl mittlerweile ihr komplettes Reparaturmanagement auf iPads umgestellt. Also alles, womit die da interagiert haben, waren einfach nur noch iPads, die ganze Software.
Ich übrigens auch, ich mach immer iFixit. Diese iPad-App von iFixit?
Ach so, eine App von iFixit?
Es gibt eine App für das iPad von iFixit. Das kostet sogar nichts. Da sind die ganzen Reparaturmanuals drauf. So richtig mit Next Step, da nimmst du deinen Finger, schiebst ein Bild drüber und so. Das benutze ich immer. Wie gesagt, den Mac Mini haben wir jetzt auch immer umgeschraubt. Und so Zeugs. Und die haben die kompletten Reparaturmanuals und Ersatzteillisten. Da gibt es in einer iFixit App. Fürs iPad. Sehr nützlich auf dem Tisch, wenn man an den Dinger rumschraubt.
Ja, ist schon... ist schon geschoppt hier. Soweit man irgendwie von sowas überhaupt reden kann. Siehste kostet, mein ich. Gut, was mir noch aufgefallen ist, das mit den Kassen. Ist das eigentlich schon mal aufgefallen? Mit den Kassen in einem Apple Store?
Welche Kasse?
Das letzte Mal, als ich in einem Apple Store war, das war in New York, aber da gab es glaube ich erst einen oder zwei Apple Stores, und zwar den einen da in Soho in diesem Postamt. Und da war das alle noch vor iPad, noch vor iPhone, und da gab es auch eine Kasse. Sogar zwei.
Ja, aber die haben sie mittlerweile abgeschafft, komplett.
Ja, siehst du, das ist total an mir vorbei gegangen, weil ich seitdem nie wieder im Apple Store war.
Ich glaube, spätestens nachdem sie alles auf ihr eigenes Gerät umgestellt haben. Am Anfang hatten sie ja diese Windows-Mobile- Kassendevices, die auch genau so waren, wie ihr jetzt guckt. Naja, aber trotzdem gibt es einen Ort, also es kommt ja durchaus mal vor, dass jemand mal Bar zahlt und du Geld rausgeben musst. Wo ist die Kasse?
Hinten bei der Genius Bar, oder?
Hast du jetzt Lagepläne von Berliner Opel?
Ich stand, mir wäre es bestimmt nicht aufgefallen, hätte ich nicht zufällig gerade nachdem ich irgendwie fertig war, mich nochmal niedergelegt, ein bisschen meine Mail gecheckt habe auf meinem Rechner und ich stand direkt vor der Kasse, merkte es aber nicht. Es war nämlich einfach das Tischende eines Tisches, wo quasi in diesen Querbalken am Tischende tatsächlich eine Cash-Schublade drin war. Cash-Schublade, tatsächlich habe ich dann natürlich gleich mal auf den Hersteller geguckt und zwar handelt es sich dabei um ein Produkt der Firma Cash-Draw.
Sehr schön, sowas gibt es hier auch immer. Mit Wifi, was kann da schon schief gehen.
Was kann da schon schief gehen, genau.
Hast du hier auch jetzt eine eingebaut?
Naja, das ist halt auch so, dass die dann halt so ihre Verkäufe gemacht haben und dann eben von ihren iPhones, die ja dann noch diesen Barcode-Scanner da unten rangepuppt haben, quasi diese Kassenöffnung ausgelöst haben.
Wie gesagt, Kassenöffnung per Wifi, was kann da schon schief gehen.
Auf jeden Fall ein schönes Thema für den Kongress nächstes Jahr. Mal diese Cash-Drohr-Technologie mal hier so ein bisschen zu analysieren.
Mit Einwurf-Schlitzen vorne.
Aber das ist schon ganz putzig, du hast halt da so diese Teile und er drückt dann halt irgendwie auf irgendein Button und schon zwischen wieder raus.
Kann man da auch noch mit Cash bezahlen?
Das weiß ich nicht.
Ich hab's nicht gemacht. Ich mach jetzt mal eine wilde Spekulation. Es kann durchaus sein, dass in Deutschland rechtlich gar nicht erlaubt ist, einen Laden zu betreiben, einen Einkaufsladen, der nicht das offizielle Zahlungsmittel, nämlich den Euro, annimmt. Sondern sagt, ich will nur noch Plastik. Das gibt es zum Beispiel in Schweden. Mein Lieblingsprovider in Schweden, so ein Drei-Laden, wenn du dahin gehst, eine SIM-Karte kaufst, oder ist ja nur so ein 100 oder so ein Auflade-Voucher für 100 Kronen, was der nicht ist, oder so was. Dann stehst du mit deinem Geldschein, sag ich, nee, no cash.
In Amsterdam hast du richtig, richtig viele Läden, wo das so ist.
Es könnte aber sein, dass, wie gesagt, wir anal fixierten Deutschen da eine tolle rechtliche Regelung haben noch aus dem Reichs- Tralala-Gesetz, die sagt, nein, du musst die offizielle Währung annehmen in Cash.
Die Währung nimmst du ja auch an.
Das offizielle Zahlungsmittel, den Zetteln und die Münzen und so. Da gibt es garantiert in Deutschland Regelungen, für die dir das vorschreiben, wenn du einen Laden betreibst. Wär mal interessant. Los, die Juristen unter den Zuhörern.
Genau. Ja, nächstes Thema. Talking about Bugs. Apple scheint es ja nicht mit der Uhr zu haben, ne?
Überhaupt nicht.
Also so Zeit.
Ich sag jetzt nicht das böse Wort mit K oder C, sonst tritt Tim wieder ab.
Lass dich nicht stören. Nein, lass dich nicht stören.
Wieso böse Wort? Ich hab alles gesagt zum Thema Kalender, was da zu sagen war. Und bevor mir noch irgendjemand eine iPhone ab einen tollen Kalender empfehlen will, mir geht's um die Mac. Und da hat sich die Situation nicht signifikant verbessert.
Bizzical, ich sag immer noch.
Bizzical ist der einzige, der zumindest mal wochenweise scrollen kann. Aber ich meine, wie wär's denn mal mit einer Geste zum soften Durchscrollen? Einfach mal so, schh, scrollen. Wie so in jedem Webbrowser seit Jahren.
Ich kann irgendwie mit Fingern scrollen beim Bizzical, aber mal gucken, ob er das auch soft genug macht. Oder ob das jetzt hier zu hibbelig ist.
Du kannst ja nicht mit der Geste scrollen.
Na wenn du schon, das war hibbelig. Wenn ihr das schon Synapsentechnisch...
Ich kann mit der falschen Geste, ich muss nach links und nach rechts schieben mit zwei Fingern, damit er hoch und runter scrollt. Das ist jetzt eher peinlich, aber vom Prinzip...
Und auch nicht soft, sondern er springt dann immer eine ganze Woche, sodass er immer wieder mit deinen Augen... Du kannst es aber umstellen in den Prefs auf eine Woche.
Das ist ja an sich, ja.
Aber das ist einfach keine...
Ich hab's nicht gesagt.
Ich wollte reden über diesen Do-Not-Disturb-Bug, was sicherlich gar nicht der Erwähnung wert ist wirklich. Trotzdem lustig, dass Apple so ein Problem hat mit Zeit. Vor allem...
Was ich viel schlimmer finde, ist, dass die bei ihren Millionen Mitarbeitern und so weiter und so fort, dass ich da keiner finde. Vor allen Dingen, nachdem sie jetzt schon x-mal auf die Nummer reingefallen sind, der jetzt mal schafft, auf seinem dreckes iPhone, mal nach Fertigstellung einer Software mal den Kalender 3 Monate vorzudrehen, um mal zu gucken, was passiert. Das ist mir einfach so unglaublich unverständlich, dass ihnen diese Dinger immer wieder durch die QA durchfallen. Das ist der eigentliche Skandal, dass du da mal ein Problem drin hast. Ich meine, die Begründung gibt's ja viele dafür, weil sie sagen, ja, diese Woche, das Jahresanfang, offizielle Jahresanfang oder die Frage, wann fängt die erste Woche eines Jahres an, war dieses Jahr besonders komplex, ja, bla bla bla, schön und gut, aber warum kriegen sie in ihrer scheiß QA nicht mal geregelt, ihre Uhr mal in drei Monaten oder sechs Monaten vorzudrehen?
Und danach noch nicht mal in der QA, also schon die Funktionen, die sagen ja, nein.
In den Unit-Tests, ja.
Durch die Unit-Tests hätte das alles auffallen müssen. Besonders pikant fand ich ja, dass sie ja genau in der Woche, wo sie diesen Bug mit Do Not Disturb hatten, dass sie dann diese Werbung geschaltet haben, die für diese Do Not Disturb Funktion geworben hat. Das fand ich wirklich geil.
Das war dann Murphy.
Ich fand aber auch so schön, dass sie irgendwie nur Läppisch dazu gesagt haben, ja, ja, das Problem, das fixt sich von alleine am 9. Januar. Am 7.
glaube ich.
Oder 7. Eine Woche später ist dann alles gut.
Das ist ja Kalenderwochen und Apple. Ich meine, dass sie überhaupt geschafft haben, in iCal mal Kalenderwochen-Anzeige einzubauen, jetzt in Version 10.8.
Was über das Dramatische? Ich glaube, internationalen Standards gehen da durcheinander, was eine Kalenderwoche ist.
Ich glaube, ich habe zur Version 10.3 mal einen Bug gefeilt, iCal keine Kalenderwochen anzeigen würde.
Nur 5 Releases gedauert, nur 6 Jahre.
Aber immerhin, sie haben mal anerkannt, dass sie da was kaputt gemacht haben.
Sie könnten auch mal anerkennen, dass sie am laufenden Meter was kaputt machen, was mir nämlich wirklich stinkt, was wir im Prinzip schon mal hatten, aber es ist neulich einfach mal wieder hochgekommen. Das ist so diese forcierte Obsoleszenz von Software bzw. von Geräten. Mit dem iPad hast du es ja vorhin schon mal so angedeutet. Man kauft sich so ein Gerät, dann updatet man das, dann kauft man sich Apps, noch ein paar Apps und alles, dann updatest du, dann kommt nochmal ein Software-Update für dein Betriebssystem, dann kommt Updates für deine Programme und irgendwann hören diese Programme auf zu funktionieren, wenn du sie immer updatest, weil sie dann irgendwann sagen, dass sie deine Betriebssystem-Versionen, die du gar nicht mehr verlassen kannst, einfach nicht mehr unterstützen.
Du kannst auch nicht zurückgehen.
Und du kannst auch nicht zurückgehen, es sei denn du hast von irgendwelchen alten Versionen jetzt Backup gemacht auf deinem Mac mit Time-Maschinen und iTunes und tralala und keiner versteht's. Aber so. Und dann führt das dann irgendwann dazu, dass einfach faktisch, wenn du keine Backups hast, du keine Chance mehr hast, dein Gerät überhaupt noch in Betrieb zu nehmen, mit der Funktionalität, die du bezahlt hast und die vielleicht vor einem Jahr noch wunderbar funktionieren und im Prinzip jetzt auch noch funktionieren würde, hättest du nicht diesen sinnlosen Update-Button gedrückt. Also nichts hindert dich daran, ein Update eines Programms zu laden, obwohl dieses Programm sagt, ich laufe gar nicht mehr unter deinem Betriebssystem. Das find ich irgendwie wirklich mega haarig.
Und das ist eine Low-Hanging-Food für die.
Ja, ich wundere mich, dass da noch nicht drauf eingehauen wurde.
Das Schlimme ist, als Software-Entwickler kannst du auch nichts machen. Also du kannst halt nur sagen, die nächste Version läuft jetzt unter dem alten Betriebssystem nicht mehr. Aber du kannst nicht sagen, okay, für die alte Version, die unter dem alten Betriebssystem noch lief, würde ich jetzt gerne noch einen kleinen Bug-Fix machen. Weil du hast ja schon eine Version rausgebracht, die nicht mehr unter dem Betriebssystem läuft.
Ja, aber ich glaube nicht.
Ja, und das ist, also...
Genau.
Ich meine, manche Hersteller machen es aber wahrscheinlich nicht nur aus diesem, oder nicht aus diesem Grunde, sondern machen es wahrscheinlich auch deswegen, weil sie nach ein paar Jahren Entwicklung doch gerne nochmal wieder ein bisschen Geld haben wollen. Das ist ja jetzt so der neue Trend. So ein paar Apps, die ich habe, die sind zum Beispiel One Password. Es gibt jetzt One Password 2. Oder zum Beispiel 4.
4 oder so.
Ja, weil sie keine andere Chance haben, das zu refinieren.
Oder jetzt nächste Woche, am 13. kommt iOutbank 2.
Gleiches Spiel.
Gleiches Spiel. Wo denn zumindest noch die Chance hast, dass du sagst, ok, auf den alten, diversen, meinem iPad 1 hab ich einen iOutbank 1. Und das bleibt da auch und läuft dann da auch. Dann läuft sie jedenfalls nicht so in diese Falle rein. Aber dadurch wird sich natürlich mittelfristig der Markt auch zerfleddern. Du wirst dann auch deinen Upstar voll haben mit tausend verschiedenen Versionen von einer und derselben Software. Oder eben nicht genau dieselbe, aber von einer und derselben Software-Title.
Ist ja auch Teil des Problems mit diesen keine bezahlten Updates im Apple Store und so.
Da warte ich übrigens noch drauf, wenn die noch mehr Applikationen machen, wird denn Apple auch wieder über ihren Review-Prozess wieder eine Spielregel diktieren und sagen, nein, du darfst kein iOutBank 3 machen. Weil damit unterläufst du unsere Regel. Ja, dass sie dann irgendwie, da warte ich noch drauf, dass sie damit ankommen. Momentan haben es jetzt nicht so viele Leute da gemacht, aber... Apple hat doch bisher auf alles, wo man sich irgendwie so ein bisschen gegen sie aufgelehnt hat oder versucht hat, sie auszutricksen, immer sofort mit einer neuen Spielregel für den Review-Prozess unterbunden und weg.
Aber trotzdem, der ganze Mechanismus von dem App Store läuft doch jetzt schon so, dass du eigentlich mit viel Aufwand ein neues Programm machst und dann nimmst du schön diese Gauss-Kurve mit, das wird jetzt ganz, ganz lange verkauft, und dann machst du noch ein, zwei, drei Point-Releases, um irgendwas zu fixen, und danach lässt es einfach rotten und machst das nächste Projekt. Also genau darauf, oder das ist der Effekt dessen, was passiert dadurch, dass der App-Store so funktioniert, wie er funktioniert. Du kannst halt nicht sagen, ich hab jetzt ein bezahltes Update, ich nehme jetzt meine User mit. Die, die, dass die halt auf die nächste Version updaten können, die kriegen für einen reduzierten Preis jetzt dieses Update, die können ihre Daten mitnehmen. Du hast ja schon allein das Problem, dass du die Daten nicht richtig mitgenommen bekommst, weil halt all diese Apps in ihren Containern vor sich hinsitzen.
Ich würde nur sagen, die iOutBank-Leute haben ja jetzt zu Weihnachten noch eine Release rausgetan. Wenn ihr Release Notes durchgelesen hast, ist da explizit das einzige größere Feature neben irgendwie ein, zwei meiner Bugfixes, dass sie sagen, wir bereiten irgendwas vor, dass du deine Daten nach iOutBank 2 migrieren kannst. Wir sind alle gespannt, ob und wie das funktioniert. Wir werden das ab nächsten Montag ausprobieren können. Aber die Leute versuchen halt wieder, irgendwelche Tricks mit irgendwelchen Haken und Ösen zu basteln, um halt eben diese Apple-Spielregeln noch wieder auszuhebeln.
Über iCloud kannst du das eigentlich ganz gut machen, weil du kannst halt mehrere Container anlegen. Diese Container können dann auch geschert sein zwischen dem Programm, aber eben nur über iCloud.
Da bin ich mir ziemlich sicher, dass sie das hinkriegen, weil diese Exportfunktion war bei iOutBank schon lange drin, weil sie ja auch in die Mac-Version hinein... Du kannst ja auch in die Mac-Version schon deinen Kram hinein exportieren.
Also, das ist ein Jammer-Tal, aber da haben wir auch schon drüber gejammert. Also das ist irgendwie...
Ja gut, aber ich wollte jetzt nochmal explizit unter diesem Aspekt... Also, dass das für Developer doof ist, darüber haben wir schon viel diskutiert. Ich habe mir einfach nur mal darüber Gedanken gemacht, dass es einfach wirklich so ist, deine Geräte rotten weg und nach drei Jahren ist das Gerät, für das du mal, was weiß ich, 900 Euro ausgegeben hast und für das du vielleicht dann noch 200 Euro an Ups ausgegeben hast. Es funktioniert einfach dann nicht mehr. Also funktioniert vielleicht noch maximal in dem Default Feature Set, wie das OS es dir bereitstellt. Also du kannst dann so webbrausen.
Mail lesen.
Ja, Mail lesen und diesen ganzen Kram. Aber es kann sein, dass alle deine Games, die du gekauft hast, das hier einfach nicht mehr funktionieren. So. Und keiner gibt dir das zurück.
Ja, aber die Games sind noch am unkritischsten, weil die sowieso nicht bloß updaten.
Doch, da gibt es auch, bei uns ist das auch so.
Der Punkt ist, es kann dir passieren und es passiert. Ich meine, ich verstehe, dass Ups natürlich auch dann nutzlos werden, wenn sie irgendein Backend brauchen und dieses Backend ist nicht mehr da. Das ist ein anderes Problem. Aber dass Apple nicht generell erstmal verhindern kann, dass Sachen installiert werden, dass sie sich nicht umscheren. Ich meine, hier geht es darum, dass Benutzer beschützt werden. Weil letzten Endes, wo bitte kann das Interesse daran liegen, so ein Gerät abzuwerten und dass du dann sozusagen gezwungen wirst, dir wieder was Neues zu kaufen, weil dir Apple einfach deine Käufe nimmt. Ich meine, in gewisser Hinsicht ist das auch, weiß ich nicht, jetzt werden wir immer die Juristen ganz praktisch, ich denke so in Richtung unlauteres Verhalten.
Warten wir einfach noch ein bisschen, bis diese iPad 1 nochmal durch ist, wenn jetzt die nächste Release von iOS 6 durchkommt, immer mehr Leute updaten. Also wenn sozusagen der Schmerz auf der iPad 1-Schiene steigt, dann warten wir einfach auf den Class Action Suit in den USA. Und dann werden sie sich der Sache annehmen.
Ich bin gespannt, ob der kommt, weil ich könnte mir auch genauso gut vorstellen, dass die ganzen iPad 1-User dann sagen, naja, das ist ein iPad 1, das ist ja auch... Da kann ich mich ja gar nicht mehr vor Freunden zeigen mit. Und ich kaufe mir jetzt einfach ein neues.
Deswegen glaube ich auch, beim iPad 1 wird es nicht passieren, weil das ist schon so Ware, die ist schon komplett weiterverkauft. Aber das iPad 2 ist da ein ganz anderes Target, weil das wird jetzt noch verkauft. Da gibt es riesige Zahlen. Und wenn die Plattform dann mal wegstirbt, dann wird es halt krass. Aber das findet ja im Prinzip mit den iPhones genauso statt. Also du kannst mit so einem iPhone 3G, das kannst du gar nicht mehr in Betrieb nehmen. Das ist vollkommen absurd.
Ja, aber bei den Telefonen ist es natürlich so, da sind die Leute sowieso auf einem 2-Jahres-Zyklus. Und du benutzt halt ein Telefon so intensiv, dass es nach zwei Jahren halt auch schon relativ abgekrabbelt ist. Und ein 4 oder 5 Jahre altes Telefon.
Ja, also es geht ja nicht darum, ob das normalerweise so ist, dass die Leute was kaufen. Ich kaufe das, ich habe da Geld für bezahlt und vor allem, mir geht es ja um die Software. Ich habe Geld in die Software investiert und diese Software wird mir quasi kaputt gemacht. Und ich habe keine Möglichkeit, das rückgängig zu machen. Es gibt keine Funktion, wo ich sagen kann, beschütze mich vor Updates, die mir die Software nehmen. Weil de facto ist das ja ein Löschen. Sie löschen meine Software. Es ist ja nicht so, da wird aktualisiert und du kommst bloß nicht damit klar und du hast den Button nicht gefunden. Sie geht dann nicht mehr, sie ist kaputt, sie wird zerstört. Also eigentlich nimmt mir Apple durch das Update die Funktion.
Ich verstehe, dass das kompliziert ist. Hattest du es schon mal, dass eine App geupdatet wurde und sie danach nicht mehr lief?
Nee, er hat ja immer neuere Geräte.
Ich hab ja hier noch so iPad 1 und da läuft schon das eine oder andere nicht.
Hast du das schon mal erlebt, dass die Software...
Weil es auf dem Gerät. Wenn du das über iTunes süngst und iTunes lädt einfach gnadenlos alle Updates runter und fragt nicht groß, welche Geräte du so hast.
Ja, das ist richtig. In deinem iTunes hast du dann immer die aktuelle Version.
Aber hast du es schon mal erlebt?
Aber hast du auch die aktuelle Version dann auf dem Device?
Hast du schon mal den Schmerz gespürt?
Weißt du, wenn du die App vom Gerät runterschmeißt und merkst hinterher, oh, ich hab in meinem iTunes aber nur noch eine, die ich nicht mehr neu installieren kann, dann ist es ja noch mal...
Dann sinkt es einfach drüber. Sie wissen ja, dass das falsch ist. Das steht ja im Store drin, steht ja in den Metadaten und trotzdem sinken sie das einfach drüber. Um dann festzustellen, dass die Version, die du drauf hast, für ein Arsch ist. Weißt du, hast du denn eine Leiche auf dem Gerät oder löschen sie dir runter vom Gerät?
Ich glaube, sie aktualisieren es nicht auf dem Gerät.
Das wär ja dann okay.
Bis es zu dem Zeitpunkt, wo du einen Restore machen musst.
Der Punkt ist, du machst einen Restore, installier mal alles neu. Da wird erstmal alles gelöscht. Dann wird ein neues OS drauf gemacht und dann holen sie dir die Apps.
Es gab doch auch Leute im Netz, die darüber geklagt haben, dass ihnen genau das passiert ist. Nicht durch einen Restore, aber durch irgendeinen Update-Prozess oder so, die sich eine App draufgeladen haben, die dann nicht mehr tut. Das ist sozusagen eine Leiche. Ich hab zum Beispiel auch noch eine Leiche drauf, auf meinem Telefon. Es gab früher mal so Wi-Fi-Scanner. Die sind ja jetzt seit einiger Zeit verboten. Das ist noch aus der iOS-4-Zeit oder so. Der liegt hier immer noch drauf. Ich hab's jetzt Spaß darauf gelassen, weil es nicht viel Platz braucht. Wenn die anklicken, passiert einfach nichts. Nichts.
Ist vielleicht die API weggefallen, die das Ding benutzt hat.
Ich glaube, da hatte nie eine ordentliche API dafür.
Nee, eben. Es waren ja eher Venom-Private-APIs.
Wo ich aber gerade da bin, bei Wi-Fi-Scanner und Apps. Ich will jetzt gerade mal ganz kurz noch einen kleinen Werbeplot einwerfen, wenn ich darf. Ich hab nämlich jetzt gerade erst vor ein paar Tagen die geile App entdeckt, für alle Leute, die in irgendeiner Form einen Datenlimit haben. Entweder auf ihrem WLAN oder eben auch auf 3G oder 4G.
Datenlimit auf WLAN?
Es gibt manche Leute, die haben zum Beispiel ihr WLAN zuhause, was hinter einem LTE-Router hängt und da ist eben auch noch so ein 4G-Sendeschluss. Diese App heißt Radio Opt Traffic Monitor mit Speedtest. Ich kann leider keinen Link posten, weil wenn ich einen Link poste, ist es ein Link in den amerikanischen Apps, da könnte alle nichts anfangen, aber ihr könnt gerne gucken. Aber ich benutze den amerikanischen App Store. Traffic Monitor with Speedtest kommt von einer deutschen Firma Radio Opt. Ja, aber wieso? Poste jetzt einfach mal den Link.
Eigentlich ist der Link, das ist egal.
Ich kriege immer wieder Links für den deutschen App Store, den ich nicht anklicken kann.
Da gibt es ja eine Webseite als erstes, den iTunes Preview, da kann man sich ja das erstmal angucken.
Das Ding ist ziemlich geil. Also es hat, erstens zählt es dir nicht nur deine Datenstumpf mit, sondern auch an welchem Tag, wie viel, wenn du willst auch wo, in welchem Modus, wie 3G, lalalalapipapo, hat eine der vernünftigsten und wenigst klattersten Speedtest-Dinger, die gut funktionieren, dass sie auch gleich sagt, hier funktioniert dein Netz so und so und so gut. Du kannst deine Limits einstellen, kannst also sagen 500 MB im Monat ab dem ersten oder mein Billing-Cycle fängt am fünften an oder so was und dann rechnet der alles schön mit. Und ist eine ziemlich schnuffige Sache und hat nebenbei auch noch eine Diagnose-Funktion.
Woher weiß er denn, wie viel ich jetzt schon verbraucht habe?
Der liest die Betriebssystemzähler aus. Deswegen sagen sie zum Beispiel, also irgendwie das Ding refresht dich von alleine, aber sie sagen, wenn du zum Beispiel vorhast, dein Gerät mal abzuschalten, sollst du vorher noch mal kurz die abstarten. Weil wenn du es mal richtig ausmachst, ich mache mein iPhone nie aus, ich zeig dir das auch an, mein Ding ist jetzt irgendwie 50 Tage an oder so, nein 36 Tage. Aber wenn du es mal richtig ausmachst, dann stehen die Betriebssystemzähler wieder auf Null, deswegen sollst du vorher noch mal diese ab kurz starten, dass du sich das merkst. Und die hat auch eine schöne Systeminfo-Funktion, wo sie die Speichernutzung anzeigt, die Auslastung der CPUs und all möglichen anderen Quatsch und so. Und diese ab ist umsonst. Für umsonst und mit, aber funktioniert ziemlich gut, finde ich. Sehr sexy gemacht. Einziger Kritikpunkt, der muss natürlich jetzt bei mir kommen, auf dass der Chat aufstöhne. Sie zeigen dir zum Beispiel auch deine IP-Adressen an, die du hast im WLAN und im 3G und so. Aber sie zeigen dir nicht deine IPv6-Adresse an. Die du hast.
Warum wusste ich, dass das kommen würde?
Warum wusste er, deswegen sage ich, ich habe dir schon die Vorrede gehalten.
Also die Radio Opt Gmb heißt unter anderem auch noch die Computer-Bild-Netztest-Applikation gebaut. Das ist ja der Wahnsinn.
Also ich empfehle es euch, da das Ding umsonst ist, tut man sich nicht weh damit, wenn man sich die mal drauf tut. Ich finde sie sehr schnuckelig, ist auch recht schön gemacht.
Ja, also Radio Opt Leute, hört euch den Clemens an, macht da mal IPv6 mit rein.
Genau, bitte.
Das ist so schlimm, finde ich das jetzt nicht.
Also gerade, wenn du diese anderen Speedtest-Dinge anguckst, die sehen immer aus wie aus einem chinesischen Store, so bunt und neon und blink und tralala und das finde ich fürchterlich.
Ist ja alles nicht so, also mit der App kann ich so einigermaßen leben. Ästhetisch gesehen. Übrigens, zum Thema Ästhetik und weil ja unsere letzte Folge Pirate Match hieß, war das die letzte? Da hat mir einer auf Twitter einen Link zu einer Webseite gegeben, die heißt movies.io. Kennste die schon?
Webseite movies.io?
Mach mal einen Browser auf. Da saß ich ja so davor und musste so ein bisschen schmunzeln, weil wir wissen ja alle, Pirate Bay hat sich jetzt lange nicht mehr so verändert vom Gewand her. Jetzt such mal irgendwie, welchen Film hier, ob es schon irgendwie Groundhog Day ist, dann klick dir nochmal an. So, und dann gibt es hier jetzt also IMDB-Rating. Man kann auch gleich so ein bisschen, so sie haben auch Sprache auswählen.
Ich hätt ihn gerne in Deutsch, ja.
Krasses Scheiße!
Ja, also es ist Jetzt krieg ich tatsächlich auch den Titel in Deutsch und alles. Ja, ich weiß jetzt nicht, kriegst du ja die Subtitel, das ist irgendwie verified, es gibt external resources, manchmal, wenn es den Film halt auch auf Netflix gibt, dann kriegst du auch einen Link auf den Film bei Netflix.
Schön finde ich aber auch den Watch-Trailer-Button.
Also das war jetzt nochmal so ein anderes Level von User-Interface. Und ich brauche jetzt mal ein Movie.
Wir müssen hier in dem Faxgerät stehen und warten, wie die Sees and Desist-Order hier von den Filmbodereien rauscht.
Faxgerät?
Achtung, da kommt gleich das nächste Stichwort. Und zwar auch jetzt aus ganz aktuellem Anlass. Also ich mache da diesen Kurs an der UDK, und da erkläre ich den Kunststudenten das Internet. Und ein Thema ist auch File-Sharing.
Wie heißt denn der Kurs?
Der heißt gerade The Hitchhiker's Guide to the Internet. Dann habe ich in der File-Sharing-Episode meiner Vorlesung sozusagen denen mal erklärt, was passiert, wenn so ein Brief kommt. Und die Einschläge in meinem Freundeskreis, die kommen gerade auch so näher, so mit Abmahnung. Und auch für Sachen, die sie nicht runtergeladen haben. Das Wichtigste für alle, die das noch nicht wissen, wenn ihr so ein Brief kommt, nicht unterschreiben, sondern sucht euch einen netten Anwalt, der schon ein Standardverfahren hat, wo ihr vielleicht im schlimmsten Fall 150 Euro für den Anwalt bezahlt und ihr aber sämtliche Forderungen los seid. Zum Beispiel eine Studentin hat einen Abmahnbrief für einen angeblich heruntergeladenen Lana Del Rey Song für 5000 Euro bekommen. Und ich hatte damals in der Vorlesung gesagt, weil der Udo Vetter mal getwittert hatte, dass sie so ein Standardverfahren da schon haben. Und hat das quasi so angeboten, hatte ich denen gesagt, hier Udo Vetter. Und den hat sie wohl einfach angeschrieben, zum Beispiel meinte hier Hilfe. Der hat dann Standardverfahren aufgefahren.
Wenn die scheiß Abmahnanmeldte Standardverfahren haben, dann darf man bitteschön auch auf der Gegenbatterie Standardverfahren auffahren.
Das Standardverfahren besteht da drin, dass man diese, ich mach das nicht mehr, Erklärung, tatsächlich zurückschickt, aber modifiziert an ein paar entscheidenden Stellen, die sich im Wesentlichen glaube ich zusammenfassen lässt mit, ja, ich tue genau, lade genau exakt diese eine Datei nie wieder herunter.
Nee, ja, das ist auf jeden Fall so. Das Ding ist, wenn man diesen Brief unterschreibt, dann ist das eine Schuldeingeständnis und im allerschlimmsten Fall kann man da so richtig, also ich weiß nicht, ob man dann sogar vorbestraft sein kann, aber dieses Schuld-
Nee, nee, nee, im Moment. Ziemlich rechtliche Verfahren.
Aber dieses Schuld-Eingeständnis ist trotzdem richtig schlecht für die eigene Position. Und wenn sie diesen Brief zurückschreiben, dann nehmen sie sozusagen alle Auslegungsformeln raus, die irgendeine Art von Schuld-Eingeständnis sind. Also in dem Sinne, ich hab das noch nie runtergeladen, ich verspreche ihnen auch, dass ich es garantiert nie runterladen werde. Statt irgendwie, ja, ich hab's runtergeladen, ich mach's nie wieder.
Übrigens, weil du gerade sagst, Brief modifiziert zurückschicken. Habt ihr die Story mitgekriegt von dem Anwalt, der einen dieser dämlichen Adressbuch-Verlage, die der irgendwie ungefragt, diese Zettel zu schicken, sagen, hier in unserem tollen Business-Verzeichnis 2012, nehmen wir sie auf, schon alle fertig ausgefüllt, musst nur unterschreiben, wenn du sie zurückschickst, dann kriegst du einen Eintrag in einem Branchenbuch, wann nie jemand liest, was aber 500 Euro im Jahr kostet. Und der Typ hat diese Schreiben genommen, hat es modifiziert, hat reingeschrieben, ja für die Aufnahme meiner Daten in ihr Verzeichnis zahlen sie mir lalala. Und hat ihn zurückgeschickt, und sie haben ihn eingetragen, und er hat ihnen Rechnung geschickt. Und er hat es durchgesetzt, vor Gericht. So geil, das fand ich echt geil. Die Leute, die darauf setzen, dass die Leute das nicht lesen, haben sozusagen das Return Paper nicht gelesen und haben es einfach eingehackt und ihn in ihr Verzeichnis aufgenommen und er hat ihnen Rechnung gestellt.
Das ist eine schöne Nummer.
Ja und ich meine, dass mit diesen Abmahnungsschreiben läuft am Ende genauso, wenn ihr euch, um denen es vielleicht kurz zu Ende zu führen, wenn ihr damit halt oder irgendwelche Freunde, verbreitet die Kunde diese Briefe nicht zu unserschreiben, sich zu kümmern, selber zu googeln oder zum Anwalt zu gehen. Erfolg durch Penetrans, irgendwann haben die dann auch keinen Bock mehr drauf.
Ja, es ist auf einmal auch so, deren Modell basiert darauf, dass sie das massenhaft rausschicken und dass dann in diesen Massen einfach 1% Dove sind und aus 1% Doven können sie das wunderbar refinanzieren. Und dadurch, dass sie das aber so massenhaft machen, können sie sich eigentlich effektiv, also es ist nicht so, dass sie dann noch groß drauf eingehen, sondern gerade da, wo sie Widerstand kriegen, das ist das letzte, wo sie jetzt noch viel Energie reinstecken. Eher noch in die, die sich nicht melden, dass sie noch mal einen Brief schicken usw. Aber in dem Moment, wo man erstmal so, ja was willst du, erklär mir erstmal ganz genau die Beweislage und beweisen sie mir, genau das ist nämlich auch so ein Punkt, beweisen sie mir, dass sie überhaupt zuständig sind, die Rechte dafür zu vertreten, dann müssten die nämlich im Prinzip erstmal eine lange Dokumentenkette nachweisen, dass sie auch wirklich jetzt diejenigen sind und das ist ja auch häufig nicht so. Es gibt da auch durchaus Abmannanwälte, die sich da einfach mal auf Sachen stürzen, mit denen sie eigentlich gar nichts zu tun haben. Also guter Hinweis, das ist etwas, das muss man definitiv betonen.
Vor allen Dingen eben, weil man diese Schreiben halt auch für Sachen kriegt, die man halt vielleicht selber gar nicht mal runtergeladen hat. Ob das jetzt in einem offenen WLAN war, oder weil halt einer der bitteren Trecker halt random IPs in die Peer-Liste tut, um halt eben diese plausible deniability auch sowieso herzustellen, muss man halt Bescheid wissen. Und ihr da draußen mit ein bisschen mehr Technikverständnis als zum Beispiel die Studenten, wenn sie bei mir das erste Mal im Kurs sitzen, seid dafür verantwortlich, die Kunden in die Welt hinaus zu tragen.
Ja, habe ich witzigerweise bei Udo Vetter auch gefunden, dieses Ding mit dem umgedrehten Spieß. Hau ich mal in den Chat. 500, Quitsch, was steht da irgendwie? Für die Erlaubnis, unsere genannten Firmendaten unter Gewerbeauskunft zentrale.de veröffentlicht zu dürfen, einschließlich der Verlinkung auf unsere Homepage erhalten wir von der GWE GmbH eine Vergütung von jährlich inklusive Umsatzsteuer 569.06. Die Berechnung erfolgt einmal pro Jahr im Voraus. Der Adressbuchverlag nahm die Daten der Anwaltskanzlei prompt in seinen Register auf, verweigert aber bislang die Vergütung. Aber ich glaube, die haben die jetzt irgendwie auch verklagt und hin und her das irgendwie... Auch noch jährlich? Machen sie ja andersrum auch so. Die haben halt den Text marginal modifiziert und das so zurückgeschickt.
Ich hab übrigens noch so ein bisschen Sachen so in meiner Kramkiste noch so für, wir steuern jetzt sehr langsam so auf die vier Stunden zu und dann kommen wir ja so vielleicht in die Kram-Ecke noch ein bisschen. Soll ich nochmal? Ich hab noch wat.
Themen haben wir ja sowieso noch einige.
Wir machen einfach so eine kleine Kramkisten-Session.
Wir haben nicht mal in der Hack- und Bastel-Ecke gelandet.
Ah, das kommt auch noch. Zum Thema Bitcoin, nur zwei, weil Denis ist ja nicht da, der ist zwar im Chat, aber jetzt nur mal zwei kurze Einwürfe. Und zwar... coinbase.com habe ich kürzlich gefunden, das gibt es auch schon länger, das ist ein Y-Combinator-Start-up. Und... Coinbase ist... Also deren Konzept ist sozusagen Your Hosted Bitcoin Wallet. Das heißt, du hast deine Wallet auf so einem Web-Service. Und der Trick dabei ist, dass du in dem Moment keinen Native Client mehr auf deinem Mobile-Phone brauchst, um irgendwo zu bezahlen. Das heißt, wenn du in Room 77 gehst und willst mit Bitcoins bezahlen, musstest du ja jetzt deinen Laptop mit schleppen, weil es gibt keine Bitcoin-Wallet auf dem iPhone. Und die, die es auf Android gibt, die weiß nicht, ob man die benutzen will. Das heißt, sie machen sozusagen noch ein Layer dazwischen. Du benutzt diesen Web-Service. Da liegen deine Bitcoins quasi rum. Was kann da schon schiefgehen? Ich pack meine Wallet in die Cloud.
Was kann da schon schiefgehen?
Egal. Erstmal so als Konzept. Es ist da halt Bewegung drin. Du kannst halt auch da, so glaube ich, bei denen auch recht einfach Bitcoins bekommen. Das heißt, du kannst sozusagen deine Kreditkartendaten oder was auch immer es da halt gibt, hinterlegen und sagst, ich brauche jetzt irgendwie mal 20 Bitcoins um bei Silk Mode oder woanders irgendwelche Sachen zu kaufen. Das heißt, so dieses Problem überhaupt erst mal eine Marke zu finden, die man jetzt vertrauenswürdig findet, und dieser ganze Hässel mit irgendwie, ja ich überweise jetzt Geld und dann irgendwann kommen die Bitcoins. Also es geht sozusagen schon mal noch mal eine etwas dynamische Richtung und sie haben halt Merchant Tools, wie sie es hier nennen. Das heißt, sie haben dann sozusagen schon vorgefertigte Widgets oder APs oder Frontends, um halt, wenn du einen Web-Store hast oder so, einfach zu sagen, hier pay with Bitcoin. Das heißt, du hast sozusagen auch die andere Seite. Und ich werfe das jetzt wie gesagt nochmal kurz in den Raum, könnt ihr euch ja mal selber angucken. Und der zweite Link zum Thema Bitcoin ist bitpay.com. Und bitpay.com, die sind auch ein Startup, die haben gerade irgendwie 500.000 Dollar Investment gerade eingesandt, so zum Loslegen. Und die wollen sozusagen das PayPal in Bitcoin sein.
In welchem Chat hast du jetzt gerade die Links gepostet?
Ich hab's erstmal in den Raum gepostet.
Ich hab's erstmal in den Raum gepostet, aber hier, Bitch. Bitpay ist das eine und Coinbase, ich meine die Namen, die sind jetzt auch wirklich trivial genug. Genau, und Bitpay sieht ein bisschen, ich weiß nicht, also die Seite sieht jetzt nicht so wahnsinnig geil aus, aber haben gerade auch so ein bisschen Presseecho bekommen, weil sie halt sozusagen dieses PayPal-Prinzip haben wollen. Sie sind halt sozusagen für alle Merchants genau der Richtige, sagen sie. Und das ist halt auch was wordpress.com benutzt, um ihre Bitcoin-Payments abzuwickeln. Deswegen ist das insofern relevant vielleicht. Tim erinnert sich ja bestimmt über diese hervorragende Nachricht. Also Bitpay, obwohl die Seite nicht so schön aussieht wie Coinbase, die sind wohl schon ein bisschen, die sind wohl schon ganz gut im Geschäft. Und Coinbase ist halt so ein Y-Combinator-Startup und die sind auch gerade nur in den US. Also da hatte ich ja auch getwittert, da gibt es noch so die Opportunity hier für Europäer, mal schnell so ein Samba-Brüder-Klon...
Die Icons. Schon mal gesehen vorhin?
So ein Samba-Brüder-Klon zu machen von Coinbase und dann später aufgekauft zu werden.
Ich verrate es nicht den Samba-Brüdern.
Ja, was auch immer. Ich finde das ehrlich gesagt nicht so schändlich. Wenn diese blöden US-Firmen es einfach verkacken und Europa einfach jetzt ignorieren, dann sehe ich da auch keinen Grund, warum das jetzt nicht jemand in Europa einfach kopieren sollte, auch wenn sie es vielleicht nicht ganz schamlos eins zu eins machen sollten, sondern vielleicht ein bisschen selber nachdenken könnten. Aber... Ich habe irgendwie halt keinen Bock mehr auf diese ganzen Kickstarter oder so einfach zu warten, bis die dann mal irgendwann sagen, ach ja, Europa. Also Europa hat mehr Einwohner als die scheiß USA, ja?
Du, das ist auch ein Thema, da könnte man uns auch mal eine halbe Sendung drüber unterhalten, auch gerade bei Apple oder sowas, was die maßlos immer aufregt.
Europa hat aber auch wirklich mehr unterschiedliche Märkte mit vollständig unterschiedlichen Steuersystemen.
Steuersysteme ist in den USA nicht uniform.
Ja, das stimmt allerdings.
Also mit Steuersystemen, da ist das Back of Earth dicker in den USA, als es hier jemals sein kann. Mit State und Local Tax und Federal Tax und County Tax und Ladentex und weiss ich nicht.
Ja, aber das bezieht sich im Wesentlichen nur auf die Umsatzsteuer, die du draufschlagen musst. Das erfasst du einmal, dann hasse das. Aber ich meine, hier sind einfach die Konzepte komplett anders. Also es ist schon...
Trotz aller Demen, trotzdem fühle ich mich als Europäer vernachlässigt von diesen Startups.
Ja, nicht bloß da. Also immer wieder.
Das war mein Handlungsstrang.
Ihr glaubt gar nicht, wie ich es vor Jahren mal gefeiert habe, als die gnadenlose, tolle Firma Apple das mal in die Bank gekriegt hat, herauszufinden, dass es Telefonemann auf dieser Welt gibt, die nicht 10-stellig sind. Das wäre schon eine Weile her, aber es ist trotzdem so ein...
Wo wir gerade bei Steuern sind?
Das ist ein schlimmer Thema. Also jetzt wirklich nur gute Nachrichten.
Ja, ich habe eine gute Nachricht für dich, weil...
Du bist von Elster Online befreit. Nein.
Nö, das ist nicht. Das finde ich auch ehrlich gesagt nicht so schlimm, weil die 5 Felder, die ich da ausfüllen muss, irgendwie alle 3 Monate...
Es geht nicht um die Felder. Es geht darum, dass die eine Technologie benutzen, die alle möglichen Leute jetzt alle wieder aus den Browsern ausbauen und so. Das wird immer dreckiger, das Zeug überhaupt an den Start zu kriegen.
Geschenkt. Aber Steuern gehen jetzt nicht weg, nur weil man sie scheiße findet. Man muss sie halt trotzdem irgendwie machen. Und einige von uns sind ja sicherlich auch irgendwie selbstständig, freiberuflich, irgendwie nicht, also alles aber nicht angestellt. Schön, weil man seine Millionen schon irgendwie umgesetzt hat, aber der Rest muss halt irgendwie noch kämpfen und ich hab halt dieses Problem, manche andere mögen dieses Problem auch haben. Und früher hab ich es halt gemacht wie alle Nerds. Ich hab einfach mich aufs Sofa gesetzt und hab mir gedacht, wenn ich das lange noch ignoriere, dann geht das bestimmt weg. Und ihr wisst, wie lange das funktioniert. So irgendwann tlopfen Menschen an deine Tür. So ein paar Jahre später geht das dann so richtig los. Also du kriegst natürlich Briefe, aber die macht man ja nicht auf.
So hart.
So die Gerichtsvollzieher und so, die kommen schon irgendwann.
Die sind ja auch sehr nett, muss ich sagen.
Echt, also das Finanzamt ist geil. Ich meine, du musst dich mal wirklich mit deinen Leuten...
Das ist der selbe Gerichtsvollzieher, der für dein Bezirk zuständig ist. Den kann sich der Kläger nicht ausruhen.
Aber mit dem Finanzamt kann man immer reden. Mit der Krankenkasse kannst du nie reden.
Da ist was dran. Genau, mit dem Finanzamt kann man immer reden. Also wer da irgendwie auch schon mal so ein bisschen Angst gehabt hat, das ist eher entspannt, mit dem Finanzamt zu reden, weil die freuen sich sehr, wenn du dich überhaupt meldest. Weil deren Problem ist Leute, die sich nie melden. Und die für sie permanente Arbeit bedeuten. Und wenn jemand irgendwie so halbwegs reuig auch so daherkommt und sagt, naja, irgendwie ist alles so schwierig und so, dann sind die schon mal sehr entgegenkommt. Steuerüberreiter können ja auch helfen, auch wenn sie Geld kosten. Aber der Schlüssel, das Problem eigentlich, sich komplett vom Hals zu halten, ist eine gewisse Ordnung einzuführen ins eigene Leben und doch wirklich mal das mit diesen Zetteln einfach anders zu machen, weil es einen einfach deutlich weniger beißt, wenn man sich da sofort drum kümmert, als drei Jahre später oder nie oder so. Dann habe ich dann vor ein paar Jahren das auch mal eingesehen und angefangen, ganz fleißig Tabellenkalkulationen zu benutzen und jeden Beleg da einzutragen. Und jedes Jahr kamen so ein paar Spalten dazu und so. Man baut sich da so seine Dinger zusammen und so. Naja, jetzt bin ich so an dem nächsten Schritt, wo ich feststelle, dass ich natürlich auch in meinen Tabellenkalkulationen diverse Fehler mache und es doch ganz sinnvoll wäre, mal etwas mehr sich von so einer Software abnehmen zu lassen, als nur das Eintragen von Zahlen in irgendwelche Kästchen.
Einmal mit Profis.
Einmal immer mit Profis, nur noch mit Profis. Aber dann so, ich kaufe mir einfach eine Buchhaltungssoftware. Und dann lädt man sich da irgendwas runter, startet das, guckt sich das zehn Minuten an. Und will gleich wieder weglaufen und vergisst das und macht nochmal, ja, mit Tabellenkalkulation und so weiter. Und so geht das dann irgendwie immer wieder hült her. Weil man weiß ja gar nicht, wie man jetzt wirklich so Buchhaltung und so weiter ist. Alles ganz furchtbar und die Sprache.
So designt, das hätte nicht jeder wissen darf.
Und jetzt gibt es auch noch was dazwischen. Und das fand ich sehr interessant. Und ich muss jetzt ein bisschen mit Einschränkung sagen, ich hab so ein bisschen damit angefangen. Ich weiß noch nicht ganz genau, wie der Spaß ausgeht. Aber ein paar Sachen haben mich auf jeden Fall schon mal sehr positiv gestimmt. Es gibt da so eine Software für den Mac, die heißt Umsatz. Beziehungsweise Umsatz Pro.
Für die, die mehr Umsatz machen.
Also nee, für die, die nur noch mit Profis arbeiten wollen.
Umsatz Pro.
Könnt ihr mal über nachschlagen. umsatzprogramm.de und das ist auch von einem, ich glaube Michael heißt der, auch ein Selbstständiger sozusagen, der irgendwie Software macht und verkauft. Unter anderem eben diese Umsatz-Software. Er macht übrigens auch up.net Clients. Also das ist durchaus ganz vorne. Das ist jetzt hier nicht so die langweiler Abteilung des Internets, sondern hier wird es irgendwie ganz interessant. Und wenn ihr mal auf dieser Homepage seid, umsatzprogramm.de, dann findet ihr so unter den Icons der Programme rechts den Hinweis iBook Buchhaltung für Selbstständige. Das ist so geil! Das ist ein iBook, was der gerade schreibt. Das gibt es derzeit nur als Leseprobe. Ganz nach unten scrollen, wenn man den Ding verfolgt hat. Also umsatzprogramm.de/ibook. Und dann iBook Buchhaltung für Selbstständige, Leseprobe inklusive Fehler. Ladet euch das mal runter und liest einfach nur die ersten fünf Seiten und ihr wisst, alles wird gut. Das ist das coolste Dokument, was ich je zu der Software dazu bekommen habe, was im Prinzip diesen ganzen Prolog, so wie ich ihn auch gerade gemacht habe, auch nochmal so zusammenfasst.
Ineinfach. Buchhaltung für Selbstständige ineinfach.
Genau, ineinfach. Und er erklärt wirklich...
Eigenarsch-Absicherung. Der Hund hat meine Abrechnung gefressen.
Genau, also es ist, so zu sagen, also voll mit Begriffen, die man normalerweise in solchen Dokumenten nicht finden zu finden erwartet und es ist halt noch nicht fertig, aber es ist schon mal jetzt ganz hilfreich, wo vor allem wirklich so die ganzen grundlegenden Missverständnisse, die alle haben, einfach erstmal so erklärt werden. Was ist das eigentlich alles und so und Vorsteuer und Umsatzsteuer und was ist das Verhältnis und man merkt so richtig, es ist auch von Nerds, von Nerd für Nerds. Also sozusagen gleich der richtige Ansatz gefunden. Das hat mich jetzt extrem darin bestärkt, es mit dieser Software auch weiterhin zu probieren, denn diese Software ist so quasi zwischen der Tabellen- kalkulation und der Buchhaltungssoftware. Du machst damit nicht deine Buchhaltung, sondern du erfasst deine ganzen Belege, Ausgaben, Anlagen, Pipapo.
Damit es deinen Steuerberater bearbeitet.
Um es dann genau digital zum Steuerberater weiterzuladen.
Daher vorhin auch deine Anfrage auf Twitter mit Datefx oder Import.
Ja genau, das fand ich auf Twitter.
Das war auf ab.net.
Und der Menüeintrag, mit dem man diesen Daten- austausch macht, heißt Steuerberater beglücken. Die Software ist voll mit solchen Sachen. Also das ist wirklich großartig. Jedes User-Interface-Element hat zum Ausklappen noch die Hilfe, wo noch mal rechts dasselbe User-Interface-Element ist, mit Erklärung. Also wirklich besser als das habe ich das bisher noch nicht gesehen. Und wie gesagt, ich habe es jetzt noch nicht befüllt und noch keinem Stresstest unterzogen, geschweige denn die Daten tatsächlich mal an einen Steuerberater gesendet.
Das steht jetzt für mich an.
Ja, ja, so was habe ich. So eine Steuerberaterin. Mal schauen, also im Prinzip könnte ich jetzt 2012 nochmal erfassen, weil ich habe es jetzt sozusagen in der Tabellenkalkulation, aber ich habe jetzt gerade 2011 durch und da waren dann eben noch so viele Kleinigkeiten dann doch wieder misslungen, weißt du. Irgendwie wahrscheinlich richtig ausgerechnet der übliche Scheiß, dass ich mir jetzt mal gedacht habe, ich muss da mal jetzt einen Schritt nach vorne gehen. Also wer dieses Problem hat, der mag sich das mal angucken, ob die Software was für euch ist, kann ich nicht beurteilen, aber zumindest dieses Buchhaltung für selbstständige Leseprobe kann ich schon mal sehr empfehlen, ist sehr unterhaltsam.
Zum Thema Erfassen kann ich auch was beitragen. Ich lebe ein relativ nomadisches Leben, das heißt bin mal häufiger hier und da und dort und ich habe jetzt keinen Bock, auch habe eine relativ kleine Wohnung, wo ich jetzt nicht so viele Akten onerstapeln will. Also habe ich mal vor ein paar Jahren angefangen, habe mir mal einen ordentlichen Dokumenten-Scanner zugelegt, also nicht den 20 Euro Canon-Scanner aus dem Media-Markt, sondern mal so ein Ding so von Fujitsu, Scan-Snap 1300 heißt der. Das ist so ein kleiner Tisch-Ding, der ist nur so groß, also schwer für die Hörer nachzuvollziehen, aber man legt so eine Bierflasche hin, eine größere, so ungefähr dieses Format, den klappst du ein bisschen aus. Der hat eine sehr schöne Mechanik, klein, leicht transportabel. Er scannt vorne und hinten gleichzeitig in einem Affenzahn.
Oh, Scan-Snap. Du scanst von hinten wie von vorn.
Genau. Die Software ist ziemlich gut, weil es ist halt nicht so eine billige Gammelsoftware, sondern du kannst deine Belege irgendwie reinschmeißen. Schräg, vorne, hinten, gedreht, auf den Kopf, seitlich, wie du willst. Er erfasst es, macht solche netten Späßchen, wie wenn du was mit so einem Marker, mit so einem blauen oder gelben Überstrich-Marker gemacht hast, dann macht er automatisch PDF-Keywords draus und so. Er erfasst das. OCR hat die Geschichte sehr, sehr ordentlich, erzeugt PDFs draus und die schmeiße ich einfach bei mir in meinen normalen Store rein. Ab da kommt dann mein Spotlight zum tragen. Das heißt, ich habe in der Hauptstadt, an das Originaldokument schmeiße ich nur eine Kiste chronologisch. Das funktioniert sehr gut, weil in der Regel will die Steuer für mir einmal im Jahr einen Zettel haben. Das weiß ich auch schon, das sind nämlich die von irgendwelchen Bankbestätigungen. Die wollen sie unbedingt im Original haben. Alles andere wollen sie nicht haben. Das heißt, wenn das einmal da drin ist, landet das Original in der Kiste, verschwindet in irgendeinem Schrank. Wenn die Kiste voll ist, schreibe ich drauf Januar 2011 bis Juni 2011 oder so und den Rest habe ich in meinem Spotlight drin und finde sofort, also ich habe vorhin zum Beispiel vorhin, als wir diese Samsung-Geschichte gesucht haben, habe ich einfach meine Cyberport-Rechnung, Samsung, zack, finde die, habe die alle da und schicke die übrigens auch so zum Steuerberater. Macht der auch OCR? Ja! Und richtig gut, vorn und hinten und tralala und so und so und scharf. Und wie gesagt, ich nehme die Dinger so und pack die zusammen, pack die dann in so einen Steuerordner und am Jahresende nehme ich diesen Ordner, ziehe den nach Apple-Mail, schicke den meinem Steuerberater.
Fertig. Und vergibst du dann auch irgendwelche Belegnummern und trägst die auch auf diese Originalzettel ein?
Ne, da ich ja in diesem Sinne dort nicht so eine Abrechnung, ich bin ja keine Selbstständiger oder sonst was, ich mach ja nur diese privaten Geschichten mit den üblichen Werbungskosten, tralala. Aber das mach ich mit meiner gesamten Post, weil ich einfach auch keinen Nerv habe, jede dusselige Schreiben von irgendeiner Behörde in irgendeinen anderen Ordner abzuheften oder sonst was. Wenn ich also wirklich mal ein Original brauche, weiß ich aufgrund der Datei, die ich ja habe, wo die ist zeitlich, findet sie in der richtigen Kiste und ich brauch wie gesagt einmal im Jahr oder zweimal im Jahr irgendein Original. Ansonsten arbeite ich nur noch auf diesen Dingern. Ich hab alles da drin, Kontauszüge, die man zum Beispiel noch auf Papier manchmal kriegt von bestimmten Buden, die dir das immer noch mal zuschicken oder sonst irgendwas und hab das alles sozusagen OCR als PDFs mit sozusagen OCR-Hintergrund. Das heißt, du kannst auf dem gescannten PDF auch schön Cut, also Copy machen und so, solche Geschichten, was sehr schön ist, wenn du so zum Beispiel lange Kontonummern abschneiden willst, kann dir das auch gerne mal zeigen, wie so was aussieht. Und den Rest macht Spotlight.
Scansnap, wie heißt das Teil?
Scansnap 1300. Es gibt jetzt, Fujitsu hat gerade vor drei, vier Tagen das Nachfolgemodell rausgebracht, der heißt, irgendetwas mit 500, der hat dann auch ein eigenes WLAN-Hinterface. Also dieser Scansnap hat nur ein USB 2. Ja, der hat richtig WLAN, tralala und so, Scansnap. Ne, suchen wir nach 500. Das ist jetzt das neue Modell. 500, MX oder NX oder sonst was heißt der?
Gibt noch einen in Deluxe.
Ja, die Deluxe ist dieselbe Hardware, da geben sie dir noch so eine Sortiersoftware mit dazu, aber als Sortiersoftware nehme ich entweder den Finder oder diesen, wie heißt der, diesen Pathfinder.
S500?
S500 oder IX, da gab es jetzt gerade diese Fressrelease, IX500. Der ist ein bisschen größer als das Club-Ding, der 1300er, hat aber dafür USB 3 und Wi-Fi-Schnittstelle und scannt 25 Dinger pro Minute. Das war zum Beispiel sehr interessant.
Wi-Fi-Schnittstelle heißt das, dass der dann unter OS X...
Ja, die haben richtig gute Mac-Software. Ja, aber du willst das schön OCR'd haben und die haben auch zum Beispiel eine Software dabei für die Leute, die immer noch Visitenkarten kriegen. Du schmeißt eine Visitenkarte in das Ding rein und das Ding macht dir einen VCF-File draus, die du sofort in dein anderes Buch einschmeißen kannst. Das kannst du mit der normalen Software von Apfel nicht. Was auch sehr gut ist, ist zum Beispiel, also das Ding ist mechanisch sehr ordentlich verarbeitet, ist wie gesagt kein Billiggerät, aber wenn sich trotzdem etwas verklemmt, weil zum Beispiel noch so eine Klammernadel drin ist oder sonst irgendwas. Die Software ist richtig gut gemacht, die tickt nicht aus und die sagt so halt, zeig dir, das ist das letzte, was ich noch gescannt habe, wo willst du weitermachen, klickst du die Seite an, sagst, die hab ich schon, die ist okay, die nächste schiebst du wieder rein, drückst du wieder auf den Knopf, geht's weiter. Also auch gerade diese Recovery-Handling nach einem Paperjam und so was, ist sehr, sehr gut gelöst. Den kleinen, den 1300er, der hat so eine Klappe, wenn du den aufklappst, startet sofort die ab und so weiter, das ist wirklich easy peasy. Das hab ich jetzt auch ein paar Leuten, so Freunden, die so eine kleine Druckerei haben in Potsdam, hab ich denen jetzt für ihren Business dort gegeben, die findet auch ganz sexy. Weil eben durch diese OCR-Funktion hast du deine ganze Post und deine Belege alle drin, findest die auch, kannst die schön zuordnen. Ich hab jetzt sogar mal angefangen für die Druckerei, Leute, so ein Feature zu machen, dass du dir über Apple-Skript da reinguckst, in die Dinger, du kannst ja in den Text des gescannten PDFs dann reingucken, sagen, wenn auf der ersten Seite, in der ersten Hälfte steht irgendwie das Wort Rechnung drin, dann schmeißt es in den Rechnungsordner oder so was. Solche Spähscan kannst du denn machen.
580 Euro.
Das ist der neue mit dem WLAN und dem USB 3. Der andere kostet 260 oder 250 Euro oder so weit, der 1300er. Ich kann noch mal gucken, ob ich hier in meiner Sammlung mal ein unverfängliches Dokument finde, dass man mal so sehen kann, wie die Scanqualität ist mit dem OCR drin.
Der 1300er ist ja auch viel kleiner, das ist ja richtig kompakt. Weißt du, es lohnt sich da so einen fetten iX500?
Ich erwähne es nur, weil jetzt gerade vor drei Tagen war erst diese Presse-Announcement.
Also WLAN finde ich ja geil. Wobei das hat man natürlich dann auch stationär irgendwie an so einem Rechner und bewegt man ja eh nicht. Reicht vielleicht das auch.
Hab ich jetzt hier was in meiner Inbox, was man mal so zur Verfügung stellen kann. Das vielleicht nicht. Und wie gesagt, in Kombination mit Spotlight auf dem Mac ist das eine echt sexy Angelegenheit. Du hast das in deinem Time Machine drin. Ich hab meine ganze Post sozusagen immer bei mir.
Kannst du auch gleich einen Briefkasten einbauen?
Ja, fast.
Kann die Software auch kopieren? Ich baue jetzt eine Kopie von dem Blatt.
Du kannst mit einem Mausklick hier laufen. Der ist jetzt natürlich grau, weil er jetzt nicht läuft. Aber ich kann sagen, ich möchte es einzeln doppelseitig gescannt haben oder so. Er macht zumindest auch die Erkennung von alleine. Ich hab so ein Standard-Ding, wo er sagt, mach mal doppelseitig. Und er dreht wie gesagt von alleine. Und wenn eine Seite leer ist, lässt er es auch weg. Scan to folder, scan to email, scan to print. Scan to Word sogar. Das ist eine Funktion, wir machen wieder eine Word-Datei draus, die funktioniert sogar. Scan to Excel hab ich noch nicht ausprobiert. Aber es war zum Beispiel eine große Hilfe. Vor anderthalb Jahren ist meine Mutter gestorben. Und als ich den Nachlass dort verwaltet habe, hab ich ihre Postkiste, die sie dort hatte, was sie so aus dem letzten Jahr hatte, einmal durch das Ding durchgejagt. Gnadenlos. Egal, was das war. Alle, jede Rechnung, lala, pipapo. Dann hab ich halt die Dinge einfach ausgewertet. Hab ich gesagt, ah, hier hat es ein Zeitschriftenabonnement, Cut and Paste, zack, Mail hin, verstorben, kündigen, zack, nächsten. Ratz, ratz, ratz. Das war wirklich eine echte Arbeitserleichterung auch. Also das Ding ist wirklich sehr schnuffig. Hab jetzt leider hier, was hab ich denn hier, sowas. Hier gibt es eine Rechnung zum Beispiel. Also wer mal, ich kann doch mal irgendwas, hier ein Vodafone-Infodok, ne, das kann ich leider auch nicht benutzen.
Du fixst mich da gerade an. Das Dove ist, dass dieser X500 ist nicht nur teuer, der sieht auch noch gut aus.
Tim, wir machen mal was, ich bringe es zum nächsten Mal, der Ding mal mit, der ist wirklich sehr klein und sehr portabel und dann jagst du einfach mal unten Quatsch da durch und guckst du dir das an. Ist ein Feature. Übrigens, für die Reverse-Richtung habe ich auch einen Dienst entdeckt, den ich auch gerne mal Leuten ans Herz leihen will, nämlich Online-Brief 24.
Hier, du darfst ihm nicht verraten, dass es hier eine Option gibt, Scan-to-Dropbox.
Ähm, aber, äh, ne, äh, die Reverse-Richtung, also ich schicke wieder was raus.
In der Software, oder was?
Ja.
Gibt's nen Button.
In dem Scanner.
In der Software.
Vom Scanner?
Nee, von der Software. Quick-Menü für Mac OS steht über dem Bild. Da gibt's einen Button, Scan-to-Dropbox.
Na gut, ich meine, da kann ich auch einfach den Dropbox...
Genau, so mache ich das nämlich auch.
Cool wäre, wenn der Scanner selber schon direkt WLANen, Internet und dann...
Das wäre natürlich knallend. Könnte er machen, über die Dropbox-RP, da einfach reinhämmern.
Dass du gar keinen Rechner mehr brauchst. Aber dann müsste ja auch die ganze OCR-Geschichte und so weiter in dem Teil laufen. Das ist wahrscheinlich etwas... Erklär noch mal diese Online-Briefgeschichte.
Online-Brief 24 ist andersrum. Wenn man jetzt einen Brief schreiben will, kann man sich den natürlich ausdrucken. Dazu brauchst du einen Drucker, dann brauchst du ein Kuvert und eine Briefmarke. Okay, die kann man sich auch drucken inzwischen von der Post. Aber es gibt einen Dienst, die machen das alles komplett. Den gibt es auch schon länger für Firmen, aber Online-Brief 24 macht das auch für Leute, die bloß einen Brief alle drei Monate schreiben. Du kannst dir ein Prepaid-Konto anlegen.
Nehmt nicht die Seite.
Sie geben dir sogar, wenn du da subscribst, irgendwie 10 Euro Gutham oder 3 Euro Gutham, die du dir erstmal verknallen kannst oder so.
Wir hätten das jetzt nicht erwähnen dürfen.
Wir haben sie jetzt geheißt. Mobile Mac haben wir sie jetzt. Das Nette ist, das ist halt so eine PC-Bude, für einen PC bieten sie dir eine Ab an.
Wir haben sie der Meta-Ebene gleich gemacht.
Für Windows bieten sie eine Software an, aber die Windows-Leute brauchen das auch. Wir Mac-Leute sind da cooler, weil wir können ja PDFs einfach so erzeugen. Wir brauchen ja nicht irgendwelche Plugins oder sowas dafür.
Wir können sie sogar anzeigen.
Du erzeugst ein PDF und SFTPs ziehen das einfach rein, mit CyberDuck oder was auch immer. Du kriegst einen Account bei denen, also einen SFTP-Server, da haust du das einfach rein und lädst das ab. Die einzige Bedingung ist, du musst an einer bestimmten Stelle auf der ersten Seite, wo das Fenster ist, von dem Brief, die Anschrift drin haben, weil die parsen sie ab. Die können sogar einschreiben, so verschicken. Du kannst doppelseitig drucken, du kannst in Farbe drucken oder wie auch immer. Das kannst du mit angeben, das sehen die an dem Dateinamen.
Wenn die Seite dann lädt.
Und dann ab dafür. Und das benutze ich auch schon eine ganze Weile, weil du kannst halt eben von überall einfach mal einen Brief schreiben. Das heißt, du druckst sozusagen in den Briefkasten deine Empfänger rein. Indem du einfach das PDF da abschmeißt.
Was kostet ein Brief?
Der Witz ist, das ist billiger, als wenn du selber druckst und ein Porto drauf machst. Zumindest bei den ersten drei Seiten oder so. Weil nämlich dadurch, dass die dir direkt an deinem Post-Verteil-Zentrum einliefern, kriegen die das Porto billiger und geben dir diesen Vorteil weiter. Das heißt, die zahlen jetzt nicht die 58 Cent oder wartet, jetzt kostet, da gab es gerade die Erhöhung. Was war das vorher 53, jetzt 58 oder? 55 und jetzt auf 58, oder? Genau.
Deswegen gibt es jetzt 3 Cent Briefmarken.
Genau, die zahlen nicht, ja, damit den upgrade. Das sind die Upgrade-Briefmarken. Die geben diesen Vorteil weiter. Sonst müsstest du ja auch noch Papier und einen Briefumschlag kaufen und so was. Und das auch immer dabei haben. Du lebst ja auch in der Bahn.
Ja, was ist jetzt der Preis für einen Brief?
Wenn die Seite laden würde, wirst du es sehen. Aber das ist günstiger, als wenn du es selber druckst. Was ist denn das?
Ein Business-Modell?
Das ist eine Druckerei, Letterei, oder so was. Die gehören dir, die machen das mit. Die nehmen halt die Marge zwischen dem, was sie dir abknöpfen und dem, was sie bei der Post abschmeißen müssen. Von denen ein paar Cent leben die. Und das Interessante ist, wie gesagt, diese Dienstart und Weise gibt's eigentlich schon seit Jahren, wurde aber bisher immer nur so Firmen angeboten oder Großkunden und das ist halt Watt, die machen das halt für Autonormalbürger. Hier oben steht nur 49,9 Cent Porto.
Also zwei Seiten, schwarz-weiß, einseitig, DIN A4 lang, Deutschland ohne Einschreiben. Sieht das richtig? 82 Cent.
Das ist aber denn teurer.
Ja, aber sie haben's gedruckt, eingetütet und die Briefmarke drauf gemacht und in den Briefkasten geschmissen. Dafür steh ich doch nicht mal vom Schreibtisch auf. Das erste, was ich machen muss, ist doch in den Schreibwarenladen gehen und Briefkuvere kaufen.
Und Briefmarken.
Dann muss ich zur Post gehen und Briefmarken kaufen.
Noch geiler sind immer diese Briefe, die ich in meinen Taschen finde, die ich vor drei Wochen einschmeißen wollte. Die ich immer dabei habe, falls ich mal in einem Briefkasten vorbeikomme.
Und du kannst sogar, habe ich sogar schon mal gemacht, letztes Jahr habe ich nämlich mal die Stadtverwaltung Potsdamer ordentlich einverpasst. Du kannst doch einschreiben, schicken darüber. Die geben dir, ich wäre sowas gerne machen möchte, ich habe mir dafür Pages, ich benutze nämlich Pages für so Briefe, habe ich mir mal so eine Vorlage gemacht, wo eben genau dieses Adressfeld schon justiert an der richtigen Stelle steckt und so. Und dann nehme ich mir das Ding, schreibe die Adresse da oben rein, den Text unten drunter. Und dann geht es sofort als PDF, mit CyberDuck Rinn bei denen und Drops ist gelutscht. Und tschüss. Finde ich eigentlich sehr sexy.
Wissen wir, wenn man das hoch lädt, dann machen die das auch gleich, man muss nicht irgendwo klicken.
Du kannst zugucken, bei CyberDuck schmeißt du rein, machst du noch 2-3 Mal Reload, dann ist es weg. Dann fischen die sofort wieder raus, dass du ein Einzelverbindungsnachweis hast, das heißt, du kannst da online gucken und die schicken dir auch einmal im Monat ein. Und das ist wirklich eine sehr sexy Geschichte, finde ich. Kein Lalalalaa, keine Mindestlutterung.
Unterliegt das der Vorratsdatenspeicherung eigentlich?
Genau, hier fragt gerade auch einer im Chat, wie sieht es denn mit dem Datenschutz aus?
Das fragt doch mal die Firma nicht mich, habe ich da Aktien bei denen oder was?
Du verschickst ja vielleicht, kriegsentscheidende Post.
Ich würde mal theoretisch jetzt als Profileihe mal sagen, dass da natürlich auch das Postgeheimnis gilt. Und benutz ich wie gesagt unterwegs eine sehr schöne Gelegenheit, einfach mal so Sachen, die so offiziell sind, Behördenquatsch oder sowas. Deswegen auch gerade die Einschreibfunktion.
Also Liebesbriefe würde ich nach wie vor mit Füller auf ordentlichen Büttenpapier und korrekten Umschlag verschicken.
Geschenkt. Parfümiert. Vielleicht haben die auch ein Bitt für parfümiert. Du musst nämlich in die Dateinamen reinquodieren. Linotype-Zapfino, fertig.
Oder du machst einfach einen Font aus deiner Handschrift, da gibt es ja auch Webseiten, und dann nimmst du gleich den Font. Nein, aus meiner Hand fällt das bestimmt nicht auf. Du weißt ja, es gibt richtig Unterschriftroboter. Für Leute, die viele Unterschriften zu machen haben, gibt es wirklich Unterschriftenroboter. Das sind Geräte, wo du deine Unterschrift sozusagen einmal reindigitalisierst, indem du sie durchführst. Ich weiß nicht ganz genau, wie das mechanisch ist, aber du rekordest sozusagen einmal deine Unterschrift, so wie du sie eben tatsächlich machst.
Jeder, der West Wing gesehen hat, weiß, dass zum Beispiel POTUS sowas benutzt. President of the United States. Da gibt es jemanden, musst du dir vorstellen, von dem Gänsefüßchen, wichtigsten Mann der Welt, gibt es so einen Unterschriftenautomaten, oder zwei, die da im weißen Haus rumstehen. Das ist sozusagen jemand so Iran, we declare war.
So viel zur Sicherheit von Unterschriften.
Die unterschriebenen Blankobriefe, da war doch auch irgendwann was bei uns.
Die Gnadendinger, das ist ja eine seiner Funktionen, die jemand macht. Werden wir übrigens auch wiedersehen, wenn Obama jetzt durch ist mit seinem zweiten Term, was zu sehen, am Ende, weil dann hat er eh nichts mehr zu verlieren, am Ende hauen sie alle noch mal so einen Stapel von Gnadendingern raus für ihre Parteifreunde, die wegen Steuervergehen oder sonst was eingebuchtet wurden. Das ist so ein traditioneller Ding der abtretenden Präsidenten. Aber wie gesagt, die machen das auch. Gnadenlos. Da gibt es dann schöne offizielle Spielregeln, wer diesen Automaten einsetzen darf. Aber...
So, jetzt haben wir schon Arke überzogen.
Ach, ich bin es nur so nebenbei. Ihr kennt diese Feature mit den Unterschriften in Preview? Also in Vorschau?
Ich weiß, dass es das gibt, aber benutzt habe ich das noch nicht.
Macht das mal, das wird dir gefallen. Selbst wenn du es hinterher wieder wegschmeißt. Er speichert sie ja verschlüsselt ab mit der Kit. Kennst du nicht? Mach mal dein Vorschau-Programm auf. Das hat ja diese Annotationsfunktion, das kennst du ja, wo du so in PDFs und so rummalen kannst. So, und dann gehst du mal oben zu diesen Werkzeugen, wo diese Annotationswerkzeuge sind.
Mit einem geöffneten PDF-Malz?
Mach mal Apfelkomma, also in Preferences. Da Signaturen. So, eigene Signatur erstellen. Jetzt sagen sie zu dir, du solltest bitte ein weißes Blatt Papier nehmen, darauf unterschreiben und das vor diese Kamerade halten. Mach das mal, muss ja nicht deine echte Signatur sein.
Ich hab kein weißes Blatt Papier.
Aber Tim hat eins. Das ist ein sehr...
Stiftig da bei deinem Bier. Ich mach das auch mal.
So, und dann hältst du das, schreibst jetzt mal... Die kannst du jetzt akzeptieren. Das heißt, du kannst sie abspeichern. Die wird verschlüsselt abgespeichert und der Key dafür in deiner Keychain abgelegt. So, und damit kannst du jetzt mit der Annotationsfunktion schön die PDFs, die dir irgendjemand zuschickt, unterschreiben und per Onlinebrief 24 gleich wieder rausjagen.
Wie klappt das hier mit dem Preview nicht?
Das funktioniert hier ja gnadellos. Also ich finde auch gerade diese Kontrastgeschichte super. Er macht nämlich in dem Moment sofort einen Snapshot, wo ihm der Kontrast gefällt und dann hast du da einen schönen...
Das hat hier irgendwie nur beim ersten Mal funktioniert und dann...
Du hast jetzt hier auch eine ziemlich blöde, weil hier von der Seite mit deiner Schreibtischlampe da reinleuchtet.
Nee, es hat dann nichts zu tun, denn er aktualisiert einfach gerade die... Die Kamera nicht.
You broke it again.
Ja, das ist halt der Tim-Bonus.
Das sind mal Bogoden.
Der findet halt die Erste schon so gut, dass er jetzt gar nicht mehr was Besseres will. Doch, jetzt hat er gerade was.
Ich muss wahrscheinlich etwas genauer auf der blauen Linie.
Das haben sie glaube ich schon mit Lion eingebaut oder so was, aber das ist ein echtes Feedback. Dass sie auch gleich dran gedacht haben, muss man ja sagen, für Amerikaner, die normalerweise nicht so Privacy konzentriert sind, dass sie das gleich verschlüsselt abspeichern und mit Keychain verbinden, ist schon mal eine schöne Nummer.
Ja, und wie mache ich die da jetzt drauf?
Indem du halt sozusagen, wenn du jetzt ein T-DF hast, oder so was, ein Note-Taste-Singlature, dann kannst du die nehmen, auch noch groß und klein ziehen und an die richtige Stelle tun und pfff hast du die da. Geht übrigens auch in Farbe. Glaub ich. Ich habe auch eine in blau, so in Kugelschreiberblau.
Wie kriege ich die jetzt hier drauf? Notiz?
Genau. Wählst du die aus?
Wie kriegt man die denn jetzt da drauf?
Das finde ich ja toll, dass ich der tiefst eingeweihtesten Mobile-Max-Runde hier nochmal so einen alten Gag nochmal.
Ich hatte irgendwie, ich weiß nicht ganz genau, ich glaube mein Bedarf war dafür relativ gering, aber deswegen habe ich es nie ausprobiert.
Aber nochmal, nimm das mal zusammen. Du scanst deine Post ein oder jemand scannte dir ein. Du kannst es ja auch machen, du bist auf Reisen, Verena jagt es einfach durch den Scanner, fertig. Zack, dein Steuerblatt. Du liest dir das durch, füllst es aus mit der Adoptionsfunktion, machst deine Unterschrift drunter und jagst gleich die Antwort per Online-Briech 24 wieder raus.
Das kennt der Chef noch selbst.
Oder so. Ja, aber das ist sozusagen...
Da muss ein kleiner Scanner mitgehen.
Das ist sozusagen Near Paperless Office. Near Paperless Office.
Das Paper entsteht woanders, aber die haben es auch verdient.
Ja, demnächst gibt es so Laserjet-Romantika, die irgendwie dann... Aber es muss doch auch nach Toner riechen, damit es irgendwie noch so ein bisschen wie früher ist.
Es muss dann noch die verschmierte Tinte drauf haben.
Ich würde Folgendes vorschlagen, weil wir schon so weit fortgeschritten sind. Wir könnten jetzt hier glaube ich noch stundenlang reden. Dass wir so ein bisschen die Hack- und Bastel-Projekte, die wir jetzt noch nicht hatten, aufs nächste Mal verschieben. Ich würde nur gerne noch zum Abschluss noch mal kurz die Microblogging-Landschaft noch mal kurz beleuchten, nämlich ab.net und Twitter. Twitter-Bericht bei Twitter sieht ja nach wie vor nicht so gut aus. Ich muss auch sagen, Twitter geht mittlerweile auch echt ganz schön auf den Geist. Zwar nicht so sehr wegen Twitter, sondern wegen dieser fortgesetzten Shitstorm-Kultur, die sich da irgendwie mittlerweile so breit gemacht hat, dass man das irgendwie alles schon gar nicht mehr lesen will. Okay, ich folge den falschen Leuten und so.
Ja, ich habe das ganz gut hinbekommen jetzt so mit meinem Filter. Also jetzt so langsam gefällt es mir wieder richtig gut.
Weil du so vielen Leuten entfolgt bist. Ja, das ist konsequent. Das muss man von Zeit zu Zeit mal machen. Die andere Variante ist up.net benutzen. Und wer das nicht verfolgt hat, bei up.net hat sich was getan. Und zwar, ich glaube noch vor Weihnachten hatten sie endlich ihre Messaging-RP-Release. Das heißt up.net kann jetzt auch private Nachrichten. Und das bedeutet, dass man jetzt eigentlich nur noch darauf warten muss, dass die Ups das auch alle integrieren. Das findet auch schon statt. Und zwar gibt es eine iPhone-App, die heißt Felix. Das ist auch so eine der populären. Du freust dich?
Ich benutze die sehr gerne.
Du benutzt Felix, genau. Ich habe mich jetzt deswegen, weil sie die ersten waren, die private Messages unterstützt haben, auch mal auf Felix eingeschossen. Und da sind ein paar Sachen auch besser als bei Netbot. Ein paar Sachen sind halt nicht so gut. Also zum Beispiel keine mehreren Accounts möglich.
Aber sie haben durch einen Trick diese Cross-Posting nach Twitter reingemacht.
Trick?
Ja, der Trick ist einfach, dass sie das nicht selber eingebaut haben in ihrer App. Das heißt, sie violaten nicht diese Twitter-Geschichte, sondern sie rufen einfach die in iOS eingebaute Share-with-Twitter-Funktion auf. Weil du darfst ja laut der Twitter-API- Vertrags-tralala, darfst ja keine abbauen, die sozusagen direkt die Twitter-API benutzt und eine andere API. Gleichzeitig. Und die Felix-Leute sagen, machen das nicht. Die benutzen keine Twitter-API, die benutzen die iOS-API, die sagt Share-with-Twitter.
Ich bin sowieso gefragt, ob das nicht eigentlich möglich sein müsste.
Das heißt, du kannst halt eben diese automatische Cross-Post machen.
Kriegst du da auch nochmal diesen View, dass du mit dieser Karte...
Wie mit der Karte?
Wenn du bei Twitter postest, kriegst du doch üblicherweise diese...
Dass sie dir dieses Ding da nochmal hinmalen. Du kannst ja mal ausprobieren. Kostet ja nichts, kostet ja kein Auto.
Du meinst, Dialog bevor man es dann abschickt sozusagen.
Den kannst du, glaube ich, nicht umgehen.
Ich vermeide ja Cross-Posting.
Ich auch, deswegen. Aber probieren wir es mal. Jetzt muss man das nochmal anmachen hier.
Es gibt auch so ein paar User-Interfaces, Sachen, die mir sehr gut gefallen. Bei Felix gibt es auch ein paar Sachen, die mir nicht so gut gefallen. Aber was zum Beispiel ganz nett ist, ist, dass bei den Posts, wenn man sie halt so in der Timeline hat, links das Icon ist von dem User. Da haben sie sich darauf geeinigt, den Rund zu machen. Okay, meinetwegen. Aber dann ist da auch gleich so ein Kontext-Menü drauf. Das heißt, wenn man auf das Avatar drauf klickt, kriegt man noch mal so ein personenbezogenes Menü versus einem tweetbezogenen Menü, was sie so wiederum nicht haben. Zumindest nicht so wie Netbot. Obwohl ich das eigentlich ganz geil finde. Also einmal so diesen Tweet anklicken und da drunter dann sozusagen die Kontrolle zu bekommen, was will ich damit machen, will ich retweeten etc. Gut, hier ist es so ähnlich nur, dass sie dann halt den ganzen Tweet, also sozusagen so ein Solo-Display-Modus haben und da kannst du dann immer noch alles machen. Naja, kann man so machen, kann man auch anders machen. Auf jeden Fall ist das eine ganz brauchbare App und die kann ich empfehlen. Und vor allem ist davon auszugehen, dass so in rascher Folge, so wie Apple dann eben die Updates durchlässt, bzw. auf anderen Plattformen ist es teilweise auch schon erfolgt. Da habe ich aber nicht ganz so den Überblick, wenn halt diese Private Messages jetzt integriert werden. Und die sind halt anders als bei Twitter in zweierlei Hinsicht. Erstens gibt es dieses Limit nicht, dass man nur Leuten, die einem folgen, Nachrichten schicken kann. Sondern bei ADN kann man einfach jedem erstmal Nachrichten schicken. Was cool ist, finde ich, auch für eine diskrete Kontaktaufnahme. Sonst ist das immer so albern mit, du musst mir jetzt mal folgen, ob ich dir eine schöne Nachricht schicken kann. Und irgendwie habe ich noch nie so den Eindruck gehabt, dass nämlich das bei Twitter groß für irgendwas beschützt. Abgesehen natürlich von der potenziellen Spam-Quelle, die man aber ab dort nicht befürchten muss, weil Spammer zahlen halt nicht für ihren Zugang. Zumindest nicht so viel. Das ist auf jeden Fall cool und man kann halt bei den privaten Nachrichten auch gleichzeitig an mehrere Leute schreiben. Das heißt, man kann eben gleich so geschlossene Benutzergruppen machen und wenn der Client einem das nett unterstützt, dann ist es eben auch cool über einen längeren Zeitraum mit N Leuten zu kommunizieren. Bei iMessage ist das ja auch so ein bisschen so ähnlich, aber hier eben innerhalb dieses Systems. Finde ich gut. Ansonsten ist glaube ich nicht so viel passiert, oder? Aber ich glaube, ich werde das jetzt mehr nutzen, weil ich das mehr nutzen werde.
Ja, bei mir ist noch so ein bisschen der...
Also vor dem Kongress war mein Default einfach auf Twitter, weil da war mir der Reach irgendwie wichtiger. Aber ich habe einfach festgestellt, dass ich eigentlich bestimmte Dinge genauso gut auf abdotnet fragen kann, wie auf Twitter auch. Da ist jetzt der Follower-Unterschied nicht mehr ganz so entscheidend. Wie viel hab ich denn überhaupt?
Jetzt wieder. Wer hat den längsten? Womit wir da beim Anfang der Sendung werden, wir brauchen hier gegen solche Diskussionen, brauchen wir jetzt hier eine Frau.
Unsere übliche Sprache oder was?
Na, das sowieso. Muss übrigens auch mal für die...
Du meinst, das hilft?
Wie die nicht sehenden Hörer mal, die müssten mal sehen, wie wir hier herum sitzen. Abhängen. Unrasiert.
Nackt. Ich trage Hemd.
Ich auch. Aber ich trage auch Bart.
Ich nicht.
Ich bin auch rasiert.
Nicht Bart.
Ich bin hier wohl aufgeräumt. Ich hab auch geputzt, bevor ihr gekommen seid.
Kannst du einmal erzählen, der keine Klampe anbutet.
Nun denn, ich glaube, mein Bier ist leer. Jetzt verließen sie Ihnen, die Biere sind leer und das Shownotes-Team kippt gleich um. Die haben schon diskutiert.
Sie sind jetzt an ihrem Maximum Fall-Size angekommen.
Ja, also im Shownotes-Bereich, da tut sich ja eine Menge. Ich bin gespannt, die Qualität der Shownotes wird weiter zunehmen, weil sich da einiges tut. Da gibt es jetzt spezielle Ether-Pads mit irgendwie Zeiterfassung und Pipapo. Alles ganz modern.
Ganz modern.
Wir loben das.
Nächstes Mal, Denis. Bist du noch dran, Denis? Sag doch mal was. Denis.
Ist schon wieder eingeschlafen.
Ist ja eingeschlafen.
Er ist schon eingeschlafen.
Der Vedert. Vedern at home.
Da ist er.
Klar, Denis. Nächstes Mal bist du wieder dabei. Schlaf dich gut aus. Wird gesund.
Er spielt jetzt bestimmt voll der Vorkraft.
Alter Frische. Genau, so. Ansonsten nehmen wir hier Gastbewerbung an.
Und nur Frauen und Eichhörnchen. Ich denke, ich hänge dich die ganze Zeit wahrscheinlich wenn ich das nimm. Ich schaffe, dass es mein komischer iChat-Klient der herumpinkt.
Das kriegen wir alles noch hin.
Genau. Na dann sagen wir einfach mal.
Wir haben gar nicht über das Ubuntu-Formen geredet, aber können wir nächstes Mal machen.
Wir haben ja die ganze Bastel-Ecke noch.
Ja, ich hab hier noch Themen, da häng ich mir alles für nächstes Mal auf.
So ein bisschen so eine 3-Wochen-Pause, was einem das doch geben kann.
Genau, aber wir machen ja ganz brav in zwei Wochen weiter und dann geht's hier weiter mit dem Themenfeuerwerk. So, jetzt haben wir aber auch genug gesagt. Eichhörnchen, bis bald. Wir sagen Tschüss, Winke, Winke.
Winke.
Nacht.
Vielen Dank für das Wissen und wir sehen uns bald!